ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG.
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HELLO.
HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN'S [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
INNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I'M BURKE.
BY KOWSKI.
WIENER [inaudible]
WELL.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WE WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR ROTH.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
THE ACTOR DALE E. TURNER SAYS.
DREAMS ARE RENEWABLE.
NO MATTER WHAT OUR AGE OR
CONDITION.
THERE ARE STILL UNTAPPED
POSSIBILITIES WITHIN US.
AND NEW BEAUTY WAITING TO BE
BORN.
GRACIOUS GOD.
TODAY WE THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
OF OUR SENATE AS THEY BRING THE
DREAMS AND HOPES OF MANY TO A
WORKABLE REALITY.
MAY THEY CONTINUED TO DISCOVER
UNTAPPED POSSIBILITIES THROUGH
THEIR CONVERSATION AND
COLLABORATION.
MAY THEY NURTURED THEIR DREAMS
TO FULFILL MEN'S THROUGH
PATIENTS EXPLORATION.
AND COURAGEOUS DISCOVERY.
MAY THEY NOT GROW TIRED OF THEIR
EFFORTS TO BRING PEACE HEALTH
AND PROSPERITY. TO THE
CONSTITUENTS WHOM THEY SERVE
AMEN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
YEAH. FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH REALLY TELLS US
CRAWL THEY CONSIST OF THANK.
SO HOW MANY DO WE HAVE NOW
[inaudible]
FORTY FIVE ALL
RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES.
WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED.
AT THIS POINT WITH PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WE MOVE ON TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR SHALL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
SHE NONE.
WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED.
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
SECOND READING FILE.
SENATE BILL EIGHTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS FORTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS. ONE FORTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO TEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO SIXTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS SECOND READING WILL
BE DEEMED COMPLETED [inaudible]
AND READ.
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
[inaudible]
SENATOR WILK.
IS NOT ON THE FLOOR WE WILL COME
BACK TO THE SENATE -- TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
MOVING ON THEN TO THE SENATE
THIRD READING COLLEAGUES WE HAVE.
A NUMBER OF BILLS TO TRY TO GET
TO TODAY.
AND IF WE COULD.
PART WE WILL GO BACK.
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
SENATOR WILK.
POLITICS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE IF YOU WOULD GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR WILK.
ON GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
SENATOR WILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF TRAINED --
TO TO THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION MR TELE SERVED ON THE
COMMISSION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN HE'S A FORMER
CAPTAIN IN THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY EIGHTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT I WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM.
CHANG.
I DON.
I DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON.
AYE JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LIKE [inaudible]
I BROWN [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
HI COVER ADAM.
BECAUSE I ADAM [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WHO ISN'T HERE?
BUT IS IT.
IS IT IS ALL RIGHT. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED [inaudible]
SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MANAGE RESIDENTS MY
COLLEAGUE SO IT'S IF EVERYONE
COULD PLEASE TAKE THEIR SEATS OR
MOVE THEIR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
CENTER WILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
APPRECIATE THAT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX IS A
CONFIRMATION ADRIA JINKINS JONES
AS CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMANS
RESOURCES.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MISS
JENKINS JONES WAS CHIEF OF KELLY
TO OUR SELECTION DIVISION.
AND SHE SPENT THE PREVIOUS
TWENTY FOUR YEARS SERVING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN VARIOUS
CAPACITIES.
INCLUDING CHIEF HUMAN RESOURCES
AND CHIEF -- RECRUITMENT AND
SELECTION SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY
EIGHTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME
TOURNEY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS APPOINTMENT.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
APPOINTMENTS TO THE GOVERNOR.
WELL.
HI FOR AGES.
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
THE PLYMOUTH.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AND BY -- TADO.
HI JACKSON.
I JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MARROW.
HI NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
HI ROB NO THERE'S A COUPLE BY
RUBIO QUESTION MARKS THEY SAID
I'VE SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BATES.
WITH ABSTAINED I VICE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED.
MOVING ON NOW TO SENATE THIRD
READING.
SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR ALAN.
MISTER MISTER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS.
SENATOR ALLEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MEMBERS THANKS SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT -- THIS BILL REQUIRES
SIGNATURE GATHERS TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
WITH THE NAMES OF THE TOP THREE
FUNDERS OF AN INITIATIVE
CAMPAIGN AT A MOMENT WHEN THAT
DISCLOSURE IS CRUCIAL.
WHEN PHYSICAL PETITION IS PLACE
BEFORE VOTERS AND THEY'RE
DECIDING WHETHER TO SIGN IT? TO
GIVE YOU A CONTEXT -- IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE HAD THIRTY SEVEN
THIS IF THE QUALIFIED FOR
CIRCULATION THE PUBLIC TWELVE
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A NEAR RECORD
SEVENTEEN EMISSIONS APPEAR IN
THE GENERAL ELECTION BALLOT.
EVERY ONE OF THESE TWENTY NINE
PROPOSITIONS A QUALIFIED BY
SIGNATURE GATHERING DID SO I I
ONLY AFTER A MILLION DOLLARS OR
MORE WAS SPENT ON PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERING WITH VOTERS.
REALLY KNOWING WHO THOSE MINERS
WORK -- MEMBER TO MEMBER THAT WE
PASS TO DISCLOSE ACT WHICH
PROVIDE DISCLOSURE NOW FOR A
TELEVISION ADS.
WE NOW HAVE ALSO PROVED BUT
PASSED THE SOCIAL MEDIA DISCLOSE
ACT WHICH MAKES IT SO THAT ADDS
THAT ARE ONLINE -- THEY REALLY
TO POLITICAL MESSAGING IN
CAMPAIGNS THE THE TOP DONORS
HAVE TO BE DISCLOSED THEIR THIS
IS THE SAME THING HERE -- YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU GO TO THE MARKET
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO GET SOME
LETTUCE IS THE MILKER NOT FROM
SANTA MONICA SO WE LIKE TO BUY.
HE WON FERRO AND AND FETA CHEESE.
ARE THE THREE FOOD GROUPS -- YOU
KNOW SOMEONE THRUST INTO YOUR
HANDS A A BALLOT YOU KNOW THE
PETITION DRIVE IN SAYS THIS IS
GONNA SAY WESTERN CIVILIZATION
AS WE KNOW IT.
HALF THE TIME THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHO'S PAYING FOR THE
SIGNATURE COLLECTION THEY JUST
KNOW THEY'RE GETTING PAID FIVE
OR SIX BUCKS.
A SIGNATURE AND AND SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT THE VOTER HAS ACCESS THE
BASIC INFORMATION WHO'S PAYING
FOR IT COULD BE A UNION COULD BE
A COMPANY COULD BE A TRADE
ORGANIZATION I DON'T KNOW WHAT --
BUT THE VOTER DOES DESERVE TO
HAVE THAT ACCESS SOME
INFORMATION THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SINGING
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY I'M
SORRY SENATOR BORCHERS FORGIVE
ME THEN SEE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
ON A MAP POSE A QUESTION -- TO
AUTHOR YOU HAVE ANY OBJECTION
ACCEPTING QUESTION OBJECTION OR
BOARD JUST GO FORWARD THANK YOU --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS AS
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER WOULD
APPLY TO ANY TOP DONOR WHETHER
IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL OR AN ENTITY.
IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT SUBJECT TO THE
YEAR MARKING RULES THAT WE HAD
BUILT INTO THE DISCLOSE ACT.
YES CAN YOU JUST.
IN A PREVIOUS -- ASH AND TELL ME
THAT EFFECTIVELY ON WHAT WE
DON'T WANT TO ALLOW FOR IS FOR
THERE TO BE LIKE SHELL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE CREATED
SO THAT IF AN INDIVIDUAL OR
ENTITY.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THE WHOLE
LEAF FUNDING AND AN ENTITY.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE -- YOU
KNOW ACME CORPORATION CREATE AN
ALLIANCE FOR JOBS PAY FOR IT
ENTIRELY AND SOMEHOW BE ABLE TO
SEE ALLIANCE FOR JOBS INSTEAD OF
ACME CORPORATION OR WERE YOU
ACTUALLY UNION TO DO THE SAME.
OUT WAS SIMILAR WITH IT WITH IT
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL SO -- WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING WHO'S PAYING
FOR IT WHETHER IT'S AN
ORGANIZATION A COMPANY A UNION
OR AN INDIVIDUAL -- BUT BUT YES
IT WOULD APPLY TO ANY ANY OF
THOSE -- ENTITIES WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NOT.
GAMES BEING PLAYED.
A SHELL ORGANIZATION BEING
CREATED TO HIDE THE IDENTITY OF
THAT UNION OR ORGANIZATION OR
COMPANY OR INDIVIDUAL SO
HYPOTHETICALLY IF THERE WERE
THREE TRADE ASSOCIATIONS THAT
COMBINED THEIR RESOURCES TO
CREATE CALIFORNIA FOR JOBS.
WITH THAT DISCLOSE CALIFORNIA
FOR JOBS OR WHAT IT RIVER
REQUIRE THE THE CONTRIBUTING
ENTITIES INTO CALIFORNIA FOR
JOBS IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND I
CAN GET YOU SOME DETAILS ABOUT
THE WAY THE RULES WORK BUT I BUT
I BUT BUT ESSENTIALLY.
IT HAS TO DO THERE'S A COUPLE
FACTORS ONE HAS TO DO WITH YOUR
MARKETING.
SO -- LET'S SAY THOSE IF THOSE
COMPANIES ARE GIVING THAT MONEY
TO JOBS PACK FOR EXAMPLE THE
CHAMBERS -- PACKED FOR GENERAL
USE PURPOSES DURING THE ELECTION.
THEN IT WOULD BE JOBS PACKED
THAT WOULD BE THE NAME THAT'S ON
THERE BUT IF THIS IS BEING DONE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS PARTICULAR
RACE.
AND THE MONEY BEING YOUR MORE
FOR THAT RACE AND THIS
ORGANIZATION IS BEING CREATED
JUST TO MESSAGE FOR THAT RACE
THEN THOSE INDIVIDUAL OUR
COMPANIES WOULD HAVE TO BE
DISCLOSED.
OKAY THERE'S A THIRTY DAY GRACE
PERIOD -- FOR UPDATING THE
MATERIAL -- OF THE TOP.
THREE RIGHT SO THE IDEA IS THAT
WE WANTED TO MAKE IT SO THAT IT
WASN'T TOO OWNERS FOR THE
SIGNATURE GATHERS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS.
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF UPDATE BEING
MADE IN CASE THERE WERE MAJOR
CHANGES TO THE BIG DONORS TO A
PARTICULAR CAMPAIGN.
BUT WE WANTED TO GIVE THE
SIGNATURE GATHERS THE TIME IN
THE CONVENIENCE TO BE ABLE TO
JUST GO ONLINE PRINT UP -- THE A
MONTHLY SHE THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO DISCLOSE -- WHO THE
DONORS ARE BUT DO SO IN A WAY
THAT PROVIDE THEM WITH A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU?
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
ALLEN YOU MAY CLOSE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS I I
THINK THAT THE QUESTIONS TO GET
WHICH
TRANSPARENCY IN JUST MAKING IT
SO THAT.
PEOPLE WILL KNOW -- WHEN THEY'RE
WHEN THEY'RE GIVEN THAT
SIGNATURE PETITION OUT AT THE
STORE -- WHO'S WHO'S WHO'S
PAYING FOR IT.
ARE BY THE WAY ALSO PROVIDES FOR
ENDORSEMENT SO THAT IF LEGAL
WOMEN VOTERS OR ANOTHER
ORGANIZATION IS ENDORSED THE
MEASURE THEY CAN PUT THAT
INFORMATION ON THERE AS WELL.
VOTERS NEED TO KNOW WE WE
OFTENTIMES YOU NO HAN ON OUR
ANALYSES WE GET TO SEE WHO COMES
OUT SUPPORTER IN OPPOSITION TO
THE THINGS THAT WE VOTE FOR THE
VOTERS DESERVE THAT CHANCE TO
WE'VE HARD SO MANY STORIES OF
PEOPLE BEING.
BEING DISSUADED OR BAMBOOZLED OR
OR OR OR YOU KNOW MANIPULATED TO
SIGN SOMETHING THAT -- THAT THEY
MAY BE AGAINST THE VALUES THAT
THEY HOLD DEAR THIS IS ABOUT
DISCLOSURES ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
AND I I I RESPECTFULLY ASK MY
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR AGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A AT A I CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING [inaudible]
I WARLOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible] FIVE RUBIO
[inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
HI MY CAO SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER.
I WELL.
I SENATOR ALLEN MOVES TO CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE SENATOR WILK.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
[inaudible]
OUR GOVERNMENT.
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR WELL AN ACT RELATING
TO THE SANTA CLARITA VALLEY WAR
WATER AGENCIES SENATOR WELL
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN IS A CLEAN UP
MEASURE OF MY SB SIX THIRTY FOUR
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
WHICH CREATED THE SENATE
CREATIVE VALLEY WATER AGENCY.
AS A CONSOLIDATION OF THE FORMER
NEW HALL COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
AND THE CASTAIC LAKE WATER
AGENCY.
UNDER THE PROVISIONS IN SB SIX
THIRTY FOUR REQUIRE THE AGENCY'S
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. TO REDUCES
MEMBERSHIP FROM THE ORIGINAL
FIFTEEN DOWN TO NINE MEMBERS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES AGENCIES BORDER
DIRECTORS TO ELIMINATE A BOARD
POSITION IF THERE IS A VACANCY
PRIOR TO THE NEXT ELECTION.
THIS IS NEEDED TO AVOID EITHER
AN ELECTION OR APPOINTMENT
PROCESS FOR SEAT.
THAT'S REQUIRED TO BE ELIMINATED
ANYWAY.
SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN A
SPONSORED BY THE AGENCY ITSELF
AND WE HAVE RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
BAY DOOR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
WANT TO COMPLIMENT -- THE CENTER
FROM SANTA CLARITA AND PLEDGE MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE --
WE'VE SEEN GOOD REFORMS OUT IN
THE VALLEY WE THINK IS WATER
DISTRICT IS STRONGER THAN EVER
AND WE THINK THIS BILL.
IS A CONTRIBUTOR COHERENT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WITHOUT
UNDERCUTTING OUR DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES LOCALLY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SENATOR WILK WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I RESPECT I TAKE MY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CANOGA PARK FIRST COMMENTS
AND THEY ARE A 100% ON THE MARK
AND AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A YELLOW [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I BROWN [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI AMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
CENTER WILL MOVES TO CALL.
OUR FOLKS IN THE BACK OF THE
ROOM THERE'S A LOT OF NOISE IT'S
ACTUALLY COMING UP THIS WAY SO
IF YOU WERE GOING TO INSIST ON
CONVERSATIONS IN THE BACK PLEASE
KEEP THEM QUIET.
OR TAKE THEM OUT IN THE HALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE MILITARY.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL WHAT IT DOES IS IT.
CHANGES PRIMARILY CHAINS
REPORTING SCHEME WHEN THERE IS
AN ALLEGATION WITH RESPECT TO A
SENIOR OFFICER NONCOMMISSIONED
OFFICER IN THE NATIONAL GUARD --
IF THERE IS A COMPLAINT AGAINST
THE SENIOR OFFICER
NONCOMMISSIONED OFFICER THAT
REPORT WOULD GO TO THE GOVERNOR
AS WELL AS TO THE ADJUTANT
GENERAL I OR TONIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
HELLO COULD WE HAVE A MY GONE
FOR CENTER ARCH LETTER CENTER OF
FLOOR SHORES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT MY FELLOW
VETERAN HAS WORKED VERY HARD AND
HE AGREED ON THE AMENDMENTS.
SO CONSEQUENTLY I AGREE WITH HIM
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA ANY
FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR UMBERG YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE ORIGINAL
VOTE.
WELL DONE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FORGES.
AYE BRADFORD.
HI COME BY ADAM.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible] FIVE
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I GROW.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
I AM VERY.
HI MY COUNTY.
I WIENER.
I WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH IT
WILL OUT ONE MORE TIME AND THEN
CLOSE THE ROLE AS ALL MEMBERS
ARE BACK ON THE FLOOR SO.
IF YOU HAVEN'T VOTED IN --
DISCARDED DO SO.
YOU'LL HAVE ONE MORE CHANCE
STARTED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
RUBIO.
HI.
OUR EYES THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT THE SENATOR UMBERG.
FILE ITEM FORTY A COLLEGE AND IF
WE COULD KEEP THE NOISE DOWN IN
THE BACK OF THE HALL PLEASE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SENATOR
UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- SENATE BLL SEVEN
FOURTEEN SIMPLY SIX SIX TO
CLARIFY A NEW REGULATION
PROMULGATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
EARLY THIS YEAR -- RELATING TO
LICENSING AND WHO IS WHO IS
EXEMPT AND WAS NOT EXEMPT FROM
KNOX KEEN ACT DIRE TONIGHT VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE
[inaudible]
MATTER.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES.
I FELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I OSEM [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
HI -- TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE ALONG [inaudible]
I MARROW [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible] FIVE SKINNER
[inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible] FOR JUST.
FIVE THEY'RE AWESOME
[inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG TO
FILE ITEM. FIFTY SENATOR BATES.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR SEC SEVEN FORTY
SIX BY SENATOR BATES AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB SEVEN FORTY
SIX REQUIRES HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
ALREADY COVER CHEMOTHERAPY OR
RADIATION THERAPY. TO ALSO COVER
ANTI CANCER MEDICAL DEVICES.
THE OF JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY I'M GONNA GO RIGHT
TO OUR OWN MY CLOTHES BECAUSE I
THINK MY VOICE IS GIVING OUT AND
IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS MAYBE I
CAN ANSWER THOSE.
SB SEVEN FORTY SIX WILL MAKE UP
CLEARING CODE THAT HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED
TO COVER ANTI CANCER MEDICAL
DEVICES OF THE ALREADY COVER
CHEMOTHERAPY.
THIS PARTICULAR DEVICE HERE.
HE THIS YEAR NOW THE STOPPING
THE ARM IT HAD MANSA OF BRAIN
CANCER GEO GLASS.
DEAL BLAST STORMER IN ITS --
THERAPY THAT IS A DELIVERY
DEVICE THAT'S WEARABLE IN
ATTACKS THE TUMOR DIRECTLY I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES PLAYED
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM.
FIFTY SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
TURNING OBJECTION THE
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
FIFTY SIX SENATOR MORE LOCK.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR NINETY SIX BY
SENATOR MORLOCK AN ACT RELATING
TO ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT
ABUSE SENATOR MORLOCK THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SO WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF BILLS ON OUR AGENDA
DEALING WITH OUR GROWING.
AGING POPULATION AND THE SENATOR
FROM SANTA BARBARA GAVE AN
ELOQUENT.
RESOLUTION YESTERDAY ON THIS
PARTICULAR GROWING SEGMENT OF
OUR DEMOGRAPHICS.
BUT WE'RE HEARING ALSO MORE
ABOUT GRANNY SCAMS.
LIKE A PHONE CALL THAT SAYS YOUR
GRANDCHILD IS BEEN KIDNAPPED
PLEASE Y. OR X. AMOUNT OF MONEY.
SENATOR CENTERS OF THE A BILL
WAS PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
TITLED THE FINANCIAL ELDER ABUSE
REPORTING ACT.
AND IT REQUIRED THAT BANKS TO
MANDATING MANDATED REPORTING
SKEWS ME.
SB FOUR NINE SIX WILL ADD BROKER
DEALERS AND INVESTMENT ADVISORS.
IT FOLLOWS THE NORTH AMERICAN
SECURITIES ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION MODEL LANGUAGE WHICH
IS ALREADY BEEN ADOPTED IN SOME
FORM OR FASHION IN NINETEEN
STATES.
AND WHAT'S REALLY NICE IS SB
FOUR NINE SIX IS WELCOMED BY THE
INDUSTRY.
AND HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY
OPPOSITION TO DATE.
SB.
FOUR NINE SIX WE'LL INCLUDE
FINANCIAL PROFESSIONALS WHO
SHOULD BE A LINE OF DEFENSE.
WHEN UNUSUAL OR ILLEGAL TRANSFER
REQUESTS OF A CLIENT SPENDS A
REQUESTED I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST?
AN AYE VOTE ON SB FOUR NINETY
SIX THANK YOU SENATOR MORE LIKE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT DI --
STRONGLY -- RECOMMEND AN AYE
VOTE ON US BEFORE NINETY SIX WE
OFTEN HAVE -- SEMINARS IN IN MY
DISTRICT TALK ABOUT ELDER ABUSE
AND AND FRAUD AND WITH OUR
GROWING SILVER SO I'M INTO THIS --
GOING ON RIGHT NOW THERE IS A
LOT OF NEFARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
AND PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT ARE.
TRYING TO GET THEIR HANDS ON THE
MONEY OF OUR SENIOR CITIZENS
THAT HAVE SOCKED AWAY ENOUGH
MONEY TO TAKE CARE OF THEM IN
THEIR IN THEIR SENIOR YEARS --
BUT WITH PEOPLE LIVING LONGER
THAN THEY EXPECTED TO AND ALL
THESE PREDATORS THAT ARE OUT
THERE POSING AS SOCIAL SECURITY
AGENTS HAS A HIGHER S. AGENTS --
WE EVEN HAVE SOME THAT WERE --
ACTUALLY THREATENING -- SOME OF
MY SENIOR CITIZENS THAT -- THEY
WERE GOING TO HARM MEMBERS OF
THEIR FAMILY AND IF THE WENT
FORWARD WITH -- REPORTING SOME
OF THOSE TO THE AUTHORITIES THAT --
THE HARM WOULD COME AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF INTIMIDATION
OUT THERE AND I THINK THAT IF
YOU HAVE A SENIOR CITIZEN THAT
IS DRAWING SIGNIFICANT SUMS FROM
THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS -- THAT THEY
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO MAKE A
REPORT OF THIS -- JUST ONE
EXAMPLE I HAD A CONSTITUENT IN
THE CITY OF MENIFEE -- AND SHE
WAS -- A PART OF THE NIGERIAN
KING -- ISSUE.
AND SHE HAD EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN MY SAVINGS
[inaudible]
AND SHE DEPLETED EVERY SENSE SHE
HAD.
AND AFTER SHE LOST ALL OF HER
MONEY SHE WAS STILL ACCEPTING
CALLS STILL THINKING THAT SHE
WAS GOING TO BE THE BENEFICIARY.
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SO WE ALL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
SENIOR POPULATION IN OUR
DISTRICT THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
TOOL TO HELP OUR SENIOR CITIZENS
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM.
NEFARIOUS PEOPLE.
IN ORGANIZATIONS THAT SEEK TO
ROB THEM.
OF THEIR RETIREMENT AND
RENDERING THEM DESTITUTE -- WHEN
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL SO MANY THINK
THE AUTHOR BRING THIS FORWARD
INNER KERR DRIVE OUT?
THANK YOU -- CENTER STONE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR MORE LIKE YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
OF WE'VE ALL GOT PERSONAL
STORIES I'M SURE [inaudible]
BY -- FATHER PASSED AWAY
RECENTLY BUT A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE STARTED WORKING ON
TRANSFERRING ASSETS.
FROM THE TO THE TRUST SO THAT WE
COULD MANAGE AFFAIRS AND WE
START LOOKING AT BANK STATEMENTS
AND SAYING WHAT ARE THESE
CHARGES.
FOR WE WENT TO THE BANK MY
SISTER WENT TO THE BANK AND THEY
SAID WELL THOSE ARE FRAUDULENT
[inaudible]
TRANSFERS.
BUT WHAT WE DO WHAT YOU CLOSE
YOUR BANK ACCOUNT WHICH IS OKAY
THAT'S CLOSE THE BANK ACCOUNT
NOW IT'S OPEN A NEW WHEN.
THEY LOOKED AT HER AND SAID NO
WE CAN'T DO THAT FOR YOU.
AND SO HE WAS ON VACATION HER
CELL PHONE WENT OFF AND HER RING
[inaudible]
FRONT DOOR -- DOORBELL AT START
HE SHOWED HER THE VIDEO OF
SOMEONE ON THE FRONT PORCH AND
THAT PERSON WAS A POLICE OFFICER.
WANTING TO KNOW IF SHE WAS
ACTUALLY THE DAUGHTER OF MY
FATHER AND WHAT THE CONNECTION
WAS.
AND I THOUGHT ISN'T AS GREAT
THAT THIS MAN DATING REPORT
MENDED REPORTING IS WORKING THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTING.
THE ELDERLY IN THIS STATE AND I
THINK ADDING BROKER DEALERS AND
INVESTMENT ADVISORS IS A GREAT
MOVE AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU CENTER MORE LIKE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR
WILK.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO ZERO TWO BY
SENATOR WELK AN AXE ROOM LEADING
TO ANIMALS SENATOR WILL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SHAKY MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS A RISE 2% SB.
TWO OH TWO THE BILL THAT WILL
HELP SAVE THE LIVES OF OUR
BELOVED ANIMALS.
CALIFORNIA'S FACING A SHORTAGE
OF ANIMAL BLOOD A RESOURCE THAT
IS CRITICAL TO PERFORM
LIFESAVING OPERATIONS WHEN
ANIMALS ARE SICK OR SEVERELY
INJURED.
WE ONLY HAVE TWO COMMERCIAL
ANIMAL BLOOD BANKS OPERATING IN
THE STATE AND THEY ARE RUNNING
OUT OF DONORS.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT OUR CURRENT.
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK ONLY ALLOWS
THE PRODUCTION SO BLOOD FROM
THESE CLOSED COLONY BANKS.
THESE ARE FACILITIES TO KEEP
ANIMALS ON THEIR PROPERTY FOR
YEARS JUST TO PROVIDE BLOOD.
SB TWO OH TWO WILL MAKE AN
ALLOWANCE FOR COMMUNITY BASED
OWNERS MEANING PRIVATE PET
OWNERS WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
VOLUNTEER THEIR ANIMALS TO
DONATE BLOOD UNDER THE OVERSIGHT
OF THE VETERINARIAN.
EVERY OTHER STATE IN THE UNION
ALREADY ALLOWS FOR COMMUNITY
BASED MODEL WHICH HAS PROVEN TO
BE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
CURRENTLY ALLOW FOR THIS OUR
BLOOD SUPPLY SPACES SERIES
DEFICIT THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE
THAT AND GUARANTEE THE HEALTH OF
THE ANIMALS EVERYWHERE THIS
MEASURES NECESSARY TO ENSURE A
HEALTHY A BOUNTIFUL SUPPLY BLOOD.
FOR OUR CATS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILL CONSIDER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION DOES.
I'M SORRY SENATOR STONE YOU WISH
TO SPEAK.
YEAH JUST A QUICK COMMENT I'M
GONNA RECOMMEND MY MY COLLEAGUE
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
THAT -- I'M BRINGING AFFORD
BECAUSE OF A PERSONAL SITUATION
JUST RECENTLY HAPPENED AS YOU
DON'T.
MANY TIMES WE WE OFTEN VALUE
YOUR PETS SOMETIMES MORE THAN
SOME OF OUR FAMILY MEMBERS THEIR
MEMBER OF OUR FAMILY WE LOVE
THEM UNCONDITIONALLY AND THEY
LOVE US UNCONDITIONALLY.
AND JUST A A QUICK STORY -- MY
WIFE AND I WE OFTEN GO TO
AUCTIONS AND WE OFTEN -- WILL
BID ON RESCUE DOGS AND WE WE
HAVE THIS BEAUTIFUL -- BEAUTIFUL
CANINE THAT WE WE BET ON AND WE
HAVE A VACATION PLANNED.
AND WE WENT AWAY AND I ASKED MY
DAUGHTER IF SHE WOULD TAKE CARE
OF THIS.
VERY CUTE LITTLE COPIC PUPPY SO
AFTER WE GOT BACK -- COUPLE
WEEKS LATER I MY WIFE ALSO TALK
ABOUT THE WHOLE TRIP WAS.
I MISSING THIS PET I WANT TO GET
GET THIS DOG BACK.
IN A MINUTE I GOT BACK WE CALLED
MY DAUGHTER TO PICK UP THE PAT
AND SHE SAID THE YOU DON'T HAVE
A PET THAT'S MY PET NOW.
YOU KNOW SOME MY MY DAUGHTER --
TOOK.
OUR CHILD IF YOU WILL ARE
BECAUSE I CHILD OUR DOG WHICH
CREATED SOME TENSION BETWEEN MY
WIFE MYSELF MY I MENTION THIS
BECAUSE THIS DOG WAS REALLY A
BEAUTIFUL DOG AND OF COURSE WE
EMBRACE OUR DAUGHTER KEEPING AT
BUT RECENTLY -- TWELVE YEARS OLD
TEN YEARS OLD -- HER NAME IS
LILY.
AND SHE GOT ALL KINDS OF BOXES
ALL OVER HER HER ABDOMEN.
AND THEY WENT INTO THE VAT AND
FOUND OUT THAT SHE HAD -- A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM THAT
REQUIRED BLOOD TRANSFUSIONS AND
WE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED THAT THE
BLOOD IS AVAILABLE FOR HUMAN
BEINGS IF YOU NEED IT AND IT'S
NOT ALWAYS AVAILABLE FOR CANINES.
AND SO LILY I ENDED UP GETTING
TRANSFUSIONS -- THE PROLONG HER
LIFE UNTIL WE UNDERSTOOD THAT IT
WAS REALLY A A FATAL DISEASE BUT
I CAN'T STRESS HOW IMPORTANT AT
THIS BLOOD SUPPLY IS MADE
AVAILABLE TO TO VETERINARIANS TO
OFFER TO THEIR THEIR CLIENTS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF PRESERVING
THE LIVES OF THEIR LOVE.
PETS AND FOR THOSE REASONS -- IN
HONOR OF LILY -- MY DAUGHTER'S
VERY SPECIAL -- BUT BE IN OUR
BELOVED PUPPY -- I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT SB.
TWO ZERO TWO THANK YOU SENATOR
STONE.
SIR WILK IN HONOR OF LILY OR ANY
OTHER.
CREATURE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES -- YES BETTER PRESENT.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE --
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY FOR
SHARING I'M GOING TO REFRAIN
FROM TELLING MY MY HEY HEY MY
DOG STORIES BUT I WILL SHARE ONE
I THINK MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
CAPITAL COMMUNITY KNOW ROBIN
BLACK.
AND KNOW WHAT AN ANIMAL LOVER
SHE IS SHE HAD A SITUATION ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO WHERE HER
BELOVED DOG WAS ILL.
WAS HERE IN A PLACE IN
SACRAMENTO NEEDED A BLOOD
TRANSFUSION -- WAS NOT AVAILABLE
SHE HAD TO DRIVE TO DAVIS AND ON
THE WAY FROM SACRAMENTO TO DAVIS --
THE DOG PASSED SO THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER WAY TO INCREASE THE
SUPPLY.
OF BLOOD AND DO IT IN A MORE YOU
MAIN WAY WHEN WILL WE GIVE BLOOD
WE LEAVE OUR HOMES WE GO WE GIVE
BLOOD WE COME BACK WE SHOULD
ALLOW THIS THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
FOR OUR FOUR LEGGED FRIENDS
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WILL CAN ANYONE
ELSE HAVE A DOG STORY.
NOT TODAY.
VERY GOOD ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
THE SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO CAT LOVERS HERE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
SENATOR HERTZBERG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT BY -- VOTED
57% OF THE FOLKS OF CALIFORNIA.
IN ALL CORNERS A CALIFORNIA THE
PEOPLE PASSED THE ADULT USE OF
MARIJUANA ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN THAT.
LET ME BE EXTENDED THE
RECREATIONAL USE TO ALL I MEAN
THE THE MEDICAL USE TO
RECREATIONAL USE PERIOD.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE AND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS BILL AND SEE EXACTLY THE
SAME BILL WE HAD LAST YEAR.
THAT WAS HELD IN COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
IS TO DEAL WITH THE UNDERLYING
BANKING ISSUE YOU'RE LITERALLY
ACCORDING TO SOME MEMBERS OF
THIS HOUSE WHO ARE SERVE THOSE
AREAS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BURIED
IN BARRELS.
THERE ARE STORY AFTER STORY WITH
THIS PUBLIC SAFETY RISK WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING HELD UP AT
GUNPOINT OR SHOT TO TRY TO GRAB
CASH THERE'S SO MUCH CASH IN THE
SYSTEM.
BECAUSE UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW WE
HAVE SCARED THESE ARE MARIJUANA
IS DEEMED TO BE A SCHEDULE ONE
DRUG WHERE THE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA SAY IT'S LEGAL AND SO
THEY WON'T BANK IT.
SO WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO DO HERE
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES.
IS TO COME UP WITH IN THE
INTERIM.
A PROCESS WHERE WE COME UP WITH
A LIMITED CHARTER BANK THAT HAS
LIMITED PURPOSES THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EMPTY BRANCHES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT COULD EASILY BE
RENTED FROM FRESNO LOS ANGELES.
OXNARD VENTURA RIVERSIDE SANTA
CRUZ SAN FRANCISCO YOU CASA
EUREKA AND BEYOND THE COULD
EASILY BE RENTED SO THE IDEA IS
TO CREATE A LIMITED CHARTER BANK
THE JEWS FOR PURPOSES. ONE TO
ALLOW VENDORS TO CREATE CHECKS
TO PAY STATE AND LOCAL TAXES AND
FEES TO TO PAY VENDORS FOR GOODS
AND SERVICES PROVIDED TO THEIR
CANNABIS BUSINESS THREE TO PAY
RENT.
AND FOR TO PURCHASE STATE AND
LOCAL BONDS AND OTHER DEBT
INSTRUMENTS WITH IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE DONE THIS A WAY TO CREATE
A CLOSED LOOP SYSTEM.
THAT WILL HAVE ITS OWN INSURANCE
AND WON'T INNER INTEGRATE WITH
THE REMAINING PORTION OF THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM OUTSIDE OF HOW
THE FEDERAL RESERVE SYSTEM WORKS.
THIS IS AS CLOSE AS WE CAN GET
UNTIL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CHANGES ITS POLICY I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO STEP
FORWARD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
PURPOSES. FOR ACCOUNTING
PURPOSES FOR THE STATE TO
INCREASE THE ABILITY TO GAIN
TAXES AND THE LIKE.
WHICH IS BEEN SOMEWHAT
CHALLENGING AS WE'VE SEEN
RECENTLY AS A RESULT OF THE
PASSAGE OF THIS ACT I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT THAN --
COLLEAGUES AYE AYE I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUE ONCE AGAIN FOR USING
HIS -- CREED OF MINE TO COME UP
WITH SOLUTIONS AND THIS WE
DEFINITELY NEED A SOLUTION IN
THIS CATEGORY.
AS YOU KNOW MY I BROUGHT FORWARD
A RESOLUTION RECENTLY -- THAT
WAS PASSED I THINK UNANIMOUSLY
OUT OF OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT.
BIRDS OF FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RECLASSIFY MARIJUANA FROM A
SCHEDULE ONE DRUG AND BASICALLY
DECLASSIFYING GET.
SO THAT WE CAN -- RESEARCH --
MARIJUANA PROPERLY AND SO THAT
WE CAN BAND.
RIGHT NOW EVERYTHING'S GOING TO
BE DONE IN CASH.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE A CASH
BUSINESS IT BRINGS IN BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
WHILE I'M SURE WE HAVE SOME
HONEST VENDORS OUT THERE THAT
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
PAYING THEIR TAXES.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS LOSING NOT
MILLIONS BUT PROBABLY HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS IF NOT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR IN TAX REVENUE --
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY CANNOT --
WRITE A CHECK -- TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY GOT TO COME IN
WITH WILL BERYL'S TO KERRY AND
ALL THE CASH AND IF THEY'RE
HONEST HONEST VENDORS AND WANTED.
TO ALLOW THE STATE TO RECEIVE
THE TAX MONEY.
BUT IN ADDITION TO HAVING WILL
BARRELS TO CARRY THEIR CASH AND
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE FEAR THAT
THEY MUST HAVE.
IN WALKING AND DRIVING AROUND
WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS OR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN THEIR CARS OR TRUCKS -- TO
SAFELY GET THE MONEY TO THE
APPROPRIATE.
ENTITIES TO PAY TAXES ARE TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES TO PAY THEIR
WAGES.
SO THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE UNTIL SUCH TIME THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAKES UP.
AND RE CLASSIFIES MARIJUANA FOR
IT'S CERTAINLY LEGITIMATE USES
AS A MEDICINE TO TREAT THE
AILING -- AND PROVIDES FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO GET
THEIR FAIR SHARE THEIR ON A
SHARE OF TAXES IT SHOULD BE PAID
ON THIS COMMODITY A FEW OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR FOR
THOSE REASONS.
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND A YES VOTE
SB FIFTY ONE COMMITTEE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
HERTZBERG YOU MAY CLOSE HI VOTE
THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELLA.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS THEM.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LIKE [inaudible]
I MORAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
SH HI AMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE VIEW. FIVE WIENER
[inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
I MORRELL I DON'T KNOW.
I THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE -- CHEESE WE ON THE
URGENCY OF ICE THIRTY FIVE THE
NOSE ONE ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE SENATOR WIENER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RE
COLLEAGUES COOLEY PLEASE QUIETED
DOWN IN THE BACK OF THE HALL.
LARA NOISE BACK THERE ARE JUST.
FORCES ITS WAY UP MAKES IT HARD
TO TO HEAR AND TO BE ABLE TO
LISTEN SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
PLEASE KEEP THAT NOISE DOWN IF
HE WOULD SENATOR WINNER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
SENATOR WINNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT CALL BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SEEN IN VOTED ON THIS.
BILL BEFORE AND THIRD TIME IS A
CHARM -- BECAUSE THIS IS A LOCAL
CONTROL BILL THAT WILL ALLOW BUT
NOT REQUIRE TEN PILOT CITIES TO
THE SIDE LOCALLY WHETHER THEY
WANT TO KEEP THEIR A NIGHT LIKE
CLOSING TIME AT TWO AM.
OR WHETHER THEY WANT TO DECIDE
LOCALLY WHETHER WORKS FOR THEM
TO GO LATER AS LATE AS FOUR AM --
RIGHT NOW FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A BLANK
IT SHUT DOWN TIME OF TWO AM
WHETHER YOU ARE IN THE DOWNTOWN
OF A MAJOR INTERNATIONAL CITY IN
CALIFORNIA OR IN A SMALL TOWN --
LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE NO
ABILITY TO DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES
WHETHER THERE NIGHT LIFE --
MAKES IT APPROPRIATE TO GO --
LATER.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THE
FLEXIBILITY -- FOR THESE TEN
PILOTS CITIES AND EITHER THE
MAYOR OR THE CITY COUNCIL IN
EACH OF THESE PILOTS CITIES HAS
ASKED TO BE INCLUDED IN THE BILL
THEY HAVE SAID. TO US THAT WE
WANT THIS FLEXIBILITY -- THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH A
PROCESS CAN BE A COMMUNITY --
TASK FORCE -- AND THEN FORMULATE
THEIR OWN LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
PLAN AND TRANSPORTATION PLAN AND
ACT AS A CITY COUNCIL -- WORK
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS --
AND THEN SUBMIT THAT PLAN -- TO
THE STATE -- BEFORE -- THE
EXTENDED HOURS COULD GO INTO
AFFECTS EACH INDIVIDUAL VENUE
WOULD STILL HAVE TO APPLY TO ABC
PER THE NORMAL PROCESS IS A VERY
PROCESS INTENSIVE SITUATION --
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF GUARD
RAILS IN ADDITION CITIES -- WILL
HAVE A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY IT'S
NOT JUST ON ON SWITCH OUR OFF
SWITCH FOR THEIR ENTIRE CITY.
THEY CAN DECIDE THAT ONLY ONE
NEIGHBORHOOD OR ON ST OR ONE
DISTRICT WILL BE INCLUDED THEY
COULD DECIDE THAT IT'LL ONLY
HAPPEN ON FRIDAY SATURDAY NIGHTS
OR ONLY ONE NIGHT A YEAR IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT -- NIGHT
LIFE IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
OUR ECONOMY INTO OUR CULTURE AND
WE SHOULD GIVE OUR CITIES THE
FLEXIBILITY -- TO DECIDE WHEN
THAT MY LIFE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER DEBATER
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
WANTED -- TO THANK THE AUTHOR OF
THIS ON THIS BILL -- FOR HIS
ATTENTION TO DETAIL AND A
WILLINGNESS TO CHAT WITH ME AND
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF FRESNO
THE REASON WHY SUPPORT IT
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE PROCESS.
IS NOT NECESSARILY THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE DRINKING OUR
SHOULD ALWAYS BE EXTENDED -- TO
WHAT IT IS NOW BUT IT EMPOWERS
THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES -- NAMELY --
THE CITY COUNCIL OR THE MAYOR
WHATEVER THE RESPECTIVE
AUTHORITY MAY BE TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS IN THEIR OWN RIGHT
THEY MAY DECIDE. TO EXTEND THE
HOURS THEY MAY DECIDE NOT TO
EXTEND THE HOURS FOR LIMITED IN
OTHER FASHIONS AS WAS DESCRIBED
BY THE AUTHOR AND THAT IS THE
REASON WHY THE CITY OF FRESNO --
HAS SUPPORTED THIS IN EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT TO ME WHICH IS WHY
I'M OFFERING MY SUPPORT -- TO TO
THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB -- FIFTY
EIGHT TO ME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS IS
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL -- IT'S ALSO
ABOUT -- PROMOTING -- TERRORISM
IN SOME OF OUR CITIES AS AN
EXAMPLE AND CITY OF PALM SPRINGS
IS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
MEASURE.
PALM SPRINGS THE CITY OF FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IT HAS OVER A MILLION TOURISTS.
THAT COME IN EVERY SINGLE YEAR --
DROPPING A LOT OF MONEY OFF --
IN SALES TAX IN T. O. T. TAXES
AND AND THEY SEE THIS AS AS A
WAY TO COMPLEMENT THE THEIR
GROWING.
TOURISM BUSINESS.
THERE.
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THERE'S
THE EXHAUSTIVE ABC PROCESS THAT.
HAS TO BE UNDERTAKEN BEFORE.
THEY COULD BE GRANTED THIS.
THIS -- OPPORTUNITY TO EXTEND
THEIR HOURS BYE BYE.
TO BUT REALLY FOR THOSE OF US
THAT CAME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WE APPRECIATE WHEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T DICTATE.
HOW WE DO OUR BUSINESS AND THIS
IS ONLY ALLOWING THOSE
MUNICIPALITIES A CHOOSE?
TO EMBARK ON THESE INCREASED
HOURS TO DO SO WE'RE NOT
MANDATING THAT THEY DO OR NOT
MANDATING THAT THEY DON'T.
AND THERE'S AN EXTENSIVE PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DO DO IT.
THEY DO IT IN THE SAFEST WAY
POSSIBLE TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
INTEREST SO FOR THOSE REASONS I
URGE A YES VOTE ON SB FIFTY
EIGHT APPRECIATE THE OFFER FOR
BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE SENATOR
[inaudible]
CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TOO
WOULD LIKE TO APPLAUD THE AUTHOR
FOR MAKING SURE THAT LOCAL
CONTROL IS IN FORCE AND WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LET OUR LOCAL --
INDIVIDUALS ARE LOCAL ELECTED TO
MAKE GOOD DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THEIR COMMUNITYBUT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR A MEETING WITH ME AND EN
THEM INCLUDING THE TWENTY NINE
PALMS MISSION A BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS.
ALTHOUGH A SOVEREIGN NATION THEY
WOULD NEED SOME TYPE OF
EXCLUSION BECAUSE OF COMPACT RT
NEGOTIATED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING THAT IN
YOUR BILL SO THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
WINNER.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL [inaudible]
I GORGEOUS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible] FIVE GROSS.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO -- TADA.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
NO JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
NO SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
NO WAY CASKEY.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
STERN.
BY AGE TWENTY EIGHT NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM [inaudible]
SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR STERN.
NOT AT HIS DESK FILE ITEM SIXTY
NINE SENATOR GALGIANI.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AN ACT RELATING
TO FIRE PREVENTION SENATOR
GALGIANI THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SB ONE THIRTY
DIRECTS CAL FIRE TO CREATE.
A PERMANENT GRANT PROGRAM TO
INSTALL AND IMPLEMENT AN
EMERGENCY FIRE SIREN WARNING
SYSTEM FOR CITIES THAT ARE
DEEMED BY CAL FIRE TO BE AND
HIVE.
FIRE HAZARD ZONES IN ORDER TO
NOTIFY AND ALERT THE PUBLIC IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
THE SPEED OF RECENT CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES IS FORCING US TOWARDS
A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH TO
NOTIFY PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY THIS
BILL ADDS ANOTHER LAYER TO
IMPROVE CURREN ALERT SYSTEMS
WHERE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES MIGHT
FAIL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI USER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS OUR DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
HAD A FEW CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL -- SENSE OF
LANDOWNERS ELECTED TO LIVE IN A
WILD FIRES OWN.
WHICH IS A PERSONAL CHOICE WHY
WHY SHOULD ALL CALIFORNIANS FUND
FOR SIRENS.
AND WITH SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY THREE BY MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
WHICH WE NOW WE'RE SAYING WE
SHOULD HAVE A SECONDARY AGENCY
CAL FIRE BE INVOLVED BESIDES THE
OFFICE OF INTO OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
AND I JUST WONDER WILL THE
SIRENS BE ELECTRIC POWERED OR
HAND CRANK TO BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
UTILITIES TURNED OFF THE
ELECTRICITY [inaudible]
AND FOURTHLY AREN'T AREN'T
CONCEPTS LIKE THIS BETTER
ADDRESSED BY ASSESSMENT
DISTRICTS.
YOU KNOW I THINK IS A WORTHY
BILL BUT I JUST.
AS A YOU KNOW KIND OF A
LIBERTARIAN LEANING PERSON.
I I I DID JUST SEEMS THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD OWN THEIR OWN DECISIONS
TO BE PERSON RESPONSIBLE. FOR
TAKING CARE OF THEMSELVES IF
THEY'VE ELECTED TO LIVE.
IN A WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE IS
OWN OR IN THE MIDDLE OF A FOREST.
AND SO WITH THAT I JUST JUST HAD
SOME CONCERNS AND MISGIVINGS
ALTHOUGH I THINK IT I AND I
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IT'S ABOUT BUT I JUST
WONDER WHY?
SACRAMENTO SHOULD BE DICTATING
THE USE OF THIS.
MONEY SO I JUST HAVE A HESITANCY
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR FOR
BILL THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SIR MORE LIKE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR BORCHERS.
I CERTAINLY NOT MATTER PRESIDENT --
CERTAINLY RESPECT -- MY
COLLEAGUES -- OUR THOUGHTS
DEFINITELY IN A MORE LIBERTARIAN
LEANING.
BUT I THINK WHEN WE CONSIDER
TSUNAMIS EARTHQUAKES EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS SHOULD EXTEND TO
THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND EVEN THOUGH INDIVIDUALS --
DESIRE TO LIVE WHEREVER THEY
CHOOSE I DON'T THINK EVERYONE
CAN CONTEMPLATE THE ON
CONTEMPLATED.
I DON'T THINK WE UNDERSTOOD THE
SEVERITY OF THE THE FORCE FIRES
ON THE WILDFIRES THAT WOULD IN
GULF AS OF THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS.
SO I BELIEVE THIS IS A STEP
FORWARD I THINK IT'S MERITORIOUS
AND CERTAINLY WORTH.
LOOKING AFTER -- THE FOLKS THAT
LIVE THERE GOD WE COULD ALSO
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE -- THERE
COULD BE A MASS EXODUS IF WE
DON'T MAKE CERTAIN PRECAUTIONS
AND PUT THEM INTO PLACE SO I
APPLIED -- THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND WOOD
BEES WILL BE SUPPORTIVE TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
GALGIANI MAKE CLOTHES -- YES.
ONE AND THE COST IS BETWEEN
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WE ARE NOT DICTATING
SPECIFICS TO CAL FIRE BUT RATHER
ALLOWING FOR THE FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT THEY CAN COME UP WITH THE
PROGRAM THAT MAKES MOST SENSE.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MOVED INTO --
FIRESTONE'S THAT AT ONE TIME
WERE NOT WHAT THEY ARE TODAY
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ALL THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE
KNOW BUT I DON'T BELIEVE WE CAN
NEVER PUT A PRICE ON LIFE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY
THINGS THAT DIDN'T GO AS THEY
SHOULD HAVE GONE DURING THESE
HORROR FLICK FIRES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
WITH A SIREN WHEN IT GOES OFF IT
ALERTS PEOPLE THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT'S WRONG AND THAT
THEY SHOULD PAY ATTENTION.
SO IF THEY'RE SLEEPING AND
SOMETHING HAPPENS AT TWO IN THE
MORNING THEY WOULD BE AWAKENED
BY A SIREN THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
IN THIS STATE WHERE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS A KIND OF
MONEY TO THEM IF THEY'RE A VERY
VERY SMALL COMMUNITY.
AND WHILE THEY MIGHT WANT TO
TAKE THIS LIFESAVING MEASURE UP
FRONT IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FINANCES TO DO SO RIGHT AWAY
THEY'RE PUTTING THEMSELVES AT
RISK.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A VERY MODEST
MEASURE AND AGAIN WE GIVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO CAL FIRE TO PUT
INTO PLACE WHAT WORKS BEST AND
WE DON'T DICTATE THE EXACT
TECHNOLOGY BUT RATHER.
A SIREN SO THAT.
THOSE WHO ARE IN DANGER ARE
AWAKENED AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO GET OUT SAFELY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS FOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
I TADA.
HI JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
OUR HI.
PRICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY THREE FILE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE SENATOR WIENER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT SENATOR WIENER.
pPRESIDENT.
SB.
ONE FORTY TWO WE'LL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR NEW MOTHERS TO RETURN
TO WORK.
WHILE ALSO CONTINUING TO BREAST
FEED -- THEIR NEWBORNS -- RIGHT
NOW TOO MANY WOMEN ARE FACED
WITH A CHOICE DO I RETURN TO
WORK AND STOP BREAST FEEDING.
OR DO I BREASTFEED MY CHILD TO
ENSURE THAT CHILD'S HEALTH.
AND DELAY RETURNING TO WORK AND
THAT IS A FALSE CHOICE ODDS ARE
SB ONE FORTY TWO WILL PUT
STANDARDS IN PLACE -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- BED WORKPLACES ARE
PROVIDING THE ABILITY FOR WOMEN
TO EXPRESS MAIL.
OUR RIGHT NOW -- THE RULE IS
THAT YOU CAN'T FORCE A WOMAN TO
EXPRESS MILK IN A BATHROOM.
AND WHILE THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MINIMUM STANDARD -- WE
NEED TO GO BEYOND -- THE BILL
AND IN GENERAL REQUIRES THAT
WOMEN HAVE A PRIVATE SPACE AND I
CAN BE A TEMPORARY PRIVATE SPACE
OR AN ACTUAL ROOM.
WITH A TABLE WITH A CHAIR WITH
AN ELECTRIC OUTLET -- AND NEARBY
RUNNING WATER AND REFRIGERATION
IT'S QUITE BASIC.
THE BILL PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY -- TO BUSINESSES --
BUSINESSES WITH FEWER THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES.
ARKAN CECA HARDSHIP -- IN
ADDITION -- WE UNDERSTAND A
DIFFERENT EMPLOYMENT SETTINGS
ARE DIFFERENT AND SO THE BILL
DOES NOT MICROMANAGE HOW THESE
PRIVATE SPACES ARE PROVIDED
THERE ARE SOME INDUSTRIES BUT
ALSO -- RECEIVE -- SPECIAL --
FLEXIBILITY INCLUDING
AGICULTURE AND THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY -- WE KNOW -- THAT
CHILDREN -- HAVE SAID THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH BENEFITS NOT
TO BREAST FEEDING -- WE ALSO
NOTE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
WOMEN TO BE ABLE TO CHOOSE FOR
THEMSELVES WHETHER TO RETURN TO
WORK -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION WILL
START WITH THE SENATOR LEYVA IN
AND GO FROM THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AYE RISES THAT CHAIR OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR HIS.
STEADFAST SUPPORT OF THIS ITS
REALLY SHOCKING WHEN YOU THINK
YOU KNOW ERR A WOMAN HAS A CHILD
SHE WANTS TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND BREAST FEED THAT CHILD.
SHE CAN'T TAKE SIX MONTHS OFF
BECAUSE THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
SIX MONTHS PAID LEAVE.
SO ALL WE'RE ASKING EMPLOYERS TO
DO IS MAKE SURE THERE'S A SPACE
SO THAT THE WOMAN CAN EXPRESS
FOR MILK AND FEED HER CHILD.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE SEEN WOMEN
IN CLOSETS I'VE SEEN WOMEN IN
THE BATHROOM TRYING TO EXPRESS
THEIR MILK.
AND IT'S JUST SHOCKING THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE HAVE
NOT DONE A BETTER JOB OF
ACCOMMODATING WOMEN WHO ARE
LITERALLY RAISING OUR FUTURE SO
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROWTH THE FORESHORES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUES.
COMMENTS ABOUT BEING IN THE
BATHROOM AND DOING LACTATION
THOSE EMPLOYER SHOULD BE CITED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS BECAUSE IT'S AGAINST
THE LAW FOR THEM TO DO THAT.
IT ISREQUIRED BY EMPLOYERS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A LACTATION
STATIONER LACTATION ROOM.
AND WE DO PROVIDE THAT TO IN THE
WORKPLACE THAT I HAVE AND I KNOW
MANY OTHER EMPLOYERS DO.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL WILL CREATE
A PAGA PENALTY WHICH THIRTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYERS ARE SUBJECT
TO POCKET PENALTIES WHICH IS A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
AND IT'S JUST A LITIGATION HELL
HOLE FOR EMPLOYERS.
POCKET WAS CREATED -- IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX IN THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WILL CREATE ANOTHER AVENUE OF
OPENING FOR TRIAL LAWYERS TO
COME IN AND SAY THEY'RE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S BEEN DENIED
THE LACTATION STATION BUT THE
ONLY THING THAT REALLY
INTERESTED IN.
OUR THEIR WEIGHT STATEMENTS
BECAUSE IF THERE'S ONE IN
CORRECT THING ON THEIR WEIGHT
STATEMENTS WHETHER IT'S A PERIOD
A COMMA A DASH OR A DATE.
THEY WILL HAVE ALMOST --
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF FINES AND NOT ALMOST
THE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF FINES BECAUSE THEY AT
IT VERY QUICKLY.
THE OTHER THING THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT DO IS IT'S NOT NARROWLY
DESIGNED FOR SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES
WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THIS BILL.
I WAS ACTUALLY AT ONE OF MY
CLIENTS SITES WHICH IS A WELDING
FABRICATION FACILITY NOT
NECESSARILY A WOMAN STILL BUT
WOMEN ARE GETTING INTO THAT
INDUSTRY.
BUT OTHER THE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO EMPLOYEES THAT ARE IN%
THAT FACILITY ONLY TWO WERE
WOMEN AND THEY OPERATE IN THE
OFFICE AND ONE IS A PAINTER AND
INDUSTRIAL PAINTER.
AND TO REQUIRE BECAUSE OF THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF THAT FACILITY
FIVE OR SIX LACTATION STATIONS
BASED ON THIS BILL WOULD BE
COMPLETELY IRRATIONAL FOR AN
EMPLOYER.
SO I WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER MAKING AMENDMENTS FOR A
SPECIFIC EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYERS
THAT.
I DON'T SEE TRADITIONALLY DON'T
EMPLOY WOMEN BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
WOMEN ARE GAINFULLY BEING
EMPLOYED IN MANY MANY INDUSTRIES.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE SOME TYPE OF
AN EXCEPTION BASED ON SQUARE
FOOTAGE -- JUST BECAUSE THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF THE FACILITY
THAT THAT MAY NOT EMPLOYEE THAT
NUMBER OF WOMEN THE OTHER THING
IS -- IN THIS BILL LIKE I SAID
WHEN I ADDRESS THE POCKET ISSUE
THERE'S ALSO THE LITIGATION
PORTION OF THIS BILL WHICH IS
EXTREMELY HARMFUL TO EMPLOYERS
AND ALL WHO WANT TO DO IS BE. TO
CREATE A JOB AGAIN I THINK
EMPLOYERS SHOULD PROVIDE A
LACTATION STATION FOR WOMEN WHO
NEED TO HAVE BREAST FEEDING THEY
NEED TO BE QUIET IT NEEDS TO
HAVE A LOCKED DOOR.
IT NEEDS TO BE A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN LACTATE APPROPRIATELY
WE JUST RE CONVERTED ONE OF OUR
OFFICES BUT AS SO FAR RECLINER
IN THEIR AT TV IF SHE WANTED TO
WATCH TV BECAUSE WE HAD. THREE
WOMEN IN OUR OFFICE IT WAS LIKE
TELL THEM TO QUIT DRINKING THE
WATER RIGHT BECAUSE THEY WERE.
EVERYBODY WAS HAVING BABIES
WHICH IS GOOD.
AND ANYWAY SO I AT WE COULD BE
CONVERTED IN OFFICE AND WE MADE
IT VERY ACCOMMODATING AND I
THINK EMPLOYERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
ENOUGH TO DO THAT.
AGAIN THERE IS ALREADY A
LEGISLATION IN PLACE IN THE LAW
ALREADY SAYS THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT WHICH IS FUNDED BY
PAGA SOME WAY.
CAN GO OUT AND ENFORCE THESE --
EMPLOYERS TO COMPLY WITH A
LACTATION STATION THAT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR ALL WOMEN THANK
YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
WIENER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS -- FROM THE MINORITY
LEADER -- SAYS TO A FEW THINGS
FIRST OF ALL EVEN THOUGH IT IS
THE LAW NOW THAT YOU CAN'T FORCE
A WOMAN TO LACTATE IN THE
BATHROOM -- THAT IS A BASELINE
STANDARD AND AS THE CENTER OF
DECEMBER ANY YOU KNOW COUNTY
MENTION.
THERE ARE STILL WOMEN WHO ARE
LACTATING AND BROOM CLOSET.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING OUT
TO THEIR VEHICLE TO DO IT IN A
CAR INALL ON A HOT DAY.
WE WITH THE STANDARDS ARE NOT
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE -- AND TO
BE VERY CLEAR THIS BILL PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY FOR
EXAMPLE MULTI UNIT COMMERCIAL
SPACE.
CAN SARE A LACTATION SPACE IN
ADDITION IF YOU ARE LET'S SAY A
SMALL RETAIL ESTABLISHMENT YOU
COULD EVEN HAVE A TEMPORARY
SPACE THAT YOU PUT UP IT DOESN'T
EVEN HAVE TO BE A PERMANENT.
ROOM WE HAVE WORKED EXTENSIVELY
OVER THE LAST YEAR WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ON THIS BILL
IN A MADE AMENDMENTS IN RESPONSE
TO FEEDBACK FROM THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE AN OPEN DOOR -- AND TO BE
FLEXIBLE AND TO BE COLLABORATIVE
WITH THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY THEM
FINALLY -- THIS BILL DOES NOT
CONTAIN DOES NOT CREATE A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
THAT WAS REMOVED FROM THE BILL --
IT YOU CAN CURRENTLY TODAY SU
UNDER PAGA.
FOR IF THE IF YOU'RE BEING
FORCED FOR EXAMPLE TO LACTATE
AND A BATHROOM THIS DOESN'T
CREATE ANY NEW CAUSE OF ACTION
IT'S SIMPLY CREATES NEW
STANDARDS -- AND THESE ARE
STANDARDS OF FRANKLY ARE LONG
OVERDUE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
NO ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR AGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
JONES NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LONG [inaudible]
NO BROWN [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO HAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO. FIVE TADA.
BY AGE TWENTY FIVE KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES TODAY MANY FOSTER
YOUTH OR ALUMNI ARE SHADOWING
SENATORS AS PART OF THE ANNUAL
FOSTER CARE WEEK LETS WELCOME
THEM TO THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
TODAY IF WE COULD GIVE A WARM.
ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO OUR FOSTER
YOU THREE ALUMNI.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA SENATE.
MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR HER TADO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR TADO AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDI CAL.
CENTER FURTADO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SB TWO ZERO SEVEN WOULD ENSURE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS ACCESS TO ASTHMA
PREVENTION SERVICES BY ALLOWING
MEDI CAL TO REIMBURSE FOR ASTHMA
EDUCATION AND HOME TRIGGER
ASSESSMENTS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS THE
HIGHEST ASK MARIE FOR CHILDREN
IN THE NATION.
OVER FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR RESIDENTS HAVE ASTHMA AND
OF THOSE A HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND OUR CHILDREN.
ADDITIONALLY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HAS THE HIGHEST RATES OF ER
VISITS FOR CHILDHOOD ASTHMA IN
THE STATE.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN ALMOST 90% OF
ALL PEDIATRIC ASTHMA EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS AND CALIFORNIA
WERE CHILDREN COVERED BY
MEDICARE.
FULLER WILL COMMUNITIES LIKE
THOSE OF MY DISTRICT ME BETTER
ACCESS TO EFFECTIVE ASTHMA
PREVENTION STRATEGIES LIKE AS MY
EDUCATION AND ACCESS TO HOME
VISITS WHICH CAN HELP PREVENT
ASTHMA ATTACKS.
ADDITIONALLY IN TWENTY TEN TOTAL
CHARGES FOR ASTHMA
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE OVER ONE BILLION.
SB TWO ZERO SEVEN WILL HELP
INSURE OUR MOST VULNERABLE HAVE
ACCESS TO ASTHMA MANAGEMENT
EDUCATION AND PREVENTION
TECHNIQUES TO HELP REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ASTHMA ATTACK AS
WELL AS ENSURE COST SAVINGS TO
THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR D'AMATO
DEBATER DESCRIBE DISCUSSION
SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND THE THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL -- FOR BRING
IT FORWARD.
WHEN I FIRST MOVED TO FRESNOI
WENT JOGGING?
THAT VERY FIRST TIME I THOUGHT I
ACTUALLY HAD ASTHMA.
THE AIR QUALITY IN THE VALLEY IS
WIDELY REGARDED AS SOME OF THE
WORST IN THE NATION.
SO THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE FOR OUR
BACKYARD AND EVEN THOUGH --
FOLKS MAY NOT ALWAYS APPRECIATE --
THE HORRIFIC COMBINATION OF
BEING IN A VALLEY WITH HEAVY BAG --
WITH DRIFT AND THE PARTICULAR
MATTER.
THAT SETTLES IN OUR AREA WE HAVE
AN EXTRAORDINARY HEALTH
CHALLENGE THAT IS -- EXPOSING
EVERYONE SO WE I SUPPORT EVERY
EFFORT TO BRING MORE ATTENTION
AND MORE MEDICAL SERVICE FOR
THIS TYPE OF IN THIS TYPE OF
ISSUE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION DOCTOR PAN SENATOR
PAN THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
JUST -- BRIEFLY -- CERTAINLY IS
A PEDIATRICIAN I WANT TO THANK.
MY GOOD FRIEND FOR BRING THIS --
BILL FORD IT IS REALLY ABOUT
PREVENTION WE WATCH YOU DON'T
WANT TO ST ASK WHAT WE WANT TO
PREVENT ASTHMA GOING GIVES
FAMILIES THE TOOLS TO DO THAT
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES AYE
OR TONIGHT.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE CENTER HER TALK TO YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
NINETY TWO SENATOR BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
OR CHOOSE ME MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO DISCRIMINATION SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AS FEE TO EIGHTEEN
ALLOWS ANY CITY OR COUNTY TO AN
ACT THEIR OWN.
ANTI DISCRIMINATION ORDINANCE
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
AND OFFER EVEN FURTHER
PROTECTIONS THE CALIFORNIA
WORKERS.
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION IS
RAMPANT IN CALIFORNIA
CONSEQUENCES ARE FELT GREAT IS
IN BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
WHEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE CALIFORNIA'S
FAIR EMPLOYMENT LAWS WORKERS ARE
BETTER PROTECTED FROM
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON THEIR
RACE.
THEIR GENDER OR THEIR AGE SB TWO
EIGHTEEN FILLS A CRITICAL
ENFORCEMENT GAP AND ENSURES THAT
PEOPLE RETURN TO WORK FASTER.
RECOVER LOST WAGES CONTRIBUTE
YOUR OUR ECONOMY AND PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOUS DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL I I BELIEVE IN MPOWER
MENTION ALLOWING OTHERS TO
IMPLEMENT POLICIES.
BUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT CREATING
A NEW LAYER OF GOVERNMENTS.
AND I'M VERY CONCERNED WHEN
THESE EMPOWERED.
WITH THOSE EMPOWER GQ'S MISTER
ABBAS THROWN RULES AND
GUIDELINES THE PAPILLA MANDATE.
CONSEQUENTLY MY MISGIVINGS GIVE
ME PAUSE ABOUT SB -- TWO ONE
EIGHT IF SOMETHING IS GOOD FOR
ONE LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT SHOULD
BE GOOD FOR ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED.
THEN THEY SHOULD BRING THOSE
CHANGES TO US WE WRITE THE BILLS
AND THEN EVERYONE UNIFORMLY
WOULD BE -- ABIDING BY THE SAME
STATUTES AROUND THE STATE SO I I
RECOMMENDED NO VOTE ON SB.
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU CENTER
MORE LIKE ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MY
COLLEAGUE OF MINE MIGHT DOWN I
APOLOGIZE.
I I JUST RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AGAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS OVERSEAS ALL EMPLOYERS
WHICH IT OVERSEAS DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING AND
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
AND THEY HAVE ALREADY IN PLACE
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PASSED BY THIS BODY.
IT'S DISCRIMINATORY STANDARDS
FOR EMPLOYMENT AND AND HOUSING
YOU CANNOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
RACE COLOR ANCESTRY NATIONAL
ORIGIN RELIGION CREED AGE OVER
FORTY DISABILITY MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL.
SEX GENDER INCLUDING PREGNANCY
CHILDBIRTH BREAST FEEDING OR
OTHER RELATED MEDICAL CONDITION
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY GENDER EXPRESSION.
MEDICAL CONDITION GENETIC
INFORMATION MARITAL STATUS
MILITARY AND VETERANS SERVICES
OR POLITICAL AFFILIATION.
SO WE ALREADY HAVE THINGS IN
PLACE THAT.
RESTRICT EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYERS
SHOULD NOT DISCRIMINATE BUT THEY
RESTRICT EMPLOYERS FROM
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST ANY
EMPLOYEE FOR ANY OF THOSE
REASONS. TO ADD ANOTHER LAYER
THAT EMPLOYERS WILL HAVE -- TO
ADDRESS AND MAKING IT DIFFERENT
FROM MULTI IMPLEMENT PLAYERS AND
MULTI COUNTY SO MAYBE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SAYS YOU KNOW YOU
CAN'T WEAR BLUE SHIRTS OR
WHATEVER THE CASE AY BE AND
THEN.
AND THEN IT'S DIFFERENT IN THE
COUNTY THAT YOU OPERATE AND YOU
HAVE COMPANIES THAT OPERATE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES IT JUST MAKES
IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR JOB
CREATORS TO OPERATE IN THIS
STATE.
THEY ALREADY HAVE STATE
ENFORCEMENT STANDARDS AGAIN
ENFORCED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS THAT
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO ADHERE TO
THIS. TO THIS STRICT STANDARD
WHICH THEY SHOULD BUT TO ALLOW
ANOTHER LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT TO
HEAR NEW RULES AND NEW
REGULATIONS IN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES.
IT DOESN'T WORK FOR
JURISDICTIONAL REASONS FOR
EMPLOYERS AND CREATING AN EXTRA
LAYER OF GOVERNMENT SO I WOULD
ASK THAT.
YOU OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR GROVE ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
ASISTIR APPOINTED STATED THERE
ARE PLENTY MEASURES IN PLACE BUT
CURRENTLY.
THOSE APARTMENTS ARE GROSSLY
UNDERSTAFFED OVER TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND CLAIMS ARE FILED EACH
YEAR.
THE MAJORITY OF THEM TAKING
NINETY DAYS TO BE RESOLVED AND
MANY OF THEM WERE NEVER RESOLVED
THIS PROVIDES AN EXTRA LAYER OF
MAKING SURE WE IMPLEMENT THOSE
STATE AND FEDERAL GUIDELINES
THAT EXIST.
AND EMPOWER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DO THE SAME -- WE'RE NOT LOOKING
TO CREATE A HODGEPODGE OF
REGULATORY -- OVERSIGHT AS
RELATES TO DISCRIMINATION BUT
ALL IN POWER IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO DO IT BECAUSE
AGAIN.
CURRENTLY THE STATE IS
UNDERSTAFFED AND OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS UNDERSTAFFED
DEALING WITH DISCRIMINATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I DRAWS THEM.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I ROSE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
JONES.
OUR EYES TWENTY NINE NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG TO
FILE ITEM.
NINETY SIX SENATOR DODD FILE
ITEM.
NINETY SIX MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
WILDLAND FIRE PROTECT PREVENTION
SENATOR DODD.
META PRESIDENT MEMBERS EXTREME
WEATHER HAS INCREASED THE NUMBER
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN THE
LAKE OF OUR WILDFIRE SEASONS.
ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE TWELVE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WERE
CAUSED BY ELECTRIC POWER AND
DISTRIBUTION INES CONDUCTORS
AND POWER POLES.
CAL FIRE CITED TREES ARE PARTS
OF TREES FALLING ON THE POWER
LINES AS SPECIFIC CLAUSES OF
THOSE FIRES.
ADEQUATE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IS CRITICAL TO REDUCING THE RISK
OF TREES AND BRUSH CONTACTING
ELECTRIC LINES IN EQUIPMENT.
PART OF CAL FIRES MISSION IS TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES.
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE PREVENTION
PROGRAM INCLUDES WILD.
LAND THREE FIRE ENGINEERING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FIRE
PLANNING EDUCATION AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUELY SITUATED
DETERMINE WHAT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS NECESSARY TO
REDUCE THE LEVEL WILD FIRE RISK
IN TO ENSURE THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT OF OUR ELECTRIC
UTILITIES.
IS SUFFICIENTLY IMPLEMENTED.
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN REQUIRE CAL
FIRE TO AUDIT EACH ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS VEGETATION MANAGER
WORK TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
EACH UTILITIES WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
CALIFORNIA BE REIMBURSED BY THE
UTILITIES FOR ALL ITS COSTS
INCLUDING THE NEW RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ITS ABILITY TO PERFORM.
ITS OTHER DUTIES WILL NOT BE
IMPAIRED FINALLY BECAUSE
VEGETATION MANAGER WORK IS VERY
DANGEROUS.
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN ALSO REQUIRES
THAT THE VEGETATION MAYES WORK
BE PERFORMED BY QUALIFIED LINE.
CLEARANCE TREE TRIMMERS OR
QUALIFIED LYING CLEARANCE TREE
TRIMMER TRAINEES.
RECENTLY JUDGE ALSO OVERSEEING
P. GENIES PROBATION IN THE SAND
BRIGADES SAID P. JEANNIE HASN'T
CUT THE RIGHT TREES TO PROPERLY
REDUCE RISK.
OF FUTURE WILDFIRES IN RESPONSE
P. JEANNIE SAID AND I QUOTE.
THERE'S A LOT OF TREES OUT THERE
AND WE DON'T HAVE EYES ON ALL OF
THEM.
YOU KNOW MADAM CHAIR AND BETTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I SUBMIT LET'S
GET THE ELECTRICAL UTILITIES
EYES THEY NEED TO ADEQUATELY
MANAGE VEGETATION AND CUT THE
RIGHT TREES RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM THE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
I FELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWS [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO. FIVE TADA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
BROWN.
MORRELL AYE NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROSS [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WAKE OWSKI.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
ICE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NINETY EIGHT SENATOR HER
TITLE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY BY SENATOR
TADO AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE.
CENTER HER TATO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB TWO
SIX SIXTY AIMS TO HELP EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS AVOID COVERAGE GAPS
WHEN THEY UNDERGO LIFE CHANGES
THAT TRIGGER LOSSES IN COVERAGE.
MANY OF THEM WILL UNDERGO LIFE
EVENTS LIKE GETTING JOBS ARE
EARNING MORE AT THEIR JOBS.
WHICH CAN CAUSE THEM TO LOSE
MEDICAL COVERAGE AND BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR COVER CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL ALLOWS COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO EXPEDITE
ENROLLMENT FOR PEOPLE LOSING
MEDI CAL BY AUTO ASSIGNING THEM
TO THE PLAN WITH THE MOST
ASSISTANCE WHILE STILL ALLOWING
THEM TO SHOP AROUND.
IT ALSO REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS TO TRANSFER A LIST
OF PEOPLE WHO LOSE COVERAGE FOR
ANY REASON TO COVER CALIFORNIA
SO COVERED CALIFORNIA CAN REACH
OUT TO GET THEM COVERED.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I PO.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
BILL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NON.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS -- I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WHITE HOUSE HE I WIENER
[inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible] FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ALL EYES THIRTY KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED SENATOR WIENER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
THREE SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO CAL WORKS SENATOR
WIENER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- SB
TWO SIXTY EIGHT IS A LONG
OVERDUE REFORM THAT REPEALS THE
CASH ASSETS TEST AND THE VEHICLE
ASSET TEST IN THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE. FOR
APPLICANTS TO THE COW WORKS
PROGRAM IT REMOVES --
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS THAT
DISCOURAGE FOR CALIFORNIANS FROM
SAVING MONEY AND ULTIMATELY
EXITING INTERGENERATIONAL
POVERTY -- THE CASH ACID TEST
REQUIRES AN APPLICANT FOR CAL
WORKS TO HAVE A NO MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS IN ASSETS TO QUALIFY FOR
CAL WORKS.
THE VEHICLE ACID TEST REQUIRES
THAT APPLICANTS CAR.
NOT BE OF A VALUE GREATER THAN
NINE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SO IF YOU HAVE SAVINGS A
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS. FOR A CAR
THAT IS WORTH MORE THAN NINETY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS ARE YOU ARE
DISQUALIFIED FROM RECEIVING CAL
WORKS.
THIS.
IS A OF RULE THAT IS NOT
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW.
AND OTHER STATES HAVE DONE AWAY
WITH THIS ASSET TEST.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING AND
POVERTY AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
GET OUT OF POVERTY.
WE KNOW THAT SO MANY OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING TO
MANY PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LIVING IN THEIR CARS AND THE
IDEA THAT WE WOULD SAY TO PEOPLE
THAT.
YOU ONLY GET HELP.
IF YOU STAY IN NOT POVERTY IF
YOU DON'T SAVE MONEY.
WE'RE PROHIBITING YOU FROM
SAVING MONEY.
IF YOU ARE TO STAY IN THIS
PROGRAM TO HELP KEEP YOUR FAMILY
OF FLOW.
IT IS SHAMEFUL AND WE NEED TO
GET RID OF THIS TEST WE SHOULD
BE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO SAVE
AND TO ULTIMATELY EXIT POVERTY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS OR ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SITTING IN HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
I FORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADA.
I JACKSON HI HI JONES
[inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MERLE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I Y. CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
TIRADO [inaudible]
I GROW.
OUR EYES TWENTY NINE NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. ONE OH SIX SENATOR ALLEN.
ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY SIX BY
SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT RELATING TO
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID SENATOR
ALLEN.
MEMBERS -- THIS BILL WILL ENABLE
STUDENTS RESIDING CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE APPLIED FOR ASYLUM TO BE
ELIGIBLE -- FOR FINANCIALLY TO
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM WHILE
THEIR ASYLUM CASES PENDING
THERE'S A GROWING BACKLOG IN THE
PROCESSING OF CASES.
FOR PEOPLE SEEKING ASYLUM OF
ESCAPE THEIR HOMES DUE TO
PERSECUTION WAR VIOLENCE.
AREN'T UNDER CURRENT LAW THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE BEEN GRANTED
ASYLUM ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
STUDENT AID IN THOSE WHOSE
ASYLUM CASES PENDING.
AND ATTENDED THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FOR THREE YEARS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CAL GRANT --
THREE EIGHTY FIVE FORTY BUT
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A TINY
LOOPHOLE HERE THAT WE'VE
DISCOVERED -- THROUGH THE WORK
OF ONE OF MY SENATE FELLAS IN
THIS ALLOWS PENDING ASYLUM
SEEKERS WHO ARE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND YOU POSSESS.
A VALID EMPLOYMENT AUTHORIZATION
DOCUMENT AND HIS SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CAL GRANT. THIRTY SURE IS IT THE
SOUND SEEKERS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION TO
BECOME PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS THE WAIT. FOR
THEIR THEIR THEIR APPLICATION TO
BE DECIDED ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
AND THEN DEPENDING ON HOW IT'S
DECIDED.
THERE EITHER SENT BACK OR THEY
STAY HERE -- AND IT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER GRANT.
PROGRAMS NOW THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR A DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
[inaudible]
SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MAY I
OF POSE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
YES WE ACCEPT THE QUESTION THIS
IDEA WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE -- HOW LONG
CAN AN ASYLUM PROCESS TAKE?
WELL -- MY EXPERIENCE I WORKED
ON WHEN THE SOUND CASE WELL AS A
AS A LAWYER TO PRO BONO MATTER
AND IT DID TAKE AWHILE -- BUT IT
I MEAN EVERY EVERY CASE IS
DIFFERENT AND A LOT OF IT
DEPENDS ON THE CURRENT ON THE ON
THE STATE OF OF OF OF THE
BACKLOG.
SO AND SOME OF THESE CASES CAN
GET PROCESS VERY QUICKLY AND
SOME OF THEM TAKE A LONG TIME
DEPENDING ON THE ON THE THE
DETAILS OF THE CASE SOMETIMES
THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE TO BE
PRESENTED.
IT EIGHT I THINK FROM A
PHILOSOPHICAL STANDPOINT -- WE
MIGHT BE OF DIFFERING OPINIONS
WHICH IS IS ENTIRELY OKAY -- MY
CONCERN THOUGH IS THAT. FOR
pASYLUM CASES THAT CAN CONTINUE
ON FOR YEARS AND YEARS THAT.
THE USE OF CAL GRANTS FOR THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR CREEK CAL GRANTS --
COULD INSTEAD BE GOING -- TO
NATIONALIZED -- OR NATURAL BORN
U. S. -- IS THERE ANY CONCERN ON
YOUR AND ABOUT.
GIVING UP.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
HERE FOR THOSE THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT.
BE ALLOWED TO STAY PENDING THEIR
ASYLUM OUTCOME EXCUSE ME SENATOR
ALLEN WOULD YOU ACCEPT ANOTHER
QUESTION -- IT YEAH THANK YOU.
KNOW IT'S A GOOD IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I WILL SAY THAT -- IF
YOU LOOK AT THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THEY'RE THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND THIS BEING IN
THE CLASS OF TENS.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS SO
IT REALLY IS A SMALL -- COST I I
I I I WOULD I WOULD SHARE THAT
CONCERN IF IT WERE A A LARGER
PORTION.
OF OF OF OF PEOPLE BY IT IS SUCH
A SMALL COSTS AND THERE ARE SOME
VERY SYMPATHETIC CASES THAT HAVE
COME TO MY ATTENTION THAT.
GOT ME TO THE PLACE WHERE I
WANTED TO RUN THIS BILL --
ITSELF A IT'S A IT'S IT'S NOT A
LOT OF MONEY AND IT'S REALLY NOT
A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU GOT TO THINK
ABOUT IT THERE'S THEY'RE NOT
THAT MANY IN THIS CASE.
IN IN THIS CATEGORY AND THEN YOU
HAVE TALK ABOUT FOLKS WHO WOULD
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE AND
ENGAGING IN AN EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM LIKE THIS.
SO FOR THAT REASONI'M I I I
DECIDED TO GET THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
ALLEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECT FASHION ABOUT.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL [inaudible]
I BORDERS [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS IN [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWS [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADA.
HI JACKSON.
I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
I PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH.
I RUBIO.
HI SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHAT HOUSE HE AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
I WELL [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
VICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN SENATOR DOROS SO.
FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTEEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR DORADO AN ACT RELATING
TO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR TO RAZA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SB THREE FIFTY FOUR WILL
EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM. TO UC AND CSU GRADUATE
STUDENTS ALLOWING THEM TO USE
EXISTING DREAM LOAN PROGRAM
FUNDS.
IN TOTAL THERE IT ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS IN BOTH THE UC
AND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
COMBINED.
THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM
EXTENDING DREAM LOAN ELIGIBILITY
TO GRADUATE STUDENTS.
IN THIS BILL WE ARE SIMPLY
ASKING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ALLOW YOU SEE AND CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY INSTITUTIONS. TO
OFFER CALIFORNIA DREAM GRADUATE
STUDENTS STATE FUNDED LOW
INTEREST LOANS TO COMPLETE THEIR
SCHOOLING JUST AS WE DO FOR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS.
WITH THAT SAID I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE ONE
SIX SENATOR.
GORGEOUS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MAY
PLEASE POSE A QUESTION TO THE
OTHER.
WE'LL ACCEPT THE QUESTION YES
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU I WANTED JUST TO
CLARIFY AND THE DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM -- THOSE INDIVIDUALS --
ALL HAVE [inaudible]
LEGAL STATUS.
THAT MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE IN UNDER
THIS PROGRAM.
NO THEY DON'T.
I HAVE IN THIS WAS.
I'M SORRY PLEASE NOTE THEY HAVE
THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF TWO TO
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ALREADY
APPROVED FOR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS SO IT'S TAKING THE SAME
FUNDS AND EXTENDING THEM. TO TO
GRADUATE STUDENTS.
HOUSE ALWAYS MAKE THIS SAID THAT
THIS THIS COMMENT I THINK --
THERE IS ONE YEAR OLD TIME
SENATOR BORCHERS YOU'RE SPEAKING
ON YOUR OWN TIME YEAH QUESTION A
QUEUE YOU KNOW WHEN YOUR CHILD
IS MAYOR QUICK STATEMENT --
REASONABLE PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE
ON THE SOCIAL BENEFITS -- IN THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THOSE SOCIAL
BENEFITS INCLUDING -- SCHOOLING
I PERSONALLY AM OF THE OPINION
THAT THAT WE SHOULD.
NOT IGNORE THOSE THAT ARE HERE --
WITHOUT DOCUMENTATION BECAUSE
THAT IS A REALITY ESPECIALLY IN
MY IN MY DISTRICT THAT IS VERY
MUCH A REALITY -- BUT I HAVE.
DIFFICULTY.
EXTENDING SOCIAL DOLLARS ARE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE WITHOUT LEGAL
STATUS. TO THE DETRIMENT OF
THOSE THAT HAVE LEGAL STATUS
WHETHER THEY'RE NATURAL BORN OR
NATURALIZED -- SO I THINK FROM A
PHILOSOPHICAL STANDPOINT.
IT'S ONE THING FOR UNDERGRADUATE.
BUT NOW WE'RE AT AN AGE FOR
GRADUATE LEVEL EDUCATION.
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
PRESUMPTIVELY ARE CAPABLE OF
HAVING BEEN INTEGRATED CAPABLE
OF WORKING AND AND IN IMPROVING --
THEIR THEIR PROSPECTS IN THIS
COUNTRY SO I THINK -- THERE
COULD BE AN ARGUMENT FOR
UNDERGRAD THE GRADUATE I THINK
IS -- IS ENTITLING -- SOCIAL
BENEFITS TO THOSE THAT ARE NOT
EVEN ELIGIBLE EVEN IF THEY'RENATURAL BORN OR NATURALIZED
AMERICANS THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR TO ROSS SO YOU MAY
CLOSE.
YES AGAIN THIS WILL EXTEND THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN PROGRAM.
TO THOSE ATTENDING YOU SEE AND
YOU IT CAL STATE UNIVERSITY AS
GRADUATE STUDENTS THIS IS NOT
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF THE
FUND IT'S MERELY EXTENDING IT.
TO OTHER STUDENTS AS GRADUATE
STUDENTS SO -- IMPASSE IN THIS --
WE'RE GONNA GIVE THOSE
CALIFORNIANS OF THEIR SAME
OPPORTUNITY FOR ACADEMIC SUCCESS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROD SO ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES.
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
HI HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
NO ROOM [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NOW.
I TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTEEN EXCUSE ME. ONE OH
NINE ONE OH NINE THAT IS SENATOR
ROTH.
PASS TEMPORARILY.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES IF YOU WOULD JOIN ME.
IN THE GALLERY VISITING FROM THE
TWENTY SIX SENATE DISTRICT ARE
TWENTY FIVE FOURTH GRADERS AND
THEIR CHAPERONES FROM TEMPLE
ISRAEL OF HOLLYWOOD DAY SCHOOL
PLEASE WELCOME THEM TO THE STATE
CAPITOL.
THERE ARE OVER HERE IN THE
CORNER.
WELCOME TO THE STATE CAPITAL. TO
OUR GUESTS [inaudible]
THE ONE MOVING ON FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
PENDING WE WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE SENATOR
MORNING.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR MINING AN ACT RELATING
TO MEDICARE.
SENATOR MONNING COLLEAGUES IF WE
COULD HAVE QUIET QUIET IN THE
BACK OF THE HALL PLEASE SHIFT
THEIR CONVERSATIONS GOING ON
MUCH LOWER THERE.
ARE VOICES PLEASE.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO SENATOR
MINING THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS -- RECENTLY INSURERS
HAVE BEGAN ADDING NON MEDICAL
INNOVATIVE BENEFITS TO THE MOST
POPULAR MEDIGAP PACKAGES IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DISTINGUISH THEIR
PRODUCT FROM OTHERS IN THE
MARKET PLACE.
WHILE THESE BENEFITS OF VISION
DENTAL AND HEARING TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL COVERAGE THE
INCLUSION OF THESE NON STANDARD
BENEFITS INSIDE THE STANDARD
MEDIGAP PACKAGE HINDER THE
ABILITY OF CONSUMERS. TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL COMPARISONS BETWEEN
NON MEDICAL BENEFITS DUE TO THE
COMPLEXITY IN VARIATION OFFERED
BY INSURERS.
SENATE BILL FOUR SEVEN SIMPLY
PROHIBITS THE PRACTICES AND
BEDDING NON MEDICAL BENEFITS
INTO THE BODY OF A STANDARD
MEDIGAP PLAN.
IN LIMIT THOSE BENEFITS TO
WRITERS THAT CAN BE SOLD
SEPARATELY PRICED SEPARATELY AND
HAVE NO EFFECT ON THE OVERALL
CLAIMS COST OF A MEDIGAP PLAN.
THIS BILL SETS CONSUMER FOCUSED
STANDARDS WHICH WILL PROTECT AND
ALLOW SENIORS TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND ALL ASPECTS OF AN
INNOVATIVE PLAN.
THAT THEY MAY SEEK TO PURCHASE
AGAIN THE BILL DOES NOT GET RID
OF THE INNOVATIVE PLANS IT
SIMPLY SEGREGATES THEM AS AN
INDEPENDENT WRITER.
SO HEN YOU'RE COMPARING ONE
MEDIGAP PLAN TO ANOTHER.
YOU'RE COMPARING APPLES TO
APPLES AND NOT APPLES TO ORANGES
I ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER MORNING ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE OSEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I SADDAM.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO BROWN [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE KING [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I WILK.
NOW ALL EYES TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES AT THIS POINT TIME WE
ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS.
ON FILE ITEMS THIRTY SEVEN AND
FORTY FIVE WILL GO THROUGH THIS
ONE TIME.
LIFTING THE CALLS ON FILE ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
GROVE NO MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI.
OUR EYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS.
PAN.
HI.
TWENTY VICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WE
HAVE.
WE HAVE IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER A A COLLEAGUE FROM THE
GREAT STATE OF WASHINGTON.
WASHINGTON STATE SENATOR TIM
SHELTON WHO REPRESENTS THE
THIRTY FIFTH LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICT LET'S GIVE HIM A WARM
CALIFORNIA SENATE WELCOME.
WELCOME TO OUR CHAMBER.
IT IS OUR UNDERSTAND HE'S BEEN
ADDED FOR TWENTY NINE TWENTY
NINE YEARS SO CONGRATULATIONS
AND CONDOLENCES.
AND WITH THAT COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU -- MADAM PRESIDENT TO
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MADDIE
LOUNGE AT NOON.
AND I THINK WE'LL RECONVENE AT
ONE THIRTY SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS OFF SITE
PLEASE GET THEIR EXPEDITIOUSLY.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS STARTING AT NOON IN THE
MADDIE LONE TREE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS OFF SITE. TO BEGIN
EXPEDITIOUSLY WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES WE WILL STAND IN.
RECESS UNTIL ONE THIRTY PM
[inaudible]
COULD WE PLEASE HAVE ALL
SENATORS BACK ON THE SENATE
FLOOR WE'RE ABOUT TO BEGIN OUR
AFTERNOON SESSION ALL SENATORS
PLEASE ON THE SENATE FLOOR
.
I COLLEAGUES WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY THREE BY SENATOR PAN
SB.
FIVE TWELVE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TO ABOUT
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
OUR COULD WE GIVE OUR ATTENTION
PLEASE TO SENATOR PAN WE ARE ON
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY THREE SENATOR PAM THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATOR SIDE TODAY
RICE BRING YOU SB FIVE TWELVE IS
WHICH IS A BILL THAT TAKES THE
FIRST CRITICAL STEP. TO CREATING
NEW LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS OUR L. TSS.
BENEFIT FOR CALIFORNIANS LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ARE
NOT ADEQUATELY COVERED BY
MEDICARE IN MOST CALIFORNIANS
CANNOT AFFORD TO PURCHASE
PRIVATE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
SB FIVE TWELVE TREAT A FRAMEWORK
FOR THE MANAGEMENT OF A LONG
TERM SERVICES SUPPORTS BENEFIT
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
PACIFIC LEE THE BILL CREATES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S RATETO DESIGN AND
FINANCE A NEW BENEFIT WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD NOW TO PUT THESE
CRITICAL PLATE PIECES IN PLACE
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE BENEFIT
FINANCING DESIGN.
I SUSPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THIRTY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY THREE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BY BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT OFF [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER HIGHGROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO.
BY JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI I'M ACQUIRED BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI AMBERG [inaudible]
IA CATHY.
I WINNER BY WILK HI.
SENATOR PAN MOVES TO CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK NOW
COLLEAGUES TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR HUESO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION SENATOR
HUESO THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SB FOUR SIXTEEN IS A BILL TO
EXTEND.
WORKERS COMPENSATION TO ALL
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR EMPLOYING
AGENCY.
WORKERS COMPENSATION IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERY WORKER
SHOULD BE ENTITLED.
TO ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
INHERENTLY PUT THEMSELVES IN
HARM'S WAY DURING THE TIME OF
THE OF OF THE CLOCK.
CURRENT LAW CREATES PRESUMPTIONS
WERE SPECIFIC INJURY OR
ILLNESSES ARE LOGICALLY WORK
RELATED.
BUT GENERALLY AFFORD SEIZE
PRESUMPTIONS TO PEACE OFFICERS
BASED UPON THEIR EMPLOYING
AGENCY RATHER THAN THEIR STATUS
AS A DUTIES AS PEACE OFFICERS SO
IF YOU WORK AS A PEACE OFFICER
ONE FOR ONE AGENCY NOT.
AFFORDED THE SAME PROTECTIONS
THAN IF YOU WORK FOR AN OTHER
AGENCY IT'S THE SAME KIND OF
WORK UNFORTUNATELY WE WE DON'T
TREAT ALL OFFICERS THE SAME.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THIS WOULD FIX THAT.
OUR STATE PEOPLE CHAVEZ WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO PROTECT US AND
KEEP US SAFE.
WE OWE IT TO THESE OFFICERS TO
IN TURN TO WHAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT THEM SHOULD THEY BECOME
INJURED OR SURE THEY UP UP FIND
THEMSELVES.
AFFECTED BY ONE OF THESE
PRESUMPTIONS THEY CAN IN AS THE
IN ESSENCE GO BANKRUPT AS A
TRYING TO GET COVERAGE -- I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO HELP
PROTECT OUR OFFICERS TO PROTECT
US EVERY DAY THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- WAS
ABOUT SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO I WAS
INVITED. TO GO TO THE STATE
ASSOCIATION COUNTY.
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS ALSO KNOWN AS
SECTORS.
AND THEY GIVE ME THE CHALLENGE
TO DEBATE MARK SALADINO WHO WAS
THE TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND SO THEY COULD THE DEBATE WAS
THE DEFINED BENEFIT VERSUS
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION AND THEY
ALLOWED ME.
TO WITH A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION.
PERSON SO WE HAD THIS
INTERESTING DEBATE I GOT UP AND
I SHARED ALL MY CONCERNS ABOUT
DEFINED BENEFIT.
PLANS AND WHAT KIND OF ABUSES
WERE OCCURRING.
INCLUDING.
HAVING VERY HIGH RATES OF RETURN
ASSUMPTIONS.
AND AND THAT AND THEN IT WAS
MARK'S TURN AND MARK IT UP WHEN
HE STARTED TALKING ABOUT.
SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS THAT
NEEDED TO BE IMPROVED AND WHY
DEFINED BENEFIT PLANS ARE
GETTING TO BE SO EXPENSIVE AND
UNSUSTAINABLE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE
BROUGHT UP WAS THE PRESUMPTIVE'S
HOW MANY PRESUMPTIVE'S THEY WERE
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
OFFICIALS.
AND HOW IT WAS CREATING SUCH
HIGH DISABILITY COSTS ARE JUST
BECAUSE THIS WAS ANOTHER AREA
THAT CAN BE ABUSED SO COLLEAGUES.
BRING THAT OVER TO THE WORKERS
COMP ARENA I THINK WE'VE GOT TO
BE CAREFUL WITH WHAT WE CREATE
AS A PRESUMPTIVE WORD NOTHING IS
DONE OTHER THAN SAYING BUT YOU
ARE IN THIS PROFESSION AND
THEREFORE.
YOU GET TO GET THIS BENEFIT SO I
I THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
WORK CAN BE REDUCED
PRESUMPTIVE'S NOT WHERE WE CAN
INCREASE THEM.
SO I WILL BE A NO VOTE ON SB
FOUR ONE SIX THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THOSE OF US WHO HAD THE TIME TO
GO OUT. TO THE LAWN HERE JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO AND AND BE THERE
WITH ALL THOSE FAMILIES MEN AND
WOMEN IN UNIFORM THAT CAME
TOGETHER FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
POLICE OFFICERS AGENCIES HIGH
WILL PATROL THEY CAME AS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
THIS BILL BRINGS A SENSE OF OF
RELIEF TO ALL THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT THEY KNOW THAT WE AS
ELECTED AS WHETHER BE CENTERS
ASSEMBLY BAND COUNCIL MEMBERS
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE ACROSS THIS
NATION ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT WE SUPPORT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THEY DO THE
SACRIFICES THEY MAKE EVERY DAY.
IN THE DANGERS THEY HAVE MAYBE
IN THE AUTOMOBILE MAYBE JUST IN
THE STREET BUT WHATEVER IT IS
THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
BEHIND HIM THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
HUESO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I I THINK THE THE
THE SUBJECT OF COST THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT BUT THERE IS.
A ALL ALTHOUGH A PRESUMPTION --
EXTENDS A BENEFITTED DOESN'T --
OF FULL IT DOESN'T -- FUND.
A CONDITION IF IT IS NOT WORK
RELATED AT THE END THERE'S A
PROCESS BUT WALL ALL OUR
OFFICERS ARE GOING THROUGH THIS
CARE -- THEY THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO BE ALLOWED TO SPEND -- THIS
MONEY OUT OF POCKET.
OUR OUR SYSTEM OF HEALTH CARE
SHOULD SHOULD SHOULD COVER --
PEOPLE AND AND GIVE THEM THE THE
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED BUT YOU
KNOW WHEN WHEN WE WE HAVE.
A SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA THAT
OUR OFFICERS ARE VERY.
DANGEROUS POSITIONS AND IT'S
HARD HARD GETTING HARDER AND
HARDER TO FILL THESE POSITIONS
STATEWIDE WE HAVE A LOT OF
VACANCIES.
IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
SO OF THIS GIVES -- DISADVANTAGE
TO CERTAIN AGENCIES THAT ARE
TRYING TO HIRE THAT DON'T HAVE
EQUAL BENEFITS THAT HEY CAN
AFFORD THEIR OFFICERS AND AND
AND THIS WILL CORRECT THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BY BATES.
NO BILL.
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHANGE [inaudible]
NO DOT [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI HILL.
AYE HUESO BY OUR TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE
[inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BY CASKEY I WIENER BY WILK
[inaudible]
NO.
SENATOR HUESO MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
FOUR SENATOR WHITE CASKEY.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SIX SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 520% HERTZBERG AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS YOU
PERSONALLY ARE KEENLY AWARE.
SOME TWENTY YEARS AGO.
SOME TWENTY YEARS AGO WE WERE
FACED WITH AN EXTRAORDINARY
ENERGY CRISIS.
THAT CRISIS OCCURRED AT THE TIME
WERE ONLY 15% OF OUR ENERGY
MARKET WAS OCCUPIED BY AND SEES
OTHER THAN INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES.
PUBLIC A P. UC INVESTOR OWNED
AND YET THE IMPACT AS WE KNOW
WAS NOTHING LESS THAN
EXTRAORDINARY.
AND OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
OR ENERGY.
LANDSCAPE HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY.
WE NOW HAVE NEARLY 44% OF OUR
ENERGY PROVIDED BY EITHER
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATION OR
DIRECT ACCESS.
AND ALTHOUGH THESE RETAIL
CHOICES HAVE GROWN DRAMATICALLY
NOT ALL LOAD SERVING IT IS
SERVING ENTITIES ARE REGULATED
LEAVING THOSE CUSTOMERS
POTENTIALLY WITHOUT.
KEY CONSUMER AND PRICE
PROTECTIONS.
LAST YEAR FOLLOWING AN EXTENSIVE
SERIES OF PUBLIC UTILITY
WORKSHOPS PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION WORKSHOPS IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT THE FINDING THAT
WE NEED TO PROVIDE FOR AND
DEFINE WHAT WAS CALLED A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT.
WHICH IS THE SUBJECT MATTER OF
THIS BILL.
IN ADDITION BY THE GOVERNOR
STRIKE TEAM IDENTIFIED IN ITS
REPORT THAT HAVING A PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT AS A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN IN THERE WILD FIRE AND
ENERGY FUTURES REPORT.
SO THIS MEASURE IN THE LARGER
ARCHITECTURE OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING AS WE MOVE MORE TOWARD
RENEWABLES AND THE AND
UNDERLYING ENERGY PROFILE THAT
EXISTS IN DELIVERING ELECTRICITY
TOOK ALL CALIFORNIANS WE NEED TO
PROVIDE FOR A BASIC SAFETY NET
FOR ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS.
BY DESIGNATING A PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT.
THIS MEASURE DESIGNATES INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AS PROVIDERS OF
LAST RESORT FOR THEIR
DISTRIBUTION SERVICE AREAS
INCLUDING CUSTOMERS FOR CCA'S
AND YES P. IS CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT PRACTICES HOWEVER WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IN THIS MEASURES PART
OF A COMPROMISE.
IS IT A I IS I OWE YOU MAY
TRANSFER THE PROVIDER OF LAST
RESORT RESPONSIBILITY TO ANOTHER
PROVIDER THAT WANTS TO SERVE
THATFUNCTION.
AS LONG AS IT MEETS CERTAIN
IMPORTANT NECESSARY FOR NATURAL
OB OF FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
A DOOR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
IS THIRD DEBATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
BY PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
HI DOT.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HI GROW.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON BY JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
BY HAMBURG IA CATHY BYE WINNER
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WE WILL THEN CLOSE THE ROLE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES [inaudible]
COPY CABALLERO [inaudible]
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO.
HI.
GUYS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WITHOUT OBJECTION
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
TO FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTEEN SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AND
ACTUALLY DO PEOPLE ATTENDANCE
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT I
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB -- THREE TWENTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT I THINK IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE TO THE YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
DECADES EDUCATORS HAVE SEARCHED
FOR A WAY TO FIND SOMETHING THAT
WORKS AND DUPLICATED AND
REPLICATED APART ACROSS
DEMOGRAPHICS.
ACROSS SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS
ACROSS [inaudible]
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATIONS ACROSS
STATES -- THEY'VE ALWAYS
STRUGGLE BECAUSE PART OF WHAT
MAKES EDUCATION WORK I THE ART
OF THE PEOPLE INVOLVED AND IT'S
HARD TO REPLICATE.
WELL IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
AFTER LOOKING AT THREE DECADES
THREE DECADES OF RESEARCH THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL.
RECOMMENDED THAT HIGH SCHOOL AND
MIDDLE SCHOOL START TIME BE
MOVED [inaudible]
DAY.
THIRTY AND OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY FROM EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC.
CHOSE TO FOLLOW THAT
RECOMMENDATION OF THE
PEDIATRICIANS.
AND THE INDEPENDENT THINKERS AT
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL.
AND THREE DECADES OF RESEARCH
AND THEY MOVE THEIR START TIME
LATER.
AND A REMARKABLE THING STARTED
TO HAPPEN.
STUDENTS STARTED TO SHOW UP IN
CLASSES MORE FREQUENTLY.
THEY WERE ALERT.
THEY STARTED TO PERFORM BETTER
ACADEMICALLY.
SO TENANTS WHAT UP GRADUATION
RATE WENT UP.
AND SOME OTHER REMARKABLE THING
STARTED TO HAPPEN.
CAR ACCIDENTS WENT DOWN.
THE INCIDENCES OF SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS WENT DOWN AND I FOR ONE
DON'T EVER WANT TO READ IN THE
NEWSPAPER READ ANOTHER YOUNG
PERSON.
WHO'S TAKEN THEIR LIFE THROUGH
SUICIDE.
AND SO WE KNOW FOR EVERY
ADDITIONAL OUR TEENS.
SUICIDE GOES DOWN 11%.
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY
IS A RESEARCH BASED PROVEN.
WAY. TO INCREASE ATTENDANCE AND
INCREASE OUR TEENS HEALTH LET ME
SAY THAT AGAIN TEST SCORES GO UP.
CAR ACCIDENTS AND SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS GO DOWN AS LONG WITH
DRUG USE MARIJUANA USE OBESITY
ALL GO DOWN AS WELL.
NOW INITIALLY WHEN IT WAS
PROPOSED PEOPLE SAID WELL WHAT
ABOUT ZERO PERIOD.
WELL WE EXEMPTED OUT ZERO PERIOD.
AND THEN THEY SAID WELL WHAT
ABOUT.
WORKING PARENTS VERY GOOD
QUESTION TO ASK AND WE SHOWED
THEM THE DATA AND IN PARTICULAR
THE RECENT DATA FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON THAT
SHOW THE BIGGEST INCREASE.
IN ATTENDANCE WAS FROM CHILDREN
WORKING PARENT HOUSEHOLDS
BECAUSE THERE'S A SOCIAL JUSTICE
COMPONENT TO THIS BILL AS WELL
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM
CHILDREN AND WORKING FAMILY
HOUSEHOLDS ARE THE MOST SLEEP
DEPRIVED CHILDREN.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE MOST
COMPLICATIONS IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD.
UNLIKE SUBURBAN CHILDREN WHICH
HAVE MORE ADVANTAGES SO THE VERY
COHORT.
THAT PEOPLE EXPRESSED TO CARE
ABOUT SEE SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT ACADEMIC GAINS AND
SOCIAL GAINS AND ATTENDANCE IS
INCREASED GREAT QUESTION.
THE DATA PROVES ELSE WISE WHEN
WE CLARIFIED ZERO PERIOD WHEN WE
GAVE IT STAGGER START TIME TO
MIDDLE SCHOOL.
THE MOST RECENT OBJECTION IS
WELL EIGHTY A IS GOING TO SUFFER
AGAIN.
A GOOD QUESTION TO ASK BUT THE
DATA SHOWS THE OPPOSITE
ATTENDANCE WILL INCREASE IF THE
LA UNIFIED SHOWS A 1% INCREASE
IN ATTENDANCE TO THE LATE START.
THEY WOULD SEE A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE TO THEIR
BUDGET.
SAID WELL WHAT ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS WELL.
RAND CORPORATION THAT AN
INDEPENDENT ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
THAT SHOWS THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY WOULD IMPROVE BY TEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF LATE START.
HOW MANY BILLS IS THIS FOR
PASSED ON SUSPENSIONS WELL GUESS%
WHAT SUSPENSIONS GO DOWN
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR GOES DOWN
OTHER BEHAVIORS IN THE CLASSROOM
GO DOWN AFTER THE LATE START?
SO FUNDAMENTALLY BY HAVING TEENS
SLEEP ACCORDING TO THEIR
BIOLOGICAL CLOCK.
AND MOVING START TIME
ACCORDINGLY WE APPROVE.
ATTENDANCE.
GRADES AND GRADUATION RATE AND
WE DECREASE ALL OF THE THINGS WE
DEEPLY CARE ABOUT AND THINGS
WE'VE RUN MANY BILLS THAT'S NOT
ANECDOTE.
THAT'S FACTUAL DATA SUPPORTED
THE CONCLUSION SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR PORTANTINO.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TOPIC SOMEONE
NEEDS TO GET UP AND JUST ASK A
FEW QUESTIONS TO MAKE SOME
OBSERVATIONS I THINK IT WAS.
IN THE LOUNGE FOR SOMEONE SAID
TO ME.
I LIKE PROGRESS IT'S IT'S CHANGE
I DON'T LIKE [inaudible]
SO A PUSHING BACK THE TIME THAT
SCHOOL START.
MAKING IT MANDATORY THIS FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING NOT OPTIONAL.
IS IS A MASSIVE CHANGE THAT WE
WILL BE.
IMPOSING ON OUR NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
ARE [inaudible]
NOT RURAL.
SO IF DISRUPTING THE WORK
SCHEDULES -- OF PERRANCE IS NOT
ENOUGH TO OPPOSE SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT WILL ALSO
MAKE A MAD AT A MAJOR IMPACT ON
THE TRANSPORTATION FOR GETTING
STUDENTS TO SCHOOL.
WHICH MEANS THAT THE BUS SYSTEMS
FOR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL
ALSO BE MODIFIED AND ARE LOOKING
AT INCREASED COSTS.
AND I'M REALLY CONCERNED
COLLEAGUES ABOUT OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEY'RE INCURRING
ANYMORE INCREASED COSTS.
HAVING LOOKED AT THE NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AUDITED FINANCIAL REPORTS IT'S
VERY DISCOURAGING AND THE NEW
ONES ARE COMING OUT IN THE%
BOTTOM.
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THERE.
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT IS
GOING UP ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
SO IF THE CLAIMS THAT REVENUES
WILL INCREASE THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S A GOOD FACT.
BUT I'M NOT SO SURE IT WILL BE
ENOUGH TO OFFSET THE EXPENSES
THAT WILL BE INCURRED IN.
THE TRANSPORTATION AREA OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT [inaudible]
JUNE. THIRTY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE SACRAMENTO CITY.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT HAD AN
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION.
THEY JUST CAME OUT WITH THEIR
KAFFIR.
A FEW WEEKS AGO.
THIS YEAR JUNE THIRTY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT IS NOW. ONE BILLION.
SIXTY FIVE IT'S DOUBLED IN ONE
YEAR WHICH COULD BE THE RETIREE
MEDICAL WE HAVE SERIOUS
FINANCIAL ISSUES.
FACING OUR DISTRICT SO BEFORE WE
ENCUMBER.
THE DISTRICTS ANYMORE LET'S MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE STRONG BALANCE
SHEETS AND LET'S MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE LOCAL CONTROL.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE ON SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU SIR
MORE LIKE SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU CAN A PRESIDENT.
BUT CERTAINLY THE SATIN LISTEN
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY GIVE US THE VARIOUS
REASONS WHY WE SHOULDN'T SUPPORT
THE BILL.
IT STRUCK ME THAT AT NO POINT
DID ANY OF HIS ARGUMENTS ADDRESS
THE NEEDS.
OF THE STUDENTS.
IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO
EDUCATE.
OUR KIDS THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
AND SO WHILE I APPRECIATE
CHANGES HARD FOR SOME.
MANY OF US HAVE TRAVELED AROUND
THE WORLD AND HAS SEEN COUNTRIES
WHERE KIDS GO TO SCHOOL SIX
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK WE'RE CLEAR
THAT OUR SEPTEMBER TO JUNE IS
BASED ON AN AGRARIAN SYSTEM THAT
NO LONGER IMPACTS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
SCHOOL ACROSS.
THIS GREAT STATE.
AND YET ON THIS FLOOR WE
CONTINUE TO DEBATE SCHOOL
READINESS GRADUATION RATES OF
THE EMPLOYERS ARE IN OUR
DISTRICTS TALK ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THE NEXT GENERATION OF OF
EMPLOYEES ARE INNOVATORS FOR
THAT MATTER ARE GOING TO BE
PREPARED. TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE GRAY CITY CALIFORNIA.
SO I HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE OPEN
MINDED ENOUGH. TO RELY ON THE
DATA AND RESEARCH. TO REALLY
DETERMINE WHAT DO STUDENTS NEED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND BUILD A DISTRICT ANY SYSTEM
AROUND THAT.
AS OPPOSED TO WHAT HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN OUR PATTERN
PRACTICE.
AND TO REALLY BE WILLING TO PUSH
THE ENVELOPE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DEVELOPING A SYSTEM IN AND
FUNDING A SYSTEM.
THAT MEETS THEIR FUNDAMENTAL
NEEDS FOR THOSE REASONS I AM
PROUD TO STAND WITH YOU IN
SUPPORT SENATE BILL.
THREE TWO EIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR MORRELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- WERE IN A STATE OF
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE -- AS WE NOW --
IN THIS -- BILL IS A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL.
AND I THINK ALL OF US WHENEVER
WE SPEAK.
TO OUR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES WE
WE ALL TALK ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL
AND I'D LIKE TO LEAVE IT WITH
LOCAL CONTROL BECAUSE I'VE HAD A
NUMBER CALLS FROM.
FROM PARENTS M. FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEY ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS AND SO I I DO
BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL LIKE I
DO TRUST THE PARENTS.
AS WELL AS THE VERY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MY DOESN'T BUT
DISTRICT TO MAKE A BETTER
DECISION. TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISION FOR THEIR KIDS.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I WILL BE A NO
VOTE BECAUSE AGAIN I I TRUST THE
PARENTS IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
THE FIGURE THIS OUT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORALE SENATOR
PAM.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH -- MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM LIKE KONATA.
BUT RATES FOR BRING THIS -- FOR
THIS BILL IS BASED ON AS HE OF
PRESENT IN THE BEGINNING --
EXTREMELY STRONGLY THE PELLING
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE A VERY POSITIVE
IMPACT.
ON OUR KIDS AND OUR ABILITY TO
LEARN.
AND WHAT WE THINK ABOUT.
OUR TEENAGERS WHEN THEY GO TO
SCHOOL WE HAVE A WINDOW OF TIME
IN WHICH TO EDUCATE THEM RIGHT
LEAD DOWN DAIS.
AND IF WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL AND WE OFTEN
SAY THAT HERE IN.
TO PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT TO ECHO
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES.
QUESTION IS IS THAT OUR OUR OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUPPOSED TO BE
DESIGNED TO HELP OUR STUDENTS.
OUR STUDENTS MERELY THERE TO
SHOW UP AT A SCHOOL THAT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY OPTIMALLY MEET THEIR
NEEDS.
I APPRECIATE.
THAT -- MY GOOD FRIEND IT.
IN ORANGE COUNTY MENTIONED WHEN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT MY VERY OWN --
DISTRICT SENATE DISTRICT I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY'RE FACING THERE ARE
ACTUALLY -- NOT.
BECAUSE OF SCHOOL START TIMES IT
HAS TO DO WITH OTHER ISSUES --
BUT AGAIN IT WE ARE HERE TO TRY
TO BE SURE THAT WE HELP OUR
STUDENTS.
SO THE EVIDENCE IS THERE THE
EVIDENCE IS STRONG.
AND THAT IS WHY I AM PROUD -- TO
THE ONLY SUPPORT THE BILL TO BE
A CO AUTHOR AND I AGAIN WANT TO
THANK.
MY GOOD FRIEND FOR FOR BEING
THIS FOR TO BE SURE WE PUT OUR
KIDS FIRST THAT'S WHAT THIS
SHOULD BE ABOUT OUR KIDS.
AND THEIR LEARNING SHOULD COME
FIRST AND WE SHOULD THEN FIGURE
OUT HOW WE MAKE -- BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE AND HOW WE MAKE.
OUR SCHOOLS MOST EFFECTIVE FOR
THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR
GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO APPLY THE AUTHOR FROM
THE DILIGENT RESEARCH THAT HE
DID DO YOU WANT IT AND THE TO BE
HONEST THE FIRST TIME HE CAME TO
SPEAK TO ME ABOUT IT I KIND OF
JUST LEFT HIM OUT OF MY CHAIR.
AM I THOUGHT YOU'RE KIDDING ME
BECAUSE I GREW UP IN WE DIDN'T
REALLY EVER HAVE A CURFEW BUT WE
HAD A WAKE UP TIME RIGHT MY MOM
IS THEREFORE CLOCK IN THE
MORNING YOU GOT IT YOU DID YOUR
CHORES TO DO WE SUPPOSED TO DO.
AND THEN YOU WHICH WORK SO AT
EIGHT O'CLOCK YOU'RE READY TO GO
TO BED -- AND SO I I DID BUT
AFTER TALKING TO THE AUTHOR AND
LISTENING TO ALL THE DATA IN THE
INFORMATION THAT HE PROVIDED
THERE IS STUDIES OUT THERE THAT
SHOW.
THAT -- TEENAGERS THE WAY THEY
GROW THE WAY THEIR MIND WORKS --
MELATONIN ISSUES HE DID MAKE A
VERY COMPELLING ARGUMENT SO I
DID DO THAT DUE DILIGENCE ON MY
SIDE REACH OUT TO MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
BEING FROM A RURAL COMMUNITY
AGAIN FROM THE VALLEY MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE VERY VERY MUCH
OPPOSED TO IT THE REASON WHY IS
BECAUSE IT AFFECTS ED. NINETY
END THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE SO
THEY'D HAVE TO HAVE TWO SEPARATE
TRANSPORTATION BUS SCHEDULES
WITH THERE'S VERY LITTLE FUNDING
FOR TRANSPORTATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND IF YOU CAN'T GET
STUDENTS. TO SCHOOL TO LEARN --
BASED ON A TRANSPORTATION ISSUE
BECAUSE SOME HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
YOU KNOW TWELVE FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
MILES AWAY FROM WHERE STUDENTS
LIVE AND SO THERE'S A HUGE
CONCERN ABOUT TRANSPORTATION AND
FINDING AND THERE IS A HUGE
ISSUE.
WITH LOCAL CONTROL AND SETTING
THE HOURS AND THEN CONTRACT
LABOR AGREEMENTS AS WELL --
WHERE THEY HAVE THE CTA OR THAT
THE TEACHERS AT NEGOTIATE WORK
SCHEDULES AND SO I DO APPLAUD
YOU FOR ALL YOUR DUE DILIGENCE
AND THE I I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BUT BECAUSE OF THE DISTRICT A
RESPONSE THAT I GOT AND OF
COURSE A?
YOU KNOW THE DISTRICT IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN MY DISTRICT I HAVE
TO POSE YOUR BILL BUT I'D I DO
THINK YOU WANNA YOU DID BRING ME
A LONG WAY SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN -- LIKE
TO ASK A QUESTION THE AUTHOR IN
AND TAKE A LOT OF YOU TAKE A
QUESTION CENTER PORTENT I WILL
TAKE A QUESTION THANK YOU THE
GENERAL FUND PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I MEAN
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION IT JUST
CAME OUT.
ON ICE MASON THE NOTHING IN THE
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT IF I WAS A
SERIOUS CONCERN ABOUT ABOUT IT
DO WILL START TIME. FOR THE
ELEMENTARY'S AT VERSES THE
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS.
NOTHING IN THE BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE DISTRICT FROM
STARTING EVERYBODY THE SAME TIME
SO THAT LATER IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT OKAY.
THAT WAS THE FIRST THING THE
SECOND THING I I JUST WANT TO
RESPOND TO THE ISSUE OF THE
CONTROL BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I SHARE AND I FIND MYSELF --
YOU KNOW NOT VOTING FOR EVERY
BILL THAT COMES BEFORE US THAT
IMPINGES UPON SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OF CONTROL BECAUSE I MYSELF
SERVE ON THE SCHOOL BOARD.
I AM ALWAYS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THESE KINDS OF ISSUES WHAT
BRINGS ME TO SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL IS MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE HAVING SERVED ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD HAVING LOOKED INTO
THIS VERY ISSUE BECAUSE I SAW
THE SIGN SO YOU SAW -- BUT BACK
WHEN I WAS ON THE BOARD AND I
LOOKED I KIND OF EXPLORING THE
IDEA OF MOVING UP ARE START TIME
IN MY LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND WHAT I WAS TOLD WAS THAT
THERE WAS NO WAY WE COULD DO IT
OUR ON OUR OWN BECAUSE OF SPORTS
SCHEDULES AND THE IMPACT ON ON
ON ON THAT WITH REGARDS TO ALL
THE OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
WE INTERACT WITH AND PLAYED WITH
AN ENGAGED WITH.
AND SO THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE I
ACTUALLY THINK IT'S OKAY FOR US
TO BE -- AND PINGING ON LOCAL
CONTROL BECAUSE THERE IS A
COLLECTIVE ACTION ISSUE HERE --
IT WITH ONE SCHOOL IF IF SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S GONNA GO OFF ON THEIR
OWN IN DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS IT
MESSES UP THE ENTIRE ATHLETIC
SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT WILL BE --
VERY PROBLEMATIC AND SO -- THAT
THAT THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I THINK -- IT'S IT'S
WORTH -- STEPPING IN AND TAKING
A STATE ACTION ON ON ON THIS
NARROW ISSUE THAT REALLY DOES
ULTIMATELY RELATE A GREAT DEAL
TO THE BIOLOGICAL PATTERNS AND
HEALTH.
OF OUR TEENAGERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
IT IS YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU A
MATTER PRESIDENT I CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF THE COMMENTS -- DURING
MY CLOTHES I KNOW WE WANT TO
KEEP MOVING BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT -- FIRST OF ALL THE
ACTED THE ECONOMIC QUESTIONS ARE
AGAIN THE RIGHT QUESTION TO ASK --
BUT THERE IS NO DATA TO SUPPORT
THE NOTION THAT IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE COSTS AND ACTUALLY THE
RAND CORPORATION STUDY SAYS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR SCHOOL DISTRICT
INVEST.
IN LATE START THEY'RE GONNA
RETURN FOR DID FOUR DOLLARS BACK
SO THERE'S ECONOMIC DATA TO SHOW
THE CONTRARY ON THE BUS
SCHEDULES WE TRIED TO BE
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE WHICH IS WHY
WE SAID A DIFFERENT MINIMUM FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN A DIFFERENT
MINIMUM. FOR HIGH SCHOOL
PRECISELY TO GIVE DISTRICTS THAT
FLEXIBILITY. TO WORK OUT THEIR
LOGISTICS AND THAT'S A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT POINT WE ARE NOT
SETTING A HARD TIME.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT SETS A
MINIMUM STANDARD BASED ON
RESEARCH FOR HEALTH AND WELFARE?
THAT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN SETTING
A MINIMUM STANDARD ON LEAD PAINT.
OR ON A SPACE THIS YOU SET
MINIMUM CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS
BASED ON SCIENCE WERE SETTING A
MINIMUM HEALTH AND WELFARE
STANDARD.
BASED ON THE RECOMMENDATION OF
PEDIATRICIANS AND THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND THEN
FINALLY AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES AND THE GOOD
PEDIATRICIAN FROM SACRAMENTO
POINTED OUT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DOING WHAT'S
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF OUR
CHILDREN.
AND THAT'S NOT A MONETARY
CONVERSATION THAT'S A HUMAN.
CONVERSATION OUR CHILDREN WILL
BE HEALTHIER HAPPIER AND PERFORM
BETTER AND FRANKLY TAKE THEIR
OWN LIFE.
LIFE LESS IF WE DO LATE START
AND THE RESEARCHERS IN THEIR
CONCLUDING STATEMENT ALWAYS
ENDED WITH WE KNOW THERE WILL BE
ADULT LOGISTICAL CONCERNS.
BUT THE OVERRIDING HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF OUR CHILDREN DEMAND
THAT WE MAKE THAT STATEMENT NOW
I'VE DONE THE IMPOSSIBLE I'VE
UNITED RESEARCHERS FROM STANFORD
AND CAL.
WHO SENT LETTERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND I JUST WANT TO READ YOU
WHAT IF WITH YOUR PERMISSION
PERMISSION TO READ?
THE CLOSING STATEMENT.
MATTER PRESENT PERMISSION TO
READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION GREAT FROM --
MATTHEW WALKER PHD PROFESSOR OF
NEUROSCIENCE NEUROSCIENCE AND
PSYCHOLOGY DIRECTOR CENTER OF
HUMAN SLEEP SCIENCE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BERKELEY SO ALL
THE ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S GO BEARS.
HE GOES AS YOU CAN SEE THE
SCIENTIFICALLY MEASURABLE SLEEP
DEFICIENCY ASSOCIATED WITH EARLY
SCHOOL START TIMES RESULT IN
MARKED MENTAL PHYSICAL AND
ACADEMIC.
DAMAGE HE USED THE WORD DAMAGE.
IT IS OUR GOAL AS EDUCATORS TO
TRULY IS IF OUR GOAL AS
EDUCATORS IS TO TRULY EDUCATE.
AND NOT RISK THE LIVES.
IN THE PROCESS THEN I FEAR WE
ARE FAILING OUR NEXT GENERATION
WITH UNSUSTAINABLE MODELS OF
EARLY SCHOOL START TIMES HE USED
DAMAGE AND RISKS TO LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU FOR
AN AYE VOTE TO PUT SCIENCE AND
OUR CHILDREN FIRST THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NO BELL.
I PURCHASE [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY HERO [inaudible]
CHANGE.
JANE.
HI DODD.
BY THE RISE OF GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
NO GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
JACKSON BY JONES HI [inaudible]
LEYVA.
NO MCGUIRE
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NELSON.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BIO CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WERE JUST [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
STERN.
VICE TWENTY FOUR KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL GO
TO FILE ITEM OF ONE OH NINE FILE
ITEM ONE OH NINE COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR ROTH.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR ROTH AND ACT REALLY IN A
WATER.
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES.
FOR THOSE YOU WERE DOING OTHER
THINGS THIS IS THE COULD EASE
BILL.
BUT THAT WOULD GET YOUR
ATTENTION. FOR THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS COULD EASE A CORPORATE
LANDOWNER IN THE MOJAVE HIS
PROPOSED TO PUMP AN AVERAGE OF
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
OF WATER PER YEAR THAT'S OVER
SIXTEEN BILLION GALLONS A YEAR.
FOR FIFTY YEARS FROM THE AQUIFER
UNDER THE MOJAVE AND SELL IT TO
WATER DISTRICTS IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE AT A PROIT OF
COURSE. FOR PURPOSES OF
GUARANTEEING WATER SUPPLY TO
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND OR
MORE.
NEW HOMES THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THE SCIENCE UNDERLYING THIS
PROJECT IS IN SERIOUS CONFLICT
AS TO WHAT AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RATE REALLY
IS.
AND IF COULD EASE IS WRONG.
THAT LEVEL OF PUMPING THE
PUMPING PROPOSED.
COULD POTENTIALLY DESTROYING.
THE MOJAVE DESERT IN THE PROCESS
AND BY THE WAY WHEN THE PUMPING
STOPS.
IMPAIR THE WATER SUPPLY TO THOSE
NEW HOMES.
NOW THIS BILL SEEKS TO HIT THE
PAUSE BUTTON ON THIS MASSIVE
WATER EXTRACTION PROJECT.
IN THIS VERY FRAGILE ECOSYSTEM
THAT HAS EXISTED IN BALLOTS FOR
CENTURIES.
AND HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET THE SCIENCE
RIGHT THAT THE SCIENCE IS
RECONCILED.
THE PROJECT HAS BEEN STALLED.
FOR YEARS BECAUSE FRANKLY THE
MATH DOESN'T ADD UP.
AS I INDICATED KIDDIES WANTS TO
PULL FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET
PER YEAR OUT AND HAS NEVER
CHANGED AS TO THAT AMOUNT.
BUT ADMITS THAT THE AQUIFER ONLY
REFILLS AT THE RATE OF THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
NOW RENOWNED SCIENTISTS.
WORKING WITH THE U. S.
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY THE NATIONAL
PARK SERVICE AND OTHERS SAY THE
REFILL RATE IS MORE LIKE.
200-021-0000 ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
NOW IF THE CHILL OUT OF THE
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY IN THE PARK
SERVICE.
SCIENCE [inaudible]
IS CORRECT.
THAT'S AT LEAST FORTY THOUSAND
ACRE FEET PER YEAR THAT'S
FOURTEEN BILLION GALLONS LESS
THAN THE COULD THESE PLANS.
PULLING OUT MORE THAN GOES IN.
NOW CLEARLY THERE IS A SERIOUS
CONFLICT IN THE SCIENCE
SOMEWHERE HERE SURROUNDING THIS
PROJECT.
AND IF COULD DISS MISCALCULATED.
THE SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RIGHT
NOT ONLY WILL THE ECOSYSTEM IN
THE MOJAVE FACE DESTRUCTION BUT
AS I INDICATED BEFORE WE HAVE A
pSERIOUS PROBLEM WITH THOSE HOMES.
HAVE BEEN PROMISED WATER FROM
THIS PROJECT.
WE THINK THE CONFLICT SHOULD BE
RESOLVED BEFORE THE PUMPING
STARTS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES NO MORE.
NO LESS.
NOW YOU.
I HAVE HEARD AND LEE OR WILL
HEAR A LOT ABOUT SEQUEL.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS BILL ON
THE FLOOR.
AND HOW COULD THESE AND IT'S
PROJECT OF ONE FIVE OR SIX SIX
LAWSUITS.
AND THAT THE COURTS ARE RESOLVED
HAVE RESOLVED THE SCIENCE
CONFLICT IN FAVOR OF GOODIES AND
VALIDATED IT'S PUMPING PROPOSAL.
UNFORTUNATELY I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU THAT THAT IS SIMPLY NOT THE
CASE SEQUEL AS YOU KNOW IS A
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE STATUTE THAT
REQUIRES PROJECT PROPONENTS AND
THE COURTS. TO IDENTIFY
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF A
PROPOSED PROJECT AND WAYS TO
MITIGATE THOSE IMPACTS.
IN FACT IN REVIEWING THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE FOR AND
AGAINST THE PROJECT SUCH AS THE
PUMPING RATES HERE.
AS THE COURT IN COULD DISS OWN
CASE NOTED COURTS ARE NOT
PERMITTED TO WEIGH AND RESOLVE
CONFLICTS IN THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE PRESENTED.
AND THIS IS ESSENTIALLY THE
COURTS STATEMENT IN REVIEWING
THE LEAD AGENCIES ACTIONS UNDER
SEQUEL WE MAY NOT SET ASIDE.
AND AGENCIES APPROVAL OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT ON
THE GROUND THAT AN OPPOSITE
CONCLUSION WOULD HAVE BEEN
EQUALLY OR MORE REASONABLE.
IN CASE THERE'S ANY DOUBT AND
THERE SHOULDN'T BE SINCE I'VE
BEEN SAYING THE SAME THING SINCE
I GOT INVOLVED.
FROM WITH THIS BILL AT THE
OUTSET I'M NOT TRYING TO PREVENT
THE PUMPING OF WATER FROM THIS
AQUIFER BYE KIDDIES OR ANY
FUTURE LANDOWNER IN THE MOJAVE
I'M FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
NEED.
MORE WATER BUT I'M SIMPLY TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT ANY PUMPING NOW
OR IN THE FUTURE IS DONE IN AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE WAY
AND AT AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE RATE.
SO AS I SAID I THINK WE SHOULD
HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON HERE AND
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT TEAM OF
SCIENTISTS REVIEW THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE. FOR AND AGAINST THE
KIDDIES PROJECT AND RESOLVE THE
CONFLICT AND THEN BASED ON THOSE
WRITTEN FINDINGS WHICH THIS BILL
REQUIRES.
SENATE ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RATE ONE
THAT INSURERS AN UNINTERRUPTED
SUPPLY OF WATER TO ALL RESIDENTS
WHILE PROTECTING A NATIONAL
TREASURE IN THIS CASE THE MOJAVE.
FROM POTENTIAL MANMADE
DESTRUCTION THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THIS BILL DOES.
NOW WHY HASN'T KIDDIES MADE AN
EFFORT TO RECONCILE THE SCIENCE
EARLIER I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
IDEA.
NOW I'M GONNA ATTEMPT TO DEAL
WITH SOME OF COULD DISS CLAIMS
THAT I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD I'VE
CERTAINLY HEARD A LOT OF THEM.
AND I'VE CERTAINLY READ ABOUT A
LOT OF THEM IN THE HANDOUTS THAT
ARE FLOATING AROUND THIS
BUILDING.
NOW THE BILL DEALS WITH ADVERSE
EFFECTS ON NATURAL OR CULTURAL
RESOURCES.
COULD HE IS APPARENTLY CLAIMS
THAT THE TERM ADVERSE EFFECTS
AND THE ADVERSE EFFECTS STANDARD
IS AMBIGUOUS.
I WILL NOTE THAT THE STANDARD OF
ADVERSE EFFECT ISSUES
CONSISTENTLY THROUGHOUT SEQUEL
AND THE FEDERAL EQUIVALENT WHICH
IS DNIEPER.
BAND IS REFERENCED EIGHTY TIMES
EIGHT ZERO EIGHTY TIMES IN COULD
DISS OWN GROUNDWATER MONITORING
MITIGATION AND MANAGEMENT PLAN
FOR THIS PROJECT.
SO THE DEFINITIONS MUST BE
FAIRLY CLEAR TO COULD THESE AND
OTHERS SINCE COULD THESE PREPARE
THE PLAN.
KIDDIES EXPRESSES CONCERNS OVER
THE USE OF THE TERM CULTURAL
RESOURCES IN THIS BILL.
APPARENTLY CLAIMING NOT TO KNOW
WHAT THAT TERM MEANS.
IN FACT THE TERM CULTURAL
RESOURCES.
IS ALSO USED TO RUN IN SEQUEL.
AND IS DEFINED IN DETAIL IN
COULD DISS OWN ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT.
CHARACTERIZED ARE CATEGORIZED AS
ARCHAEOLOGICAL RESOURCES
HISTORIC RESOURCES CONTEMPORARY
NATIVE AMERICAN RESOURCE IS AND
PALEONTOLOGICAL RESOURCES THAT'S
WHAT CULTURAL RESOURCES MEANS
AND COULD THESE KNOWS THAT
BECAUSE COULD THESE TO FIND IT.
IN ITS OWN E. I. ARE.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD COULD THESE
SAY THAT IF ONE ADDITIONAL
MOLECULE OF ADVERSE IMPACT IS
FOUND AS A RESULT OF THIS STUDY
ONE ADDITIONAL MOLECULE.
THAT THE AGENCIES CAN KILL THE
PROJECT.
IN FACT IN THE CASE OF
COMMUNITIES FOR BETTER
ENVIRONMENT AND CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION A
CASE.
INVOLVING SEQUEL GUIDELINES HE
E. R. PREPARATION IN A
DISCUSSION OF THRESHOLDS OF
SIGNIFICANCE IN CUMULATIVE
IMPACTS.
THE COURT NOTED THE ONE
ADDITIONAL MOLECULE RULE IS NOT.
THE LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT IN ORDER TO BE
DETERMINATIVE THE ADVERSE IMPACT
MUST BE SIGNIFICANT SO ONE
MOLECULE SIMPLY WON'T CUT IT.
NOW I'VE TRIED TO ADDRESS THE
SEQUEL ISSUE AND AND THE OTHER
CLAIMS THAT THE BILL IS AIMED AT
STOPPING.
THE PROJECT'S IMPLEMENTATION.
ALTOGETHER BUT THERE'S ONE FINAL.
GOODIES CLAIM THAT DISTURBS ME
THE MOST.
AND THAT'S THE CLAIM THAT A TAX
MY INTEGRITY.
ASSERTING THAT DURING THIS
PROCESS I HAVE FAILED TO UPHOLD
THE COMMITMENTS I MADE TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITMENTS THAT I MADE THE
KIDDIES IN THE COMMITMENTS I
MADE EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
NOW YOU KNOW I'VE I SERVE THIRTY
TWO YEARS IN THE AIRFORCE.
AND IN THE AIRFORCE OUR MISSION
IT SENATE ROTH ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
IT IS GETTING A LITTLE NOISY UP
IN THE GALLERY I KNOW THERE ARE
A LOT OF YOUNG ONES HERE THEY'VE
BEEN HERE FOR A GOOD PORTION OF
THE DAY AND IT'S KIND OF HARD TO
STAY QUIET.
BUT I WOULD ASK THE PARENTS
PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR
CHILDREN'S VOICES DOWN OR TAKE
THEM OUTSIDE.
WELL WE HAVE THIS IMPORTANT
DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK ABOUT A PRESENT I CAN
CERTAINLY TALK OVER ANYONE.
IN MY THIRD QUESTIONS HARD TO
LISTEN -- FOR EVERYONE TO I WANT
TO HEAR WHAT YOUR WORDS ARE SO
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU MA'AM.
THIRTY TWO YEARS IN THE AIRFORCE
OUR AIRFORCE CORE VALUES WERE
AND CONTINUE TO BE INTEGRITY
FIRST SERVICE BEFORE SELF AND
EXCELLENCE IN ALL WE DO.
I HAVE CERTAINLY TRIED TO FOLLOW
THOSE CORE VALUES DURING MY
AIRFORCE SERVICE.
AND I'VE CERTAINLY TRIED TO DO
SO SENSE AND I HOPE THAT YOU
THINK I'VE SUCCEEDED.
I ALSO HOPE YOU AGREE THAT.
AT LEAST MY REPUTATION HERE IS
THAT I SAY WHAT I MEAN AND DO
WHAT I SAY.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE MY REACTION.
AND MY EXTREME DISAPPOINTMENT.
WHEN I LEARNED THAT MY INTEGRITY
WAS BEING CHALLENGED DURING THIS
PROCESS BY COULD COULD THESE
CLAIMING THAT I DID NOT HONOR MY
COMMITMENTS AND IN LEAST IN ONE
CASE THAT I LIVE?
I WANT TO TELL YOU AND I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU THAT I HAVE TRIED TO
WORK WITH KIDDIES THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS.
I HAVE SAT THROUGH NUMEROUS
MEETINGS BOTH HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND IN THE DISTRICT
ATTEMPTING TO WORK OUT.
COULD DISS CONCERNS.
SO LONG AS WE GET THE
RECONCILIATION OF THE SCIENCE I
HAVE SAID FROM THE BEGINNING
THAT THE ONLY THING THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN WITH THIS BILL.
IS TO HAVE A TOP DOWN REVIEW OF
THE SCIENCE THE CONFLICTS IN THE
SCIENCE AND A RECONCILIATION OF
THE SCIENCE AND THE SETTING OF
AN ENIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
PUMPING.
NO MORE NO LESS NOW DURING THESE
VARIOUS MEETINGS AND WE WE
STARTED WITH A VARIETY OF
AMENDMENTS BEING EXCHANGED
INCLUDING THE FIRST ONE WITH
COULD THESE WHICH WANTED TO
LIMIT THE REVIEW. TO THE SCIENCE
IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT AND SET THE TIME LINE FOR
THAT REVIEW IT SIXTY DAYS.
NOW YOU KNOW AND I KNOW THAT IF
YOU'RE VIOLATING SCIENCE IN YOUR
HIRING HIRING NEW SCIENCE IN
TRYING TO RECONCILE SIXTY DAYS
IS COMPLETELY UNREASONABLE
OBVIOUSLY THAT AMENDMENT DIDN'T
WORK.
WE WENT BACK AND FORTH AND WENT
BACK AND FORTH NOW COULD HE'S
ONE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES ADDED TO THIS BILL SO
WE ADDED THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
COULD HE'S ONE OF THE PROCESS SO
WE ADDED A PROCESS COULD HE'S
ONE OF THE TIMELINE IN A TIME
LIMIT PUT ON THE REVIEW WE DID
SELL.
FRANKLY I COULDN'T AGREE TO
EVERYTHING KIDDIES WANTED BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE I COULD
HAVE DONE A CURRENTLY WHAT I DID
WAS NOT ENOUGH FOR KIDDIES.
SO COLLEAGUES LONG GOING TO BE A
LONG DAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL SAY THIS -- I
HAVE NOT I DON'T THINK I'VE
ASKED FOR YOUR HELP [inaudible]
BUT ONE OR TWO TIMES IN THE SIX
AND A HALF YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
ON THIS.
FOR SO.
AND I KNOW THIS IS A DIFFICULT
BILL.
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO CAN.
I WOULD ASK YOUR HELP AND I
WOULD REQUEST NAY VOTE IN THIS
CASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION THE SENATOR GORGEOUS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I WANT.
TO FIRST START OFF WITH -- I
DON'T HAVE THE INTIMATE
KNOWLEDGE ON THIS ISSUE AS MY
COLLEAGUE AND THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL DOES.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU FROM WHAT I
DO KNOW THIS AUTHOR -- HE IS AN
OUTSTANDING INDIVIDUAL AND IF.
INTEGRITY WAS EVER QUESTIONS
THAT I WOULD QUESTION THOSE THAT
MIGHT PUT FORWARD SUCH
ALLEGATIONS SO.
I WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THAT'S THAT'S PUT OUT THERE.
BUT FROM MY STANDPOINT AS A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
REVIEWED THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
THE SO I SAT ON THE POLICY
COMMITTEE ON PARTICIPATING RIGHT
IN ONE OF THE MOST DELIBERATE
DISCUSSIONS OF THE POLICY
QUESTIONS POSED BY THIS BILL --
BOTH SIDES PREVENTED GOOD
CREDIBLE POLICY ARGUMENTS AS WE
DELIVERY THIS BILL IT BECAME
CLEAR TO ME.
THAT THERE APPEARED TO BE A PATH
FORWARD.
A RECONCILIATION OF THE
POSITIONS ESPECIALLY ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS I WAS VERY --
EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
I REYES TO CONSIDER THE REVIEW
SHOULD NOT TRY TO REDO THE
SEQUEL PROCESS.
I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE AREAS
OF ROB -- WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
HAVING A SEQUEL REVIEW PROCESS?
IF THERE WILL BE TRAILER
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS ATTACHED
AD NAUSEAM -- SO I BELIEVE AT
LEAST FROM A LEGAL AND
PROCEDURAL STANDPOINT.
YOU CAN'T CONTINUE TO ADD
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND LEGAL
PROCEDURES.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT A DESIRED
OUTCOME -- I THINK THAT IS KIND
OF WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS THAT.
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
CHALLENGING THIS PROJECT WE'RE
NOT FINDING THE DESIRED OUTCOME.
THAT THEY WERE -- ACCRETING NEW
PROCEDURAL AND REGULATORY
OBSTACLES TO MAKE THIS THING
HAPPEN.
BUT AT ONE POINT IN THE HEARING
I AGREE WITH OTHER MEMBERS THAT
WE SHOULD NOT TRY TO RE WRITE
THE BILL IN THE HEARING.
AND THERE WAS A CLEAR PATH TO
AMENDING THE BILL IN HAVE THE
PROPER AGENCY CONDUCT THE REVIEW
OF MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
WAS A WATER RESOURCES -- WAS
ADDED -- I THINK THE IDEA THOUGH.
WITHOUT AMENDMENTS AND I THINK.
FOLKS WERE WERE APPRECIATIVE
THAT WAS INCLUDED.
BUT IT WENT BACK TO THE FACT
THAT WE STILL DIDN'T WANT TO GO
THROUGH OR THE ENTITIES DID NOT
WANT TO GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS
AGAIN SEE WHAT ONCE.
DOES NOT MEAN SEE QUIRK INFINITY --
AND I THINK THAT'S WERE ADD.
I IT I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
VOTES ARE ON THIS TODAY AND I
KNOW IT'S A CONTENTIOUS ISSUE --
IN A PERFECT WORLD I'D LOVE TO
SEE THIS CONVERSATION CONTINUE.
I DON'T WISH THAT PROBABLY ON MY
WORST ENEMY HOWEVER.
SO -- SO SENATOR I I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE -- PUT IN A GOOD AMOUNT A
LEG WORK ON THIS AND I DON'T
KNOW WE'RE THE MEETING OF THE
MINDS CAN OCCUR.
I'M JUST OF THE OPINION THAT I
DON'T THINK WE'RE DONE.
BUT IN ITS CURRENT FORM I HAVE
TO HONOR SOME OF THE INITIAL
REQUEST BECAUSE I THOUGHT THEY
WERE REASONABLE.
THAT WE SHOULD NOT EXTENSIVE AND
FOR THOSE REASONS I WILL
RESPECTFULLY OF VOTE AGAINST THE
BILL IN SH.
AND IF IT SHOULD IT PASS -- THEN
I'M HOPING THAT THERE WILL BE A
REITERATION IN THE SECOND HOUSE --
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN
THIS PROCESS.
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU -- THAT A PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AND IF FOR ME IT IS NOT A
DIFFICULT BILLER CONTROVERSIAL
BECAUSE IT RECOGNIZES THAT.
ONCE THE PLEADED ONCE WE REMOVE
FOR GROUND WATER THEN THE
AQUIFER.
CAN [inaudible]
RESTORE.
IT IS PRETTY MUCH THE
IRREVERSIBLE.
AND I THINK FOR THOSE OF US WHO
TRAVELED ELSEWHERE IN THE WORLD
OR EVEN JUST TRAVELED IN THE
SOUTHWEST STATES.
WHEN YOU VISIT THE VARIOUS
ARCHAEOLOGICAL SITES YOU SEE
THAT THEY WERE THRIVING
CIVILIZATIONS AND THEN THEY PUT
THE EXPLANATION OF WHAT THE?
WHAT THE?
SCIENTISTS AND OTHERS ARE
ANTHROPOLOGISTS AND SUCH YOU
STARTED THE SITE.
DETERMINE WHAT YOU KNOW WHY DO
THESE PEOPLE LEAVE WHY DID THIS --
THRIVING COMMUNITY NO LONGER
EXIST AND USUALLY THE
EXPLANATION IS DEPLETION OF
GROUNDWATER IS A WATER ISSUE.
NOW CALIFORNIA DID NOT MEASURE
OR MONITOR IT'S GROUND WATER FOR
YEARS.
WE DID NOT TAKE ACTION. TO
EITHER MEASURE OR MONITOR OR
LIMIT.
THE DEPLETION OF GROUND WATER
UNTIL.
TWENTY FIFTEEN I WOULD ENCOURAGE
ANY MEMBERS WHO ARE THINK THAT
PERHAPS OR GROUND WATER.
NOT ONLY IN THIS AREA OF MOJAVE
MIGHT BE AT RISK BUT ACROSS THE
STATE TO LOOK AT STANFORD.
UNIVERSITY WEBSITE WHERE THEY
SHOW A SERIES OF NASA
PHOTOGRAPHS SATELLITE IMAGES
USING INFRARED TECHNOLOGY.
WHICH SHOW THE STATUS FOR GROUND
WATER.
ACROSS THE STATE.
FIRST IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THEN JUNE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT AND THEN JUNE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN IN JUNE TWENTY
FOURTEEN PRETTY MUCH ALL OF THE
AREAS THAT HAD BEEN GREEN GREEN
SHOWING THAT THERE WAS.
A AT LEAST SOME GOOD.
RESERVE WHETHER IT WAS ADEQUATE
OR NOT IS ANOTHER STORY.
THAT ENTIRE MAP IS READ.
NOW WE KNOW ALSO THAT THAT WAS
AT THE HEIGHT OF OUR VERY LONG
DROUGHT.
BUT IN THE MOST RECENT INFRARED
IMAGES IT ONCE AGAIN.
SHOWS MOST OF THAT AREA AS READ
AND WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING THE
MOJAVE.
SO.
IT TO KNOW THAT AN AREA LIKE THE
MOJAVE THAT IS ONE OF OUR MOST
RESTRICTED AREAS IN TERMS OF
RAINFALL AND RUN OFF SO THE
LEAST ABLE. TO RESTORE ITS
AQUIFER.
THAT WE WOULD AT THIS TIME.
NOT SUPPORT A BILL LIKE THIS
THAT JUST ALLOWS OUR SCIENTISTS
TO COME BACK TOGETHER.
AND LOOKED AT WHAT IS THE REAL
STATUS OF THE AQUIFER AND WHAT
CAN IT REALLY BE SUSTAINED IN
TERMS OF THE AMOUNT THAT COULD
BE PUMPED OUT OF IT.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
I FIGURE OUT A PRESIDENT -- I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
OF SEVEN WHICH WILL PROTECT OUR
DESERT'S FROM TENSELY
UNSUSTAINABLE.
PUMPING OF GROUNDWATER WITHOUT
ADEQUATE ANALYSIS A REVIEW.
I CALIFORNIAS DESERT SO SOME OF
THE MOST ECOLOGICALLY DIVERSE IN
THE WORLD.
AND THE HARBOR A GREAT NUMBER OF
ENDANGERED SPECIES RANGER
RANGING FROM BURROWING AL'S TO
AND DEMOCRATS FROM ROSES.
I THESE REGIONS ARE ALSO HOME TO
SOME OF THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND OUR STATE. FOR
HOME A DRAMATIC SHIFT IN WATER
TABLES COULD PROVE DISASTROUS.
BY THIS LEGISLATION SIMPLY
FORCES THE STATE TO TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THE REAL IMPACTS
OF THE PROPOSED GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTION.
AS THE LA TIMES IS WRITTEN ON
THIS ISSUE QUOTE ONE POLITICS
OUT FLYING SCIENCE IT DOESN'T
HURT TO ADD A LITTLE MORE
SCIENCE.
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT AND VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IDEA
OF WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
TAKING SUCH A HIGH INTEREST IN
MY DISTRICT -- I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR MOJAVE DESERT THE KIDDIES
PROJECT THE DISEASE ITSELF THE
RESIDENTS THE MOJAVE.
DESERT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY THEY ALL BELONG TO THE
SIXTEENTH SENATE DISTRICT.
AND THE IT'S A PERSONAL ISSUE
FOR ME AND WE DO WHAT WE CAN
KERN COUNTY HAS ALREADY APPROVED
A SIGNAL PLAN WHICH WAS PASSED.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE THE SCIENCE
SHOWS THAT THE SPACE AND IS AN
OPEN BASIN AND WILL BE RECHARGED.
KIDDIES THE CLIENT IN THE
CONSTITUENT IN MY DISTRICT THAT
IS WHEN HE DOING THIS PROJECT.
HAS THE DELAY IN THE PROJECT
BEING PUMPED AND RESOURCE OUT
NOW TO PROVIDE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES.
IN THE LOS ANGELES OR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA WITH NECESSARY
WATER IF IT'S NEEDED ESPECIALLY
WHEN IF WE GO INTO WATER
RATIONING AT FIFTY FIVE GALLONS
A DAY.
THIS COMPANY WHO IS DOING THIS --
THE REASON WHY IT'S TAKEN SO
LONG IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
IN COURT FIGHTING LAWSUIT AFTER
LAWSUIT AFTER LAWSUIT. TWELVE
LAWSUIT.
OVER A PERIOD OF YEARS THESE
TWELVE LAWSUITS HAVE DELAYED THE
EXTRACTION AND THEY HAVE BEEN TO
OVER BACKWARDS THEY HAVE ONE
EVERY TIME IN COURT.
N. AS IT GOES IN CALIFORNIA IF
YOU WIN IN COURT AND THE
ADVERSARY IS NOT HAPPY WITH IT
THEY BRING THE PRODUCT OR THE
IDEA TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE TO HOPEFULLY.
OVERRULED WITH THE COURT SYSTEM
HAS SAID.
AGAIN COLLEAGUES THIS IS IN MY
DISTRICT.
THIS COMPANY HAS GONE ABOVE AND
BEYOND SCIENCE SHOWS THAT IS AN
OPEN BASIN THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
MY DISTRICT ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE WE WANT TO RESET WE
WANT TO PROTECT THE MOJAVE
DESERT -- TO MAKE SURE IT IS
STILL ONE OF THE MOST PRISTINE
AREAS IN OUR DISTRICT THAT
PEOPLE CAN GO TO BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE WATER TO THE
CONSTITUENTS THIS TO THE SOUTH
OF US.
AND AGAIN THINK ABOUT THAT FOR
JUST SICK MAN WE'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE A BASE AN OVERDRAFT THE
MOHAVE BASIN IS INCLUDED IN THE
SIGMA PROJECT.
AND TWELVE LAWSUITS IN OVER A
DECADE LATER.
THEY HAVE LOST EVERY SINGLE
LAWSUIT AND THEY COME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE TOO
AGAIN IMPACT MY DISTRICT IN THIS
PROJECT IS GONNA.
A PROVIDE ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
JOBS.
WE TOOK -- WE TAKE A VOTE THE
OTHER DAY ON THE FLOOR THAT
ELIMINATES -- OUR CITIES FROM
BRINGING IN FACTORIES WHERE WE
HAVE.
OR WAREHOUSES WHERE WE HAVE
PLACES TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
BECAUSE WE ON A LOT OF LAND --
BUT WE DON'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
THE COLD CALIFORNIA STATE A
TAXPAYERS PAYING FOR A RE A
MANUFACTURER'S CREDITOR RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT CREDIT WERE
APPLE PAYS WHAT POINT 0003% OF
ANY TAX RATE.
SO IT'S IN THE VALLEY THE VALLEY
IS CONSTANTLY CHORE CHANGED AND
THIS IS ANOTHER WAY THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE'S COMING INTO MY
DISTRICT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND TRYING TO TAKE JOBS WHEN WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
COMPLY WITH EVERY STATE LAW THAT
COMES OUT OF THIS BUILDING.
SO I WOULD ASK YOU TO NOT VOTE
FOR THIS BILL SAVE THE SIX
THOUSAND JOBS UP PULLED WITH THE
COURT SAID AFTER TWELVE LAWSUITS.
THAT HAVE BEEN FILED IN IT JUST
CONTINUES AND NOW THEY'VE COME
LIKE I SAID TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO GET YOU TO
SUPERSEDE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
SO I WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT EYES
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB -- THREE
OH SEVEN AND I ALSO RISE TO
COMPLEMENT ITS AUTHOR FROM MY
DISTRICT JUST EAST OF MINE -- I
DON'T THINK THERE WAS A MORE
THOUGHTFUL PERSON TO BE
SHEPHERDING THIS THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE'S YOU KNOW THIS --
EFFORT IS HAD A TWO YEAR RUN
LAST YEAR THERE WERE SOME PREACH
PROCEDURAL ISSUES -- SURROUNDING
IT IN THIS YEAR -- THE GOOD --
SENATOR HAS I THINK TRIED -- IN
A HERCULEAN EFFORT TO GET ALL
SIDES TO WORK TOGETHER -- HE IS
SHOWN -- CLASS AND DIGNITY IN
THAT PROCESS AND I'M PROUD.
TO STAND WITH HIM IN SUPPORT SB
THREE OH SEVEN AND HOPE THIS.
CONTINUES TO MOVE IN CONTINUES
THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
AB MEMBERS I I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE TODAY I WE HEARD
IT BEFORE THE COMMITTEE I CHAIR
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCE IN
WATER COMMITTEE AND I JUST WANT
TO CORRECT A FEW -- RUMORS I
GUESS FOR THE RECORD HERE --
WHEN IT COMES TO THE INTEGRITY
OF THE SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE I
THINK NONE OF US OUGHT HAVE ANY
DOUBT BUT IF IT NEEDS
CLARIFICATION?
THE COMMITMENTS MADE BEFORE THAT
COMMITTEE I BELIEVE HAVE BEEN
FULFILLED.
AND IF ANYTHING.
THE DAYLIGHT WE SAW IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMPROMISE IN
THAT COMMITTEE HEARING.
CAME FROM THE KIDDIES PROJECT
PROPONENTS THEMSELVES.
I HEARD FROM THEM THAT THEY WERE
OPEN TO A PRE PROJECTS
[inaudible]
SCIENTIFIC REVIEW.
AND FROM MY UNDERSTANDING.
THAT AMENDMENT IS NOT BEEN
AGREED -- TO FOR THE PROJECT
PROPONENTS THEMSELVES.
IF THEY WERE WILLING AND OPEN TO
HAVE THIS PROJECT LOOKED AT WITH
AN OPEN INDEPENDENT SCIENTIFIC
BODY HAS THIS BEEN PROPOSED.
THE OFFER SITTING ON THE TABLE.
SO THE CONCERN HERE IS THAT
POLITICS IS BLED INTO THE POLICY.
AND THIS IS JUST BECOME POSTURE
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE ACTUAL
SUBSTANCE OF THIS MEASURE.
THERE ARE SOME EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES ARE SO
SPECIAL.
THAT WE NEED TO THE TAKE A LOOK
AT A SINGLE PROJECT.
AND I DON'T LIKE SINGLE PROJECT
BILLS WHETHER YOUR OPPOSED TO A
PROJECT OR WITH THE SUPPORT OF
PROJECT.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE PROCESS.
I THINK THERE'S A TON OF
INTEGRITY TO THIS.
I RESPECT WHAT THE SENATE FROM
RIVERSIDE IS DONE.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
[inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YU ON MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS ARE I DO RISE COMES UP
WITH CONCERNS ABOUT SB.
THREE OH SEVEN AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY I REPRESENT THE SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT WHICH
IS IN MY DISTRICT.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN --
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE DISTRICT
TOOK THE LEAD IN THE SECRET
PROCESS THIS LEGISLATION JUST
LIKE ITS PREDECESSORS WHICH IS
AB ONE THOUSAND SP. ONE TWENTY
SIX TO CREATE A NEW ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATION PROCESS AND YOU'VE
ALL HEARD ABOUT FOR WATER
CONVEYED IN CALIFORNIA'S WATER
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
OUR SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT ACTED PROPERLY IN THE
CONDUCT OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT AS REQUIRED BY
SEQUEL -- IN YOU OF HEARD THAT
MANY MANY -- LAWSUITS WERE --
ENTERED IN ON THE COURT UPHELD
THEIR REVIEW.
THAT COULD THESE PROJECT HAS
GONE THROUGH EXTENSIVE
LITIGATION AND PREVAILED AT
EVERY LEVEL.
THIS BILL UNFORTUNATELY APPEARS
TO BE A TAX BILL EXAMPLE OF
CHANGING THE RULES OF THE GAME.
BEFORE -- BECAUSE BEFORE THE
FACT BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE THE
OUTCOME.
OUR WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ME PERSONALLY AND TO MY DISTRICT
AND I THINK TO ARE.
THE FUTURE OF WATER CAN DANCE IS
THAT THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY AND
I AM ASSUMING AND INTENTIONALLY
CONSIDERING THE AUTHOR.
KILLS THIS PROJECT AND SAYS THAT
PRESIDENT GOING FORWARD FOR ANY
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD
HAVE TO DO WITH WATER CAN DANCE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE TAKE A SECOND LOOK ARE
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUGGESTED PERHAPS WILL NOT
BEEN.
NECESSARILY A COMFORTABLE AND TO
THE GOOD AUTHOR BOB THAT
CERTAINLY DESERVES SOME
CONSIDERATION SO WE DON'T HAVE A
PRESIDENT.
THAT REALLY SHUTS DOWN A PROJECT
THAT HAS I THINK THROUGH THAT
WOULD BE OUR ALMOST EIGHT YEARS --
WALK THE WALK FOLLOW THE RULE
BOOK AND NOW IN THE LAST.
MILE IS HAVING SOMETHING THROWN
AT THEM THAT COULD BASICALLY
SHUT THE WHOLE THING DOWN I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING OF GREAT
CONCERN ARE CERTAINLY TO MY
DISTRICT TO THE KIDDIES PROJECT
PROPONENTS.
AND I ALSO THINK TO THIS
LEGISLATURE ARE WE NEED TO FIND
A SOLUTION AND THIS ONE OUT
LACKS ARE CERTAINLY A FEW
AMENDMENTS THAT COULD.
MOVE IT ALONG IN AND CERTAINLY
PROTECT THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED FROM THOSE WHO
CURRENTLY OPPOSE.
I ASKED -- FOR YOUR NOBLE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SITTING IN HEARING NONE.
SENATOR ROTH YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM.
BOTH SIDES PRO AND CON VERY
THOUGHTFUL.
A JUST NOT TO BELABOR IT BUT
JUST TO REITERATE THERE'S NO
REDO OF SEQUEL THERE NO DOCUMENT
DUMPSTER NO PUBLIC HEARINGS
THERE'S NO.
CERTIFICATION PROCESS JUST OF
SCIENTIFIC FINDING AS TO WHAT AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
PUMPING RATE IS.
I WILL SAY THIS FORTUNATELY THE
MOJAVE DESERT DOESN'T BELONG TO
ANYONE OF US.
AND DOESN'T BELONG TO ANY SINGLE
SENATE DISTRICT.
IT'S A NATIONAL MONUMENT.
IN A STATE TREASURER.
AND JUST LIKE TOM HOLE IN OUR
CALIFORNIA COASTS IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE DESERVES SOME
SPECIAL ATTENTION SO WITH THAT.
I KNOW IT'S A DIFFICULT VOTE
IDEAS FOR YOUR HELP AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
NO GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
HI WITH SO -- TITLE.
JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO.
SKINNER BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY CASKEY.
BY WINNER BY WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
WITH SO -- TITLE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I'M A GUY. FIVE ICE TWENTY ONE
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
REPORTER STONE SAID NO
SO.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR WHAT WAS
YOURS UP STONE NO I KNOW WHEN
YOU ARE AYE AYES TWENTY ONE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
BY COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY THREE
pINTO ELECTIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE BETTER PRESENT
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS HERE TO PRESENT TODAY SB
THREE FIFTY SIX THE NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY RIGHT AWAY
TRANCERS.
KIDS TO ORANGE ALL VERY QUICKLY
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP BILL THE
LAST YEAR'S SB TEN TWENTY NINE
WHICH WAS PASSED AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR WHICH IS THE ANTI
ARE A CLOSURE IN.
TRANSITION TO TRAIL ACT.
SB TEN TWENTY NINE SET UP A
PROCESS TO TRANSITION THREE
HUNDRED PLUS MILE MOSTLY
DILAPIDATED AND LARGE THE
INOPERATIVE RAIL LINE INTO A
WORLD CLASS TRAIL SYSTEM THAT
RUNS THROUGH SOME THE WILDEST.
MOST SCENIC LANDSCAPES IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA THIS
TRACK IS LOCATED NORTHERN CAT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RUNNING FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY IN THE
SOUTH ALL THE WAY TO THE HUMBLE
BAY IN THE NORTH.
THIS YEAR WE'VE INTRODUCED SB
THREE FIFTY SIX WHICH HAS BEEN
RECEIVING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO
CONTINUE THE N. T. R. A. SHUT
DOWN WHICH IS FUNCTIONALLY
BANKRUPT.
BY TRANSFERRING TWENTY POINT
SEVEN EIGHT MILES OF RAIL ASSETS
FROM HEALDSBURG THE CLOVERDALE
WITH IN CINEMA COUNTY TO THE
CINEMA MARIN ALE RAIL TRANSIT
AUTHORITY.
BETTER PRESENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE VOTE AND
APPROPRIATE TIME.
COLLEAGUES WE ARE ON FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS SB.
FIVE TWENTY THREE AS HER ANY
QUESTION HERE.
BUT LET'S HOLD ON ONE SECOND
[inaudible]
WHAT SORRY?
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT BILL WE OWN
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY SEVEN SB FIVE TWENTY
THREE WANT TO TRY THAT ONE AGAIN.
THE PRESIDENT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY WAS PAYING
ATTENTION.
YOU GOT IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- IN BECAUSE
OF THAT I'M GONNA PASS ON FILE
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN IS A
PASS ON FILE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE PREAMBLE
TO YOUR REMARKS BUT I GLAD TO
HEAR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ALONG
NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
SENATOR HILL YOU READY TO
PROCEED.
ON SB.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN ALRIGHT WE
WILL GO AHEAD WITH FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SAID ABOUT FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR HILL AND
ACTUALLY TO WORKERS COMPENSATION.
SENATOR HILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN A BILL THAT SEEKS TO
REDUCE.
MEDICAL DISPUTES AND INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY IN THE OPERATION OF
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORKS WITHIN
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW MEDICAL
PROVIDER NETWORKS OR EMPTY ENDS
ARE A KEY TOOL IN OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM TO ENSURE
THE INJURED WORKERS GET THE
TREATMENT THEY NEED IN A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY.
M. P. AND ALSO ENSURE THAT
WORKERS HAVE ENOUGH CHOICES TO
ACCESS MEDICAL CARE WITH
PROVIDERS THEY LIGHT HOWEVER
MORE AND MORE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
STEPPED FORWARD WITH CONCERNS.
ON HOW SOME IN PEONS ARE
OPERATING IN THIS STATE.
SPECIFICALLY THE CALIFORNIA
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION HAS
SHARED WITH US MULTIPLE
DOCUMENTED INSTANCES OF PHYSICAL
THERAPIST BEING PUSHED. TO TAKE
EXTREMELY LOW REIMBURSEMENTS
UNDER THE THREAT OF RECEIVING
FEWER INJURED WORKER REFERRALS.
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THIS RACE TO THE BOTTOM BY
SETTING THE FEDERAL MEDICARE FEE
SCHEDULE AS THE MINIMUM
REIMBURSEMENT HALTING THE RACE
TO THE BOTTOM.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT SOME
IN PEONS HAVE REACHED OUT.
WITH SOME TECHNICAL CONCERNS ON
HOW THE BILL IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED.
I COMMIT TO WORKING WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS THESE TECHNICAL CONCERNS
TO IMPROVE THE AM PM SYSTEM. FOR
ALL STAKEHOLDERS EVER REQUEST
DRIVE A MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR HILL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
THIS JOURNEY DEBATER DISCUSSION
SHOOTING IN HEARING ON I'M SORRY
SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THERE
ARE VERY FEW WORKERS COMP BILLS
THAT COME OFF THIS FLOOR THAT I
WOULD STAND IN SUPPORT SO I
PLUGGED THE AUTHOR. FOR MAKING
THINGS A LITTLE BETTER FOR US IS
EMPLOYERS BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORK THAT
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT PROVIDES GOOD ACCESS.
TO CARE WHEN WE HAVE AN INJURED
WORKER AND THIS MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF QUALITY -- INDIVIDUALS
AND COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE
ACCESS TO CARE AND THEY HAVE
GOOD QUALITY CARE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE HONOR IMPIAN NETWORK OR
WILL NOT JOIN OR IN PM NETWORK
BECAUSE THE FEE SCHEDULE IT'S
NEGOTIATED SO LOW.
SO I APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION FURTHER
DEBATE SENATOR NIELSEN.
VOTER PRESENTLY ASIAN JOURNAL
THE SENATE I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT AND I WANT TO COMPLIMENT
THE AUTHOR.
OVER THE DECADES THE WORKERS
COMP BILLS OFTEN PROMISED AS
MAJOR REFORMS.
HAD FATAL FLAWS.
AMONG THE MOST OWNERS OF WHICH
WAS TO MAKE THAT BILL.
SUPPOSEDLY REFORM BUILT MORE
LITIGIOUS RATHER THAN LAST.
AND THEN THE PROPONENTS WOULD
SAY WELL IT'S THE BEST WE CAN
GET.
I THINK THAT THIS BILL IS.
OF THE BEST WE CAN GET TODAY BUT
IT DOES NOT AS I SEE.
HAVE ANY OF THOSE ONEROUS
PROVISIONS THAT MAKES THE SYSTEM.
MORE LITIGIOUS.
BUT RATHER IT HOLDS.
THE COURSE OF THE REFORMS WE'VE
HELD IN THE PAST.
AND WILL BE.
A PLUS.
NOT A MINUS IRISH IN MY BOOK.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR BORDERS.
COMMAND THE AUTHOR URGENT I'VE A
THANK YOU IS THERE OF ANY OTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER HILL LOOKS
LIKE YOU'RE.
AHEAD OF THE GAME HERE IT DOES
INDEED THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU TO MY COMMENTS FOR THE
OF MY THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THE GOOD COMMENTS TODAY I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
WE NEED A ROLL CALL VERY GOOD
WILL GET A ROLL CALL MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
BELL BATES AYE BILL I PURCHASE
[inaudible]
HI.
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHANGE [inaudible]
HI DOT [inaudible]
BY.
THE RISE OF HI GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE.
HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK.
HE SAID MORRELL.
PLEASE HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS.
MORE LOCK.
AYE AYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO SENATOR
STERN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
THREE SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY TWO
BY SENATOR STERN AND ACTUALLY TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NO
WHERE IS THAT CRISIS MORE
PRONOUNCED THAN AMONG OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS.
THE LOSS OF LIFE DUE TO SUICIDE
THIS PAST YEAR.
OUTPACED THE LOSS OF LIFE ON THE
FRONT LINES FIGHTING FIRES
MAKING RESCUES IN THE LINE OF
DUTY.
THIS IS A TROUBLING TREND THAT
NEEDS TO BE STOPPED.
PART OF THIS ABOUT POLICY IN
PART OF ITS BY CHANGING THE
STIGMA AROUND MENTAL HEALTH.
NEARLY ONE IN FOUR POLICE
OFFICERS AND ONE IN SIX
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE CONSIDERED
SUICIDE.
AND 20% OF FIRE SERVICE MEMBERS
IN 32% OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
HAVE SUFFERED FROM PT
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURIES AT
ONE POINT.
COMPARED TO AN ESTIMATED 328% OF
ALL ADULTS.
THESE ARE HARD JOBS.
AND A MENTAL HEALTH INJURY A
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURY IS
AN INJURY JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
INJURY.
BIKE A DISLOCATED SHOULDER OR
BROKEN RISK.
BUT THESE HIDE IN THE SHADOWS.
AND TODAY.
WITH THIS VOTE WE HOPE.
WE CAN TELL.
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS THAT WE
BELIEVE YOU.
THAT WE ARE ON YOUR SIDE.
AND THAT WHEN YOU GET ARE BACK
YOU KNOW WE WILL HAVE YOURS THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS.
THIS BAT PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS.
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD
IN THIS LEGISLATION WE KNOW
THERE'S SOME CONCERNS AND
CONCERNS IT'S STILL OUTSTANDING.
IN TERMS OF HOW THE MECHANICS OF
THIS WILL WORK AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
I AM VERY OPEN IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND LOOK FOR TO
RESOLVING SOME OF THOSE ISSUES --
BUT WE THINK ON THE WHOLE THIS
BILL IS A SOLID FRAMEWORK AN
IMPORTANT STEP.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN COLLEAGUES IN THE
BACK.
LET'S PLEASE KEEP THE NOISE DOWN
IF WE COULD AND IN THE GALLERY
AGAIN.
I KNOW THERE'S SOME LITTLE ONES
HERE LET'S PLEASE TRY TO MANAGE
THEM OR GOING TO HAVE TO ASK YOU
TO LEAVE.
THE BETTER DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SENATOR NIELSEN.
BUT A PRESERVATION DONE THE
SENATE I DON'T OFTEN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SUCH BILLS.
BUT I FIND MERIT.
IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
AND PART OF MY AYE VOTE IS TO BE
IN A POSITION TO CONTINUE.
THE NEGOTIATIONS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH I'M VERY
SENSITIVE.
TO AND WHICH HAS BEEN A MAJOR
REASON FOR MY OBJECTION.
IN YEARS PAST.
BUT I MUST CONFESS IS THIS IS
ONE THAT KIND OF PULLS AT THE
HEARTSTRINGS.
KNOWING AS INTIMATELY AS I DO.
ARMORED -- MERGES THE PERSONNEL.
OF POLICE OFFICERS.
THE DEPUTY SHERIFF'S.
WHO WALKED DEBATE?
IN A FIRE FIGHTERS.
ALL OVER THE STATE.
ALL OF WHO PUT THEIR LIVES AT
RISK.
IN A TELLING A MOMENT OCCURRED
IN MY OFFICE JUST A VERY FEW
YEARS AGO.
I HAD SOME POLICE OFFICERS.
WIRES.
THE MY OFFICE.
TALKING ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
THEIR JOB AND HOW THE TIDE
TURNED AGAINST THEM [inaudible]
THEIR HUSBANDS. FOR THE FACT FOR
THE AND THEY WERE NOW.
MORE AT RISK.
THAN EVER BEFORE.
AND ONE WOMAN THOUGH LOOKED AT
ME AND SHE SAID THAT WHAT ABOUT
ME [inaudible]
SENATOR.
MY HUSBAND'S NAME CANNOT GO UPON
THAT MEMORIAL WALL [inaudible]
BECAUSE HE COMMITTED SUICIDE.
I BRING THAT TO YOUR ATTENTION
BECAUSE I'M NOT UNFAMILIAR
THOUGH I'VE NEVER BEEN A SWORN.
OFFICER I HAVE WALKED THE BEAT.
AND I KNOW.
THE STRESS THAT IT ENTAILS.
AND I KNOW THE DIFFICULTIES. FOR
I'VE HAD TO DEAL WITH A VERY
VERY PERSONALLY.
OF COURSE NOT TAKING IT HOME.
THAT WHICH YOU SAW DURING THE
COURSE OF YOUR WORK THAT DAY. TO
NOT TAKE IT HOME [inaudible]
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
DESERVE THAT CONSIDERATION. TO
MAKE THEIR LIVES THE LIVES OF
THEIR FAMILIES.
A LITTLE BIT EASIER HIGHER CHEN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN.
SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
WOULD LIKE YOU GUYS ALL I GET
THAT IT THIS IS A TUG ON THE
HEARTSTRINGS BUT I WANT YOU GUYS
TO ALL LOOK AT THE LEGISLATION
AND LOOK AT POLICY THAT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE.
AND THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT IT A
CUMULATIVE TRAUMA FROM
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE OFFICERS.
IS A HUGE ISSUE BUT THIS BILL IS
DEALING WITH STRICTLY A STRICT
PRESUMPTION.
PRESUMING THAT ANY CLAIM BROUGHT
TO GIVES THE COUNTY IS PRESUMED
AUTOMATICALLY TO BE.
A POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS SYNDROME
CLAIM OR PRESUME TO TO BE A
CLAIM.
WHAT IS IN PLACE NOW IS THE
FIRST TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS?
SO MEANING THAT IF SOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER FIREFIGHTER
ANY WORKER FOR ANY MATTER.
FILES A CLAIM WITH THE EMPLOYER
THE FIRST TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
IMMEDIATELY STARTS EVEN IF THE
COMPLAINT THE CLAIM IS IN
DISPUTE.
SO THE FIREFIGHTER THE POLICE
OFFICER ANYONE ELSE CAN GO TO
THE DOCTOR SEE A PSYCHOLOGIST
AND THEN.
THEY CAN THEY CAN DETERMINE THAT
IT IS A WORK RELATED INJURY IN
THE FIRST TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
IS COVERED.
BY THE EMPLOYER OR THE COUNTY.
THAT IS A PROPER DETERMINATION
WHERE YOUR DOCTOR THAT YOU PICK
OR THE PSYCHOLOGIST THAT YOU
PICK OR THE PERSON YOU DECIDE
FOR TREATMENT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO EVALUATE YOU. TO SAY YES THIS
IS A WORK RELATED ISSUE YES THIS
DID HAPPEN OVER TIME YES YOU ARE
AFFECTED BY THIS AND THAT IS THE
FIRST TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
AVAILABLE.
PASSING THIS BILL SIR CONVINCED
THAT PROCESS AND AUTOMATICALLY
PRESUMES NO MATTER WHAT.
THEY DID IS A CUMULATIVE TRAUMA
WORK RELATED POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS SYNDROME -- ISSUE I JUST
ASK THAT YOU LET THE LAW THAT IS
IN PLACE NOW WITH THIS TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR AUTOMATIC
GUARANTEE.
PAYMENT OF BENEFITS THAT STARTS
IMMEDIATELY UNDISPUTED WHEN THE
CLAIM IS FILED.
THAT THEY GET TO USE THAT TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS GO SEE THE
DOCTOR THEY CHOOSE TO SEE WITHIN
THE MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORK AND
MAKE SURE.
THAT IT TRULY IS A CLAIM AND
PROTECT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM STEPH IS NOT NAM AS SEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIREFIGHTERS
WILL FALL FILE FALSE CLAIMS.
THAT'S I DON'T I THINK THAT'S
ALMOST UNHEARD OF I JUST WOULD
ASK YOU TO ALLOW THE LAW THAT IS
IN PLACE CONTINUE TO WORK.
AND NOT CREATE A PRESUMPTION
THAT MAKES IT AUTOMATICALLY
PAYABLE BY TE COUNTY I THINK IT
AFFECTS OUR COUNTIES AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS -- AND I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT THERE REALLY IS A
MECHANISM ON THE BOOKS TO ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
CARE -- OR PSYCHIATRIC CARE --
AND THEY CAN GO TO THEIR DOCTOR
TO GET THAT AND THAT DR CAN
MAKING EVALUATION AND DETERMINE
TO BE COMPENSATED BOWL AND THEN
THE EMPLOYER IS AUTOMATICALLY
REQUIRED TO MAKE SURE IT'S
COMPENSATED BOWL SO I WOULD
APPRECIATE A NO VOTE ON A
PRESUMPTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVER ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR STERN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THEY MAY PRESENT AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS [inaudible]
FOR THE DISCUSSION.
I I DO WANT TO MAKE ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION.
THIS BILL WOULD PUT IN PLACE A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION ABOUT THE
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURY SO --
IF THERE IS CONCERN ABOUT --
WHETHER THIS PRESUMPTION WOULD
BEING.
CONCLUSIVE AND JUST SOLELY BASED
ON SAY AN ATTESTATION FROM A
FIRST RESPONDER THAT'S NOT THE
CASE.
THE PREMISE OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS THAT. TO PUT THE BURDEN ON A
FIRST RESPONDER. TO INITIALLY
HAVE TO GO BACK AND BEAR THAT
BURDEN TO PROVE THAT IF THEY'RE
HAVING SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
OR IF THEY'RE HAVING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES IN THEIR LIVES TO
SAY.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T BELIEVE YOU
THE BURDEN IS ON YOU TO PROVE TO
US THAT YOU ACTUALLY HAD THAT
INJURY.
THEN YOU NEED TO GO BACK AND
SHOW EVERY LITTLE PIECE OF
DOCUMENTATION BEFORE WE CAN EVEN
GET THAT CLAIM GOING.
THAT TO ME SEEMS LIKE THE WRONG
BALANCE AND WE ALREADY HAVE THIS
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR HEART
DISEASE TUBERCULOSIS OTHER
COMMON CANCERS ACTUALLY THAT
ARISE FROM FIREFIGHTERS ARE
EXPOSED.
TO PARTICULAR CHEMICALS SO WE
HAVE THIS KIND OF REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION ON OUR BOOKS ALREADY --
BUT WE THINK IT OF ITS
APPROPRIATE HERE IN THE POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS INJURY CONTEXT
I DO WANT TO SAY THOUGH THAT.
THIS BILL WILL ADD SOME COST THE
SYSTEM -- WE HOPE THAT IT WILL.
WE HOPE THAT PEOPLE USE THESE
SERVICES TO ACTUALLY GET
THEMSELVES OUT OF THEIR INJURED
STATE -- BUT THE COSTS SHOULD BE
EXCESSIVELY MANAGEABLE --
COMPARED TO THE BURDENS THAT
THESE FIRST RESPONDERS ALREADY
THERE.
AND WE THINK IT'S A FAIR
FRAMEWORK THAT IS FRAUD PROOF
AND YEAH.
I I HAVE TROUBLE WITH -- THAT
PRESUMPTION THAT OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS MIGHT BE.
DECEIVING US WHEN THEY SAY THEY
HAVE A PROBLEM I THINK THE
PROBLEM IS JUST THE OPPOSITE.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO GET PAST
THAT STIGMA INTO A PLACE WHERE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE PERFECT
EVERY DAY YOU DON'T HAVE TO
PROFESS.
TOTAL TOUGHNESS IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN INJURED TODAY
IS THE START TO ENDING THAT
STIGMA.
AND WITH THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR STERN ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA[inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I POOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON I JONES [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN.
BY PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY NUMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY.
BY WIENER AYE WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I THE VICE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
THREE SENATOR.
PASS ON FILE.
ONE FIFTY FOUR YOU'LL TAKE THAT
ONE UP YES ALL RIGHT THE CHEST
BE.
FIVE FIFTY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY BY SENATOR HILL AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC UTILITIES.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SB FIVE FIFTY PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA FOR THE S.
P. CPUC TO CONSIDER IN REVIEWING
A PROPOSED.
CORPORATE RESTRUCTURING TO
ENSURE SAFE SERVICE OF THE
SUCCESSOR ENTITY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE ALREADY LIST
CRITERIA THE COMMISSION MUST
CONSIDER.
PRIOR TO AUTHORIZING ANY
CORPORATE RESTRUCTURING SB FIVE
FIFTY EXPANDS THESE CRITERIA TO
INCLUDE SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON FILE
ONE FIFTY FOUR SEEING AND
HEARING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORCHES.
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
CHANGE AYE DODD AYE DORADO
[inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
I GROW.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY NUMBER.
IF I WERE CASKEY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
HI -- TADA HI.
JONES NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY THREE KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SENATOR BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SAID ABOUT FIVE SEVENTY FIVE A
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO CAL GRANTS SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
NELSON MANDELA OFTEN STATED THE
MOST.
POWERFUL TOOL IN CHANGING THE
WORLD IS IT EDUCATION.
AND IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN IT'S
ALSO THE MOST POWERFUL TOOL TO
CHANGE ALIVE.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE PRESENTING
SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE TO PROVIDE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY CHANGE
YOUR LIFE WOULD CHANGE THE WORLD
AS WELL.
INCARCERATIONS SHOULD NOT BE
AUTOMATIC DISQUALIFICATION FOR
STUDENTS FROM THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE REMOVES
OUTDATED BARRIERS AND EXPAND
ACCESS TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INCARCERATED STUDENTS.
THROUGH THE SECOND CHANCE CAL
GRANTS WHILE SUPPORTING AFFECT
THE REBEL REBEL TATE OF EFFORTS
WITH IN OUR CORRECTIONAL
INSTITUTION AGAIN OF
REHABILITATION IS TO BE REAL
EDUCATION HOUSE TO BE PART OF IT.
MEMBERS PROVIDING FINANCIAL AID
TO INCARCERATED STUDENT IT'S NOT
NOTHING NEW HERE IN CALIFORNIA
NOR IN THIS COUNTRY.
HIGHER ED THE HIGHER EDUCATION
ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
AUTHORIZED THOSE WHO WERE
INCARCERATED TO BE ELIGIBLE. TO
RECEIVE A PELL GRANT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY DOING ARE
TOUGH ON CRIME.
WE ENDED THE PROGRAM.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA ANNOUNCES SECOND
CHANCE PELL GRANT PLY PILOT
PROGRAM TO ALLOW THOSE
INCARCERATED TO RECEIVE.
PELL GRANTS TO BRIDGE PURSUE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
IMPROVING THAT EDUCATION IS A
NON PARTISAN.
ISSUE.
THIS CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
EXTENDED TO A A BOMB ERA PILOT
PROGRAM FOR THE FOURTH TIME THIS
YEAR.
SO WHY IS CALIFORNIA NOT DOING
THE SAME THING WHEN THE BENEFITS
ARE CLEAR.
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE WHO TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE INCARCERATED TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION HOW
WILL 43% LOWER RECIDIVISM RATE.
EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED IN
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION
RESEARCHERS FOUND.
RETURNS FOUR TO FIVE DOLLARS
BACK TO SOCIETY CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY SPANS OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR TO
HOUSING INMATE.
YET FULL TIME EDUCATION FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS COSTS A LITTLE
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR WHAT EDUCATION ALONE DOES
NOT SOLVE OUR ISSUES AS IT
RELATES SIR.
INCARCERATION IN RECIDIVISM IT
IS IMPORTANT COMPONENT WHICH IS
WHY YOU WILL SEE A VARIETY OF
EDUCATIONAL IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
THE ABILITY TO HAVE A SECOND
CHANCE IS FUNDAMENTAL NOT ONLY
TO OUR STATE.
BUT TO OUR NATION THIS IS JUST A
FAIR PASS AND I I MEAN IN
STATING THE SECOND CHANCE CAL
GRANT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
BORCHERS.
THE MAN PRESIDENT -- THIS IS THE
EARLY THE DAY OF CAL GRANTS --
BUT I WANTED -- TO COMMAND THE
AUTHOR.
OF FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
I DON'T HAVE DATA I HAVE NOT
SEEN ANY EVIDENCE -- THAT MIGHT
JUSTIFY.
BUT IT JUST TAKES COMMONSENSE
THE THING THAT.
YOU GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
WHILE THEY'RE INCARCERATED -- TO
BUILD UP SOME SKILLS TO BECOME
EDUCATED THAT THE RATE OF
RECIDIVISM HAS TO DRAW I CAN'T
IMAGINE A SCENARIO WHERE THAT'S
NOT THE CASE.
THIS I THINK IS A GOOD USE OF
OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS HEALTH
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE REDUCE THE
COST OF THE OVERHEAD THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS IS SOMETHING WORTH
SUPPORTING THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR ARCHULETA FALL BY
SENATOR WAYS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
YOU'VE HEARD ME BACK PROMOTE LAW
ENFORCEMENT YOU HEARD ME STAND
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS ACTUALLY IS THE BEST WAY TO
PREVENT THE KIDS WHEN THEY COME
OUT TO GET INVOLVED IN THE END
NEGATIVE ACTIVITIES.
THEY COME OUT WITH THE EDUCATION
THEY COME OUT WITH THE ABILITY
TO READ AND WRITE AND CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS A DOOR
OPENER.
AND I THINK IT'S A AND A QUALITY
ISSUE AS WELL SO I I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD STRONGLY CONSIDER.
APPROVING THIS MEASURED
APPROVING THIS BILL RATHER
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT IT IS
ONE THAT WILL CREATE NEW LIVES
NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE TO
TRULY NEEDED AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU BARBARA.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO THE
SIMPLY I DON'T WANT TO PILE ON
BUT I'M JUST SHOCKED COMPLETELY
SHOCKED.
THAT THIS LAW IS EVEN IN THE
BOOKS.
AFTER ALL THESE YEARS AND WE
COULDN'T OF DRESSES SOONER.
I JUST WANT -- TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR [inaudible] FOR FOR
PUSHING THIS BILL IN ADVOCATING
FOR THIS POPULATION.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN REDEMPTION.
HOW CAN YOU OF?
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE PUNISHMENTS
FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE DONE THEIR
TIME I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THIS IN
THIS POPULAR IT POPULATION TO
MAKE SURE THEY CAN RE INTEGRATED
SOCIETY GIVEN THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED.
AND THIS IS JUST A WONDERFUL
BILL.
CONGRATULATIONS AND BY I'D LIKE
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR IF THAT'S
NOT TOO LATE AS IT GOES TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
EXCELLENT WORK THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE COMMENTED
HERE I THINK IS OUT TO ADEQUATE
CLOSE BUT I WOULD JUST ADD I
THINK WE'VE REFLECTED WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES ARE IN OUR CURRENT
BUDGET BOTH THE SENATE.
AND THE GOVERNOR AND AS IT
RELATES TO EDUCATION AND AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WE OF COMMITTED TO
THAT IT SHOULD TOUCH ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHETHER THEY'RE
INCARCERATED AND NOT THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE NITROUS
QUICKLY AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
I BILL.
BY BURGESS.
AYE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO.
AYE TING.
AYE DODD.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROW.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE HI
JACKSON HI I JONES.
BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO.
NUMBER.
VIA CASKEY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS MORE LOCKED
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
MORRELL NO.
BY STURDY FOR KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SEND FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX SB.
SIX HUNDRED SENATE BILL SIX
HUNDRED BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
ANAK WILLING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE [inaudible]
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- AND
SENATORS SB SIX HUNDRED WILL
MAKE CLEAR WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT
THE STANDARD FERTILITY
PRESERVATION SERVICES.
WHEN A MEDICALLY NECESSARY
TREATMENT MAY DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY BECAUSE --
INFERTILITY ARE COVERED ARE A
COVERED BENEFIT BECAUSE THE LAW
DOES NOT EXPLICITLY SPELL OUT
EACH AND EVERY COVERED SERVICE
THERE IS CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS.
MANY PATIENTS HAVE BEEN
WRONGFULLY DENIED COVERAGE
DESPITE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE REPEATEDLY
AND CONSISTENTLY OVERTURNING
HEALTH PLAN DENIALS OF COVERAGE.
FOR FERTILITY PRESERVATION THESE
WRONGFUL DELAYS AND THE NILES
CONTINUE TO REGULARLY OCCUR AND
MULTIPLE HEALTH PLANS HAVE
BLATANTLY DEFIED.
THE MH SHE'S ORDER TO PAY
SPECIFIC CLAIMS COVERAGE WITH
PROP APPROVALS FOR CARE IS
CRITICAL FOR ACCESS.
THE REBEL RELATIVELY HIGH OUT OF
POCKET COSTS COUPLED WITH A
SHORT WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
UNDERGOING THESE PROCEDURES
BETWEEN DIAGNOSIS AND
COMMENCEMENT OF TREATMENT.
MAKE THEM ON AFFORDABLE FOR MANY
PATIENTS WITHOUT INSURANCE OR
HEALTH PLAN COVERAGE. FOR SOME
PATIENTS THIS POTENTIAL LOSS OF
PARENTHOOD IS VERY PROFOUND
CAUSING DEPRESSION LOWER QUALITY
OF LIFE AND A SOME STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN HE EVEN THE WILLING TO
STOP FOR LESS EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT.
OR FAILURE TO ADHERE TO
TREATMENT TO TRY TO MINIMUM THE
MINIMIZE THE LOSS OF FERTILITY
SB SIX HUNDRED IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS CAN OBTAIN
FERTILITY PRESERVATION
IMMEDIATELY.
ENABLING THEM TO FOCUS ON THEIR
TREATMENT AN UNDERLYING DISEASE
CONDITION AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE
OF DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
AND HEARING NONE.
I'M SORRY SENATOR BOARD JUST.
MADAM PRESIDENT MAY I POSE A
QUESTION TO THE ALL TO ACCEPT
THE QUESTION I WANT WITHOUT
OBJECTION YOU MAY PROCEED.
MAYBE YOU CAN -- OFFER
CLARIFICATION ON THIS -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
CLARIFIES THAT AN INDIVIDUAL OR
GROUP HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN --
CONTRACTOR HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICY THAT COVERS HOSPITAL
MEDICAL OR SURGICAL EXPENSES
INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR STANDARD
FERTILITY PRESERVATION SERVICES.
THE STANDARD FERTILITY
PRESERVATION SERVICES CAN YOU
GIVE ME A QUICK.
UNDERSTANDING THAT'S NOT
FERTILITY SERVICES ITS FERTILITY
PRESERVATION IS THAT.
SO IT'S HARVESTING OF EGGS AND
SPERM PRIMARILY. TO PRESERVE
SOMEONE'S OPTION FOR FERTILITY
WHEN THE MANDATES ORIGINALLY
CREATED WHEN.
CHEMOTHERAPY TREATMENTS WORK.
YOU KNOW BECAME THE STANDARD OF
CARE THEY WERE ABOUT THIRTY
EIGHT COVERED CONSEQUENCES OF
CHEMO -- FERTILITY PRESERVATION
WAS NOT -- ONE NOW IT WOULD BE
COVERED -- I KNOW ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT'S COME UP WITH.
THE CREATION OF EMBRYOS -- BUT
AS THE STANDARD OF FERTILITY
PRESERVATION HAS GOTTEN.
BETTER AND MORE EFFICIENT --
EGGS ARE JUST AS EFFECTIVE IN SO
THAT'S TYPICALLY THE PRIMARY USE
FOR PRIMARY CHOSEN FERTILITY
PRESERVATION METHOD FOR WOMEN
OBVIOUSLY FOR MAN IT'S IT'S
DIFFERENT -- SO THAT'S THE STATS
THE COVERAGE SO PRESERVING AG'S
PRESERVING SPERM ALLOWING THAT
PERSON TO GET.
CURED.
AND THEN CAN HAVE A FAMILY AFTER
THEIR CURED OF THEIR CANCER OR
OTHER ELEMENT TO FOLLOW QUESTION --
IS -- PURITY TIME THAT I'M SORRY
SENATOR WE ACCEPT THE FOLLOWING
QUESTION ALL EXCEPT TO FOLLOW
THANK.
SO IS THERE A PERIOD OF TIME
THAT -- THE COVERAGE WOULD ALLOW
FOR THE PRESERVATION OF THOSE
EGGS IS IT ONLY DURING.
THE CANCER TREATMENT OR THE THE
TREATMENT.
OR IN PERPETUITY IS IT SIGNED
ITS PRIOR TO TREATMENT.
BUT AFTER BUT AFTER THE
TREATMENT IT IS THEN BECOME THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE OF THE
INSURANCE CARRIER OR THE
INDIVIDUAL TO MAINTAIN THOSE
EGGS.
IN A FROZEN STATE I THINK THERE
ONCE THEY'RE HARVARD AND THEIR
FROZEN I I ACTUALLY HAVE. TO TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU DON'T KNOW
LONG DON'T KNOW THE LONGEVITY OF
THAT COMMITMENT BUT TYPICALLY
WHOEVER HARBORS SCHISM.
THE HAS A CONTRACT WITH THE
CRYOGENIC LABORATORY TO FREEZE
THEM AND STORE THEM AS PART OF
THAT TREATMENT SO I THINK IT'S A
BUILT IN COST. FOR A FULL
SERVICE FERTILITY PRESERVATION.
THAT I THINK WOULD BE IMPORTANT
TO FIND OUT -- THIS HITS HOME
FOR ME ON A VERY PERSONAL LEVEL --
FOR A COUPLE YEARS MY WIFE WENT
THROUGH -- SHE WENT THROUGH A
LOT OF TREATMENT [inaudible]
AND THIS ISSUE CAME UP.
AND IT ADDED INSULT TO THAT
INJURY.
AND I THINK I I HAVE SOME ISSUES
ON A POLICY LEVEL I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY.
WHERE?
EVERYTHING PLAYS OUT WITH THIS
LEGISLATION.
BUT I THINK THE ABILITY TO
PRESERVE A WOMAN'S RIGHT -- OF
OF COUPLES RIGHT TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
IS SO TANTAMOUNT AND FUNDAMENTAL
TO OUR HUMAN CONDITION CONDITION
EXPERIENCE.
THIS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED A
COMPONENT OF THAT SERVICE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE.
THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES AND I WANT TO THANK.
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING US THREE
SIX HUNDRED FORWARD AND I ALSO
WANT.
TO COMMEND MY MY FRESHMAN
SENATOR -- FOR ASKING A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD QUESTIONS TODAY AND
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
WE HAVE ISSUES WITH BILLS THAT
ARE COMING FORWARD SO I JUST
WANNA THROW LITTLE SHOT OUT TO
YOU.
BUT I WOULD SAY WITHOUT THAT ONE
OF THE WORST DIAGNOSES AT A A
MAN OR A YOUNG MAN WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR IS THAT THEY HAVE TO STICK
A CANCER OR A WOMAN HAVING
CERVICAL CANCER OVARIAN CANCER.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IT ALLOWS SOMEONE THAT GETS THIS
DIAGNOSIS AND HAS TO GET WHAT'S
CALLED AN ORCHIECTOMY DOCTOR CAN
THOSE WITH THAT IS AS WHEN YOU
HAVE.
THE MALE GENITALS -- BASICALLY --
REMOVE THE **** REMOVED OR IF
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO HAS TO HAVE
A HYSTERECTOMY.
OR HAS TO UNDERGO SOME
CHEMOTHERAPY THAT CAN CAUSE SOME
LONG TERM DAMAGE TO THESE ORGANS.
PRIOR TO INITIATING THE THIRD
THE SURGERY OR THE CHEMOTHERAPY.
ONE CAN PRESERVE THEIR SPERM OR
THEIR AEGS.
SO THAT THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE A PARENT.
IN THE FUTURE.
THE CHALLENGE WITH THIS
[inaudible]
WAY OF PRESERVING THE SPERM ARE
THE AGES IT IS VERY EXPENSIVE
AND WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES WOULDN'T
WANT.
TO PAY FOR THE SERVICE IN A
CERTAINLY OUT OF THE ROOM -- FOR
MANY YOUNG COUPLES OR MIDDLE AGE
COUPLES FOR THAT MATTER TO PAY
FOR THE SERVICES.
IT'S A VERY NARROW WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU WILL TO ALLOW
SOMEONE TO HAVE THE JOYS.
AND THE PLEASURE.
OF BEING A PARENT OF A CHILD.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ALLOW
THOSE COUPLES THAT HAVE ALREADY
HAVE THE ODDS STACKED AGAINST
THEM IN LIFE WITH THESE.
HORRIBLE DIAGNOSES. TO HOPEFULLY.
RECOVER FROM THESE DIAGNOSES.
BUT ENJOY.
THE LOVE AND A PLEASURE OF BEING
A PARENT ONE DAY FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SHOULD STAND UP AND
SUPPORT SB.
SIX HUNDRED THANK YOU CENTER
STONE ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SIR PORTANTINO SOUNDS LIKE A
LOVE FEST YOU MAKE FUNDS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE WHAT ONE
COMMENT IN RESPONSE -- HAVING.
THIS ABILITY.
ALLOWS PATIENTS TO PRESERVE
THEIR PRESENT OF FERTILITY AND
GET CURED QUICKER THERE'S
ACTUALLY ECONOMIC MODELS TO SHOW
THAT THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
WILL SAVE MONEY.
BECAUSE WHEN PATIENTS DELAY
TREATMENT OR TRY TO HAVE A BABY
IN THE NEXT NINE MONTHS THEY GET
SICKER AND HAVE MORE CUTE --
INSTANCES OF HEALTH CARE NEEDS
AND IT ACTUALLY COSTS INSURANCE
COMPANY MORE AND THE ADVANCES IN
FERTILITY PRESERVATION ARE OUT
OF THE STRATOSPHERE BETTER THAN
THEY WERE TWENTY YEARS AGO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
COPYRIGHT.
I CHIANG BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY HAMBURG.
IA CASKEY BY WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BRADFORD I JONES.
BY VICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY ONE SENATOR GLAZER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX TEMAS SENATOR
GLAZER AN ACTOR LINDA
CONTRACTORS [inaudible]
SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SAT.
SB SIX TEN IS THE SON SAID BILL
FOR THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD.
THE BILL EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATA
THE BOARD UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND MAKES
OTHER CHANGES STEMMING FROM THIS
YEAR'S SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
OF THE BOARD.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY THREE SENATOR STERN.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR HUESO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETEEN BY
SENATOR HUESO ANAK RULING TO
PROMISE ZONES SENATOR HUESO.
MEMBERS CREDIT IS A NECESSITY IN
TODAY'S ECONOMY.
A PERSON'S CREDIT SCORE DECIDES
EVERYTHING FROM INTEREST RATES
LOAN TERMS THE SIZE OF THEIR
SECURITY DEPOSIT AND WHETHER A
RENTAL APPLICATION IS APPROVED
OR DEMOTT DENIED.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE SEEKING A RENTAL
UNIT?
SB SIX ONE NINE CREATES THE RENT
CREDIT REPORTING PILOT PROGRAM
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PROMISE ZONES.
BRENT REPORTING IS ONE
ATTENDANCE MONTHLY RENTAL
PAYMENTS ARE FURNISHED TO A
CONSUMER CREDIT BUREAU SO THEY
CAN BE INCLUDED.
ON THEIR CREDIT REPORT. FOR MOST
TEN IN. FOR MOST TENANTS FOR
MOST PEOPLE RENT IS THE LARGEST
PAYMENT THEY MAKE EACH MONTH
WITHOUT RECEIVING THE CREDIT
BENEFIT A LOT THAT --
TRADITIONAL MORTGAGE HOLDER GETS.
THIS WILL OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE IN.
PROMISE ZONES TO ESTABLISH THEIR
CREDITS A PILOT PROGRAM WE'RE
GETTING KICKED OFF WITHIN THESE
AREAS TO SEE IF IT'S A VIABLE
PROGRAM TO IMPLEMENT STATEWIDE
SOMETIME.
IN THE FUTURE.
LAST FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO HELP GET
PEOPLE ACCESS TO CREDIT.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION.
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD BILL.
THIS IS A GREAT BILL. ONE
O'CLOCK MY FRIEND FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR BRINGING AFFORD.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE WILL OF THE
BIGGEST RATE LIMITING STEPS TO
SOME OF OUR MIDDLE INCOME FOLKS
FROM BUYING A HOME IS.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY FOR
THE DOWN PAYMENT AND THEY DON'T
HAVE A CREDIT HISTORY TO GET A
MORTGAGE.
SO I THINK THIS BILL GOES A LONG
WAY.
IN GIVING PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
A CREDIT HISTORY THE SHOW THAT
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE THAT THEY
PAY THE RENT ON TIME.
AND HOPEFULLY THEY CAN PUT A FEW
BUCKS AWAY.
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL SEE PRICES
LEVEL OFF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CREATE MORE MORE
HOMEOWNERS AND AND REALLY
RESTORE THE AMERICAN DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THE STATE AND%
FOR THOSE REASONS I HEARD AND I
VOTE ON SB.
SIX ONE NINE THANK YOU SENATOR
STONE.
CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I HAVE
TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
THANK YOU -- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IT IS REALLY HARD TO
ESTABLISH CREDIT IN THIS STATE
AND TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO USE THEIR
RENT CHECKS OR THEIR RENT
PAYMENTS WHEN THEY PAY THEM ON
TIME.
IS A GREAT IDEA IN ORDER TO
ESTABLISH CREDIT BECAUSE IF YOU
CAN PAY SIX SEVEN EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH RENT IT'S PAID ON TIME
THAT WOULD EQUAL HOPEFULLY ONE
DAY THE AMERICAN DREAM AND
BUYING A HOME AND HAVING THAT
CREDIT.
AND BEING ABLE TO BE
SUBSTANTIATED BY -- ON TIME
PAYMENTS SO THIS IS A GREAT A
BILL AND I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
HUESO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THIS SIMPLY US FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BELL BY BURGESS.
I BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO.
AYE CHIANG.
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
BY WITH SOME.
BY HER TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M RAIL.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE [inaudible]
BOB AKOWSKI.
HI WINNER BY WILK.
HI VICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY SIX SB SIX TWENTY
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACT
REALLY INTO CRIMINAL OFFENDER
RECORD INFORMATION SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SIX TWENTY WHICH WOULD UNITS
WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZED TO
SPECIFIED LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. TO FURNISH LIMITED
INFORMATION ABOUT PERSONS ON
SUPERVISED RELEASE WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION TO NONPROFIT
PROVIDERS OF SERVICE.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE A PERSON
ON SUPERVISED RELEASE TO BE
NOTIFIED THAT THEIR INFORMATION
MAY BE RELEASED FOR THIS PURPOSE.
FOR THIS PURPOSE AND ONE ALLOW
THESE PART PERSONS TO ADOPT IN
TO THE PROGRAM SO THEIR
INFORMATION COULD BE RELEASED
WITH THEIR PERMISSION.
WHEN SOMEONE IS RELEASED?
FROM INCARCERATION THE RETURN TO
THEIR CITY OF RESIDENCE.
FRANKLY WITHOUT GUIDANCE OR IN
THE NEEDED REPORT WITH THE
NEEDED RESOURCES TO GET THEIR
LIFE BACK ON TRACK.
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY 47% OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO RETURNED
FROM INCARCERATION REPEAT
OFFENDER.
AND ARE RE INCARCERATED WITHIN
THREE YEARS THIS RESULTS IN
PREDICTABLE PREVENTABLE
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA IN
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE MANY RAISE
THEIR FAMILIES.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
HAVE RELEASED DATA AND THE
PERSONNEL INFORMATION OF EVERY
PAROLE LEE AND POST RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
PROBATIONER HOWEVER THEY CANNOT
CONNECT.
THESE PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS OR RELEASE THIS
INFORMATION AS THEY CANNOT
CONNECT THOSE PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED WITH THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT CAN HELP THEM.
IN MANY INSTANCES WITH JOB
TRAINING DRUG TREATMENT ALL
KINDS OF SERVICES THAT ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO LOWER THE
RECIDIVISM RATE AND GIVE.
THAT RECENTLY INCARCERATED
PERSON A CHANCE TO DO SOMETHING
ELSE BY HAVING CONTACT
INFORMATION. FOR THOSE PROVIDED
TO THE PROVIDERS -- CITY CHAU
RECIDIVISM Là HOURS AND THESE
FOLKS HAVE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING WITH THEIR LIVES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX SEEING
AND HEARING NONE.
MR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
TELL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED.
NO BRADFORD.
I COMING AT ALL.
I CHIANG BY DOT I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROVE [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON LIKE I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE AYE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO NUMBER.
PILOT CASKEY.
I WIENER.
BY WILK.
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES.
NO [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR MORNING.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR MONNING AN ACT RELATING
TO CANNABIS CULTIVATION SENATOR
MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN ALLOWS A
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER
TO INCLUDE CANNABIS PRODUCTION
DATA.
AS AN ADDENDUM TO THE COUNTY'S
ANNUAL AGRICULTURAL REPORT.
BETTER KNOWN AS THE CROP REPORT.
THE DATA COLLECTED WOULD BE
ORGANIZED BY SPECIFIC CATEGORIES
SOME COUNTIES ARE FINDING THAT
BECAUSE CANNABIS IS CURRENTLY
NOT INCLUDED IN THE ANNUAL CROP
REPORT.
IT IS NOT AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION OF A COUNTIES
AGRICULTURAL CULTIVATION.
NORMALIZING CANNABIS IS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT WILL
ENCOURAGE UNLICENSED GROWERS TO
COME FORWARD.
BECOME LEGITIMATE PERMITTED IN
TAX PAYING BUSINESSES.
THIS MEASURE DOES NOT MANDATE
THIS MEASURE ALLOWS AT COUNTY TO
INCLUDE THIS IN ITS CROP REPORT
IF IT CHOOSES TO DO SO MEMBERS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL.
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WITH SO -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES.
HI.
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
TIME WERE LOCKED.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN.
AYE STONE BY NUMBER.
BY WORK OWSKI BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HIGH MORALE [inaudible]
NO.
NIELSEN NO ICE THIRTY TWO KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ALONG TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SIX SENATOR BRADFORD FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY SIX MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN OH FOUR BUT
CENTER BRADFORD ENACT WILLING TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SENATOR
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB
SEVEN OH FOUR TO SIX STANDS THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM THAT WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHTY SEVEN BY FORMER SOMEONE
PERSON.
OGWEN MORE AS WE KNOW LIFELINE
IS A LOW INCOME PHONE SERVICE
AND YOU KNOW -- THE TELEPHONY
HAS CHANGED OVER THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS MOST FOLKS HAD A LAND
LINE AT THEIR HOME NOW THEY'RE
USING WIRED WIRELESS DEVICES SO --
THIS AFFORDS THOSE INDIVIDUALS
MANY OF WHOM ARE OUT OF FOSTER
CARE -- HOMELESS TO ACCESS --
THE LIFELINE PROGRAMMERS BUT
LAST YEAR I VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SIX SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
COPYRIGHT [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
DODD.
BY DORADO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADA.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY COUNTY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES [inaudible]
BRADFORD HI [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BOMBERG [inaudible]
WILK.
PRICE TWENTY SEVEN NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS CENTER PORTANTINO
FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR I RISE TO
ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION OF FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX SB.
SIX TWENTY WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT WILL BE SO ORDERED.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO UNDER
RECONSIDERATION.
GREEK CONSIDERATIONS GRANTED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WE ARE BACK ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY SIX FOR A REVOTE
SENATOR.
PORTANTINO IS REQUESTED THAT AND
MISTER SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I HAD CONSENT.
I BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY STONE NO NUMBER.
VIA CASSIE I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
HI.
WILK HI HI.
I THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ALONG TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE NINETY NINE SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY NINE TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND EXPLAINED
EDUCATION FINANCE SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SB SEVEN TWENTY NINE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE AMOUNT OF THE BASS
GRANT FOR THE 200-019-2000
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR FOR THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THE INCREASE BY A FIVE POINT ONE
SIX COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
THE LC FF WAS IN IMPLEMENTED IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN PLACING
FUNDING DECISIONS IN THE HAND OF
LOCAL DISTRICTS LAST YEAR.
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET -- WAS A
COLA AND THIS INCREASES THE CALL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE
OF DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY NINE SEEING IN
HERE I'M SORRY SENATOR CHIANG.
COULD YOU PLEASE SIR.
ALL RIGHT YOU'RE ALL SET TO GO
CENTER CHIANG FLOORS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANT
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR ON THIS
GREAT BILLS INCREASE THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA BASED
GRANT.
LCF OF HAS BEEN A POSITIVE MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION OF KATE
THE TWELVE FUNDING.
SUPPORTING THOSE STUDENTS MOST
IN NEED BUT THERE ARE STILL
SCHOOLS THAT STROLL MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS FOR STUDENTS AND
THOUGH THIS BILL MEANS PROGRESS
IN HER.
PEOPLE FINDING WAYS TO HAVE MORE
TO DO AS WE SHOULD AIM TO BE
RANKED HIGHER RELATIVE TO OTHER
STATES ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG ANY
OTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING ON
CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAY CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ALL DEBATEHAVING SEIZED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
I HARSH LETTER.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I BILL.
GORGEOUS THANKS I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CHIANG.
I DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
I OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES I LEYVA
[inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY AMBER I CASKEY.
AYE WIENER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BELL.
HI.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO WITH
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG
TO FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED SENATOR
BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD ENACT WILLING
TO WORKERS COMPENSATION SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SB SEVEN THREE ONE
PROHIBITS TO REDUCTION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION BENEFITS ON
THE BASIS OF A MUTABLE.
FACTORS SUCH AS RACE GENDER AND
GENETIC MAKE UP.
THIS BILL RESPONSE TO RECENT
COURT DECISION WHICH I INJURED
WORKER PERMANENTLY DISABILITY
THE PERMIT DISABILITY BENEFITS
WERE REDUCE 49% BECAUSE OF THEIR
GENETIC DISPOSITION INDIVIDUALS
SUCH.
WITH LUPUS AND SICKLE CELL AND
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE THIS BILL
PROVIDES ADDED PROTECTION TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS AND
ENSURES THAT THEY ARE TREATED
EQUALLY AND FAIRLY WHEN
RECEIVING THE BENEFITS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR MORRELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- TODAY I RISE WITH A
FEW CONCERNS ABOUT SB.
SEVEN THIRTY ONE I DID SUPPORT
IT THIS BILL IN LABOR AND PURSE
COMMITTEE -- BUT UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE AUTHOR WAS
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION --
FOR THIS BILL SO WHILE I STILL
SUPPORT THIS GOAL THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
OPPOSITION -- TO THE BROAD
LANGUAGE A GENETIC
CHARACTERISTICS -- HAS BEEN
HEARD AND THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED.
AND SO I GUESS QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR.
IF YOU WERE SENATOR WE TAKE A
QUESTION.
HAVE THOSE CONCERNS BETTER WILL
WILL WILL HE HE'S GOT TO APPROVE
THAT.
YES I WILL ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD
YOU MAKE IT GO AHEAD AMY HAD NOT
THEY'LL.
I MUST'VE MISSED IT FROM THIS
ANGLE.
SO GO AHEAD AND ASK YOUR
QUESTION.
I HAVE THOSE CONCERNS BEEN
ADDRESSED WE ARE STILL WORKING
ON THOSE HAVE WE GOTHIC
AGREEMENT ALL NO BUT THERE WERE
STILL IN.
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE OURS
RECKLESS FOR A VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD I CAPITAL
[inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DOT.
BY THE RISE OF HI GALGIANI
[inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG BILIK OWSKI.
I WIENER.
BY WILK.
HI.
VICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG TO
FILE ITEM TWO OH SIX SENATOR
STERN.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM TO
THIRTEEN SENATOR ALAN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM.
TO THIRTEEN SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR ALAN
AND ACTUALLY TO FOOD SAFETY
SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS IS SIMPLE BUT
IMPORTANT MEASURE IT'S BASED ON
LAWS THAT EXIST IN -- IT WE SIX
OTHER STATES -- AND HAS TO DO
WITH -- THE USE OF NATURAL LATEX
GLOVES IN RESTAURANTS OTHER FOOD
FACILITIES.
THE 6% OF FOLKS IN THE U. S. ARE
ALLERGIC TO LATEX INCLUDING UP
217% OF HEALTH CARE AND FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS AN 11% OF THE
ELDERLY.
WHY IS IT SO MUCH HIGHER AMOUNTS
FOOD SERVICE WORKERS WELL IT'S
BECAUSE?
THERE ARE ALSO REALLY EXPOSED A
LOT MORE TO TO LAY TAX I WHICH
AND IT'S BECOMING -- RESULTING
IN MANY CASES IT WITH A LIFE
THREATENING ALLERGY.
AND SO FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM THIS ALLERGY EVEN
TRACE AMOUNTS OF NATURAL RUBBER
LATEX CAN BE DEADLY.
NOW RECOGNIZING THE GROWING
THREAT OF LATEX EXPOSURE THE CDC
AND THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
RECOMMEND WORKERS QUOTE.
USE OF NON LATEX GLOVES FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NOT LIKELY
TO INVOLVE CONTACT WITH
INFECTIOUS MATERIALS.
SUCH AS FOOD PREPARATION ROUTINE
HOUSEKEEPING GENTLEMEN IS
ETCETERA.
AND MANY RESIDENTS OF ALREADY
GONE LATEX FREE AS MANY HEALTH
CARE AND DENTAL FACILITIES THAT
ONE PROTECT OUR STAFF.
ALTERNATIVE SUCH AS NITRILE
GLOVES OFFER THE SAME AND FOR
BETTER PROTECTION AND HERE'S THE
THING THERE ARE.
MOST OFTEN CHEAPER.
SO -- THIS -- PHASES OUT THE USE
OF LATEX IN.
RESTAURANTS WE'VE HAD LONG
CONVERSATIONS WITH FOLKS IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND AND THEY
ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THEY THINK THERE'S AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT FOR PORTION
THE POPULATION -- THAT IS NOT
ABLE TO GO OUT TO YOU RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
COMFORT OF KNOWING -- THAT THAT
THEY THEY WON'T.
BE AT RISK OF OF X. DANGERS
EXPOSURE -- THIS WILL MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE THE FACT WE'VE
GOT ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE BOTH
SAFER AND ALSO LESS EXPENSIVE
OUT THERE ARE GIVES GREAT
COMFORT TO OUR FRIENDS IN
INDUSTRY.
AND WITH THAT -- THE THE BILL'S
RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HEALTH COMMITTEE ASK PRIVATE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
STONE.
THANK YOU MY PRESIDENT IS NOT
VERY OFTEN I GET TO STAND UP AND
SUPPORT ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
FROM US ANIMA BECAUSE BILLS.
AND SO I AM VERY PROUD -- TO TO
STAND UP AND WE SEE LATEX
ALLERGY CERTAINLY IN THE IN THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD -- IN A WORST
CASE SCENARIO YOU CAN YOU CAN
GET ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK IN FACT
WE HAD ONE OF THE WITNESSES AT
WHEN SHE CAME IN CONTACT WITH
LATEX YOU COULD HAVE A LIFE
THREATENING -- ISSUE WOULD HAVE
TO CARRIER ON ACTUALLY -- THE
EMERGENCY PACK WITH HER WITH THE
UNHAPPY TEND TO MAKE SURE THAT
SHE CAN REVIVED IN THE EVENT
THAT SOMEBODY THAT DID HAVE
CONTACT WITH LATEX.
HAD CONTACT WITH HER WITHOUT HER
KNOWING IT OF THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES OUT
THERE BOTH IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
AND IN THE RESTAURANT FIELD.
WHETHER EQUAL OR LESS EXPENSIVE
AND SO IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
PROTECTING OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR RESIDENTS ARE URGED AYE
VOTE ON SB TWO SIX SB.
SIX SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SING IN.
SEEING HEARING HEARING NONE
SENATOR ALAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
HI I VERY MUCH AS A I THINK MY
MY FRIEND FROM TO MACULA FOR HIS
SUPPORT AND ASK FOR A VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZE
DISCERNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTEEN SENATOR BELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TEN BY SENATOR BELL
AND ACTUALLY TO MENTAL HEALTH
SENATOR BILL.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS
BILL SB TEN ESTABLISHES A
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST.
APPEAR PROVIDER IS A PERSON WHO
HAS LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS. FORTY EIGHT STATES
HAVE NOW ADOPTED HERE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS MEANING
THEY HAVE ESTABLISHED A CLEAR
BASIC STANDARDS FOR PEER
TRAINING.
MEDICAID REIMBURSES -- 450% OF
THE COST OF THE PIER SERVICES IN
STATES WHERE CERTIFICATION
PROGRAMS REDUCING THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
ON OUR COUNTY PROVIDERS THE BILL
WILL MAKE SURE PEERS GET THE
TRAINING THEY NEED TO DO THEIR
BEST WORK.
IT WOULD ALSO HELP GROW OUR
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
RESULT IN BETTER CARE THIS BILL
HAS STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
REGION I VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS FOR
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTEEN SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM TO
EIGHTEEN SENATOR LEYVA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA
AN ACT RELATING TO EVIDENCE.
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS IN SPITE OF
THE FORMER GOVERNOR SHORT
SIGHTED VETO OF MY SB FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE LAST YEAR OUCH.
WHAT MAKE SURE EVERYBODY'S
AWAKEN LISTENING I KNOW THAT WE
ALL REMAIN FULLY COMMITTED TO
MAKING THE PROMPT TESTING OF
RAPE KIDS A REALITY WHICH IS WHY
I AM BEFORE YOU TODAY WITH THIS
RE INTRODUCTION?
THE CORE OF SB TWENTY TWO IS
ACTUALLY VERY SIMPLE BUT IT WILL
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF SURVIVORS AND HELP PUT
RAPISTS BEHIND BARS.
THIS MAJOR SIMPLY CHANGES ONE
WORD IN EXISTING LAW BY SAYING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND FORENSIC LABORATORIES SHALL
FOLLOW INSTEAD OF SHOULD FOLLOW
AS IT CURRENTLY STATES LISTED
TIME FRAMES FOR SUBMITTING AND
ANALYZING RAPE KIT EVIDENCE.
MEMBERS MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT
JUST THREE YEARS AGO MY SB EIGHT
THIRTEEN WHICH ELIMINATED THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ON RATE
WAS SIGNED INTO AW.
THOUGH THAT WAS CERTAINLY A HUGE
VICTORY THE ROAD TO JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS OF RAPE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT WILL BE INCOMPLETE IF
THE RAPE KITS ARE NEVER TESTED.
AND THEY JUST SAID IN A
WAREHOUSE OR EVIDENCE LOCKER
SOMEWHERE COLLECTING DUST ALL
RAPE SURVIVORS TO SPOT DESERVE
TO HAVE THE RATE KIDS TESTED
PROMPTLY.
WHICH CAN IN TURN HELP TO ENSURE
JUSTICE IDENTIFIES SERIAL
PERPETRATORS AND EVEN EXONERATE
THE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR STONE THANK YOU
BETTER PRESIDENT I PROBABLY
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
TWO AND I'M HONORED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR WITH -- THAT THE GREAT
SENATOR FROM CHINO HILLS AND I
APPRECIATE HER STEADFAST.
EFFORTS TO CONTINUE -- TO ENSURE
THAT THESE RATE KIDS THAT ARE
VERY EXPENSIVE BY THE WAY -- TO
TO GET WHEN YOU GO -- THREE
START EXAMINING COUNTY HOSPITAL
OR ANOTHER HOSPITAL WE WE WE DO
OUR BEST TO THE EVIDENCE
PRESERVE SO THAT WE GET THE TOOL
STORE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. TO
FILE CASES AGAINST A SUCKER
PREDATORS AND AND LET THEM FACE
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR CRIMES
SO AGAIN THANKS TO THE US
SENATOR FROM CHINO HILLS STRONG
URGE AN AYE VOTE IN SB.
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND ARE ALSO WANT TO
THANK OUR I'M CALLING FROM CHINO --
WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS WERE
TRYING.
TO GET THROUGH IN THE GOD THIS
WEEK AND NEXT AND I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT THIS BILL IS GOING
TO BE VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO STE THE END
UP AND SPEAK TO IT BECAUSE AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TO MACULA POINTED
OUT [inaudible]
THE IF A PERSON WHO WAS SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED.
GOES TO THE TROUBLE OF REPORTING
IT THAT'S THE FIRST THING%
BECAUSE IT'S NUMBER.
ONE VERY FEW.
SEXUAL ASSAULTS OR EVEN REPORTED.
AND THEN THEY ARE WILLING TO
SUBJECT THEMSELVES TO THE MAN
MEDICAL EXAMINATION AND WE'RE
NOT TALKING A SIMPLE MEDICAL
EXAMINATION THIS IS AN
EXAMINATION THAT TAKES HOURS.
AND IS VERY INVASIVE SO THEN
THAT PERSON SUBJECT THEMSELVES
TO THAT.
AND THEN THAT EVIDENCE WHICH IS
THEN PUT INTO SOMETHING WE CALL
A RAPE KIT WHICH ARE -- REFER TO
IS THAT A REFER TO IT AS THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE.
AND THEN IT IS NOT THE DNA IF
THEN THAT EVIDENCE IS LEFT ON
THE SHELF.
IN NO DNA IS EVER EXTRACTED.
THEN WHY DID THE PERSON GO TO
EVEN TO THE TROUBLE OF REPORTING
IT WE'RE GOING TO THE MEDICAL
EXAMINATION.
SO [inaudible]
TO INSURER THAT PEOPLE WHO
SUFFER SEXUAL ASSAULT HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEIR CRIME WILL
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
WE MUST TEST ALL EVIDENCE FROM
SEXUAL ASSAULTS I ASKED ZERO
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
BRIEFLY I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE WHICH IS PROUDLY WANT TO
SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THAT AT L. A. -- AT CAL STATE
LOS ANGELES FOR THE LARGEST
CRIME LAB EXISTS IN THE COUNTRY
THERE IS NO BACKLOG IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BUT THE REST OF
THE STATE NEEDS THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
BAD BACK I SHOULD SAY.
BACK SLAPPING OR OTHERWISE.
SENATOR LEYVA THE FLOOR IS YOURS
TO CONCLUDE YOUR REMARKS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
WE KNOW THAT DNA SOLVES CRIMES
SO LET'S GET THIS OFF THE SENATE
FLOOR OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AND HOPEFULLY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO TWENTY TWO
SENATOR ROSS DO YOU WISH TO TAKE
UP THE SIDE OF PASS ON FILE FILE
ITEMTO TWENTY THREE SENATOR
ALAN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM TWO TO THREE SENATE
BILL FIFTY NUMBER SENATOR ALAN
ACT RELATING TO A THOMAS VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY SENATOR ALAN.
MEMBERS -- THE INTRODUCTION OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES HAS THE
POTENTIAL. TO REVOLUTIONIZE THE
HOW WE GET AROUND IN RESHAPING.
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT IS SOME
EXTRAORDINARY POTENTIAL BENEFITS
RIGHT THE THE UNIT THIS
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY MAY
DRASTICALLY REDUCE COLLISIONS.
ME ENHANCE TRAFFIC FLOW -- THAT
CERTAINLY VERY PROMISING.
BUT ON THE FLIP SIDE IF NOT
THOUGHT FULLY DEPLOYED -- THIS
NEW TECH MOBILITY REVOLUTION
COULD ACTUALLY HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACTS --
INCLUDING EXACERBATING
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY SEVERE
CLIMB AND AIR QUALITY PLANNING
AND CONGESTION CHALLENGES.
ARE THERE WAS A RECENT STUDY FOR
EXAMPLE THE CAME OUT THAT SHOWED
THAT IT AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
ACTUALLY INCREASE.
TRAFFIC -- THE THEY DID A STUDY.
BASED ON GIVING FOLKS OF A
ACCESS TO A FREE SHOW FOR WHO
JUST.
DRIVING AROUND WHENEVER THEY
WANTED TO SEE WHAT SORT OF
BEHAVIORS WITH WITH IN SU.
AND THE PEOPLE A LITTLE HAVE
THEIR DRIVER TO CIRCLE AROUND
THE BLOCK SO AS NOT TO HAVE TO
FIND PARKING AND PAY FOR PARKING --
YOU KNOW THESE TYPES OF GHOSTS
TRIPS COULD UNDERCUT THE
CONGESTION BENEFITS THAT WE
EXPECT FROM REDUCE COLLISIONS
THE OTHER THING IS THEY FOUND IT
BECAUSE IT'S SO.
NICE AND EASY CAN BE A NOT TO
pWILLING TO GET -- BEHIND THE
WHEEL AND AND AND TIED INTO A
CAR AND AND AND AND DRIVE AROUND.
SO THIS BILL CREATES AN
INTERAGENCY WORK GROUP TO
DELIBERATELY PLAN FOR AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES IN A WAY THAT SUPPORTS
OUR GOALS.
ARE HOUSING GOALS ARE PLANNING
GOALS ARE SEEN THE BILL THE
GOALS WITH THE MIND TOWARD
AVOIDING POTENTIAL NEGATIVE
IMPACTS IT TAKES A AN ABSOLUTE
DOESN'T COME IN WITH AN ATTITUDE
THAT -- THIS IS A GOOD THING OR
A BAD THING IT JUST SAYS THIS IS
COMING.
THERE'S A LOT OF POTENTIAL
BENEFITS LET'S TRY TO MAXIMIZE
THE BENEFITS AND MITIGATE THE
NEGATIVES.
OUR WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING INDUSTRY
GROUPS AUTOMAKERS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS -- AND AND AND
AND CONSUMER GROUPS AS WELL TO
REFINE THE MEASURE TO ENSURE
THAT WE GOT OUT AHEAD OF THIS
PARADIGM SHIFT IN -- AND BUT DO
SO IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T STYMIE
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY AND SO THE
MEASURE HAS.
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
GLAZERS -- OUT OF PRESIDENT NOT
A PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FROM -- SANTA
MONICA FOR GETTING IN FRONT OF
THE THIS THIS TECHNOLOGY AND
WHAT IT MEANS.
AND THE IMPACT IT WILL HAVE AN I
AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF IT GOING
FORWARD TODAY I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD ASK THE SENATOR IS THAT.
ARE THERE ARE -- IMPACTS BEYOND
WHICH YOU THINK IDENTIFIED IN
THE BILL CERTAINLY -- FOR THOSE
WHO CURRENTLY ARE DRIVERS OF
VEHICLES IN OUR OUR WORLD.
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO PLANNING
FOR MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT --
HE RAISES IN THE BILL I THINK
PLANNING FOR THE DISPLACEMENT OF
WORKERS IS ANOTHER VERY
IMPORTANT IMPACT -- THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED GOING FORWARD AND
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO TO LOOK AT
THAT DOING THAT THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR MORLOCK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION
YES YES WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- TO
SENATOR I HAVE BEEN -- ENJOYING
THIS SUBJECT AND ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT WE'VE BEEN EXPLORING
IS THE ABILITY MAYBE TO ADD NEW
LANES.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE AN ABILITY
FOR THOMAS VEHICLES -- TO GET
THEM OFF OF MAYBE THE MAJOR
THOROUGHFARES AND NOT INTERFERE
WITH GOODS MOVEMENT-O'DONNELL
OTHER ACTIVITIES.
WOULD THAT BE CONSIDERED A A
POLICY RECOMMENDATION WITH
REGARDS TO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
YEAH I KNOW THE THE HOLY BOB
THROUGH THE CHAIR AT THE MANTA
PRESIDENT -- THE THE THE THE THE
IDEA HERE IS THAT ALL OF THOSE
KINDS OF INNOVATIVE POLICY
OPTIONS WOULD BE ON THE TABLE.
AND THAT THE OFFICE THE OPR
WOULD BE LOOKING AT ALL THESE
VARIOUS OPTIONS.
AND WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WERE WERE REALLY BEING
THOUGHTFUL.
I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF
THE NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE.
WERE SOME THESE WONDERFUL BUT
BUT PROTECT THE DESTRUCTIVE
ELECTRIC SCOOTERS HAVE BEEN TO
SORT OF LAID OUT ON UNDER THE ON
THE CURBS -- AND YOU THERE THERE
ARE SOME CHALLENGES HERE WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WE WE ALLOW
THIS ROLL OUT IN A THOUGHTFUL
WAY AND I WAS REALLY BE
SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD BE
CONSIDERING.
GREAT SO THE THIS THIS -- RULING
BODY OR WHATEVER THIS GROUP THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD WOULD BE.
LOOKING FROM THIRTY THOUSAND
FEET ALL OPTIONS. FIVE CREATE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR BORCHERS MAY POSE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHR ABSOLUTE
EXCEPT THE QUESTION THE CITY.
CENTER BORDERS I ABSOLUTE
SUPPORT THIS -- DO YOU THINK
THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO EXCEL
OR THE TIME LINE -- TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SEEMS -- A LITTLE FAR
OUT. FOR A GROUP TO BE CONVENE
THE MORE TALK ABOUT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT EVENTS THAT ARE
OCCURRING RIGHT NOW -- AND I
DON'T.
I DON'T KNOW IF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO JUST TOO LATE.
WELL I I WILL SAY THE DATE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE TO COME
BACK TO US BY NO LATER THAN
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SO THEY WILL SO WE WITH OTHER
WERE CONVENING IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO YOUR WORK
STARTS NOW AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
GET BACK TO US BY THE FIRST OF
JANUARY. TWENTY TWENTY TWO ALL
OF THE THAT IS IT JUST A
FRIENDLY COMMENT I WOULD MAKE IT.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT I'LL
DEFINITELY BE SUPPORT IF THEY
YEAH NO IT'S A GOOD POINT AND
LET ME TAKE A LOOK AND AND TO
THE POSSIBILITIES EXPAND THE
TIME LINE.
I DON'T WANT TO TRIGGER TOO MANY
APPROPRIATIONS SAID THINGS.
BUT BUT BUT BUT IT BUT THE LET
LET'S LET'S SPEND THE TIME
LOOKING AT THAT BECAUSE I AGREE
WITH YOU IS NEEDS TO HAPPEN
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
ALLEN YOU MAY CLOSE THE
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS IN A
THOUGHTFUL.
IT WORK PLEASE REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE AND LET'S LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WE THAT WE ADDRESS THIS
THIS ENORMOUS CHANGE TO THE WAY
WE GET AROUND.
IN A WAY THAT'S AWFUL WELL
PLANNED.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECT FRESNO
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
I BATES AYE BELL.
I PURCHASED AYE BRADFORD I
CARILLO I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
I WAS SO.
I OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MORNING I'M MORE LOCK I AM A
REAL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
BOB CASKEY BY WIENER AYE WILK
[inaudible]
BY. THIRTY SEVEN OUR EYES THE
NOSE ONE THE MEASURE PASSES WE
ARE GOING TO GO BACK NOW
COLLEAGUES TO FILE.
ITEM. TO NINETEEN SENATOR
WINNERS MATTER MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE FREE SENATE BILL TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR WINNER AN
ACCOLADE CRIME.
SENATOR WIENER I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
SB TWENTY THREE CLARIFIES -- THE
FORCIBLE UNLAWFUL ENTRY OF A
VEHICLE INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE
PASSING OUT THE WINDOW.
IS IN FACT AUTO BURGLARY.
THIS NARROW CHANGE MEANS THAT
BREAKING A WINDOW OF A VEHICLE
BY USE OF IT AS A FORM OF
FORCIBLE ENTRY WITH THE INTENT
TO STEAL SOMETHING INSIDE THE
VEHICLE.
AMOUNTS TO AN AUTO BURGLARY.
UNDER CURRENT LAW -- THERE'S A
QUIRK OR FRANKLY A LOOPHOLE --
DIE IN ORDER TO PROVE IN AUTUMN
BURKE WHERE YOU HAVE TO PROVE.
THAT THE VEHICLE WAS LOCKED
WHICH IS OFTEN IMPOSSIBLE TO DO
FOR EXAMPLE IF WITH A RENTAL CAR
AT THE TOURIST HAS LEFT.
OR IF SOMEONE DOES NOT REMEMBER
WHETHER THEY LOCK THEIR CAR --
AND YOU HAVE TO PROVE THAT THE
DOOR WAS LOCKED EVEN IF YOU HAVE
ON VIDEO SOMEONE PASSING IN THE
WINDOW TO GET INTO THE CAR.
SO YOU CAN LOSE A PROSECUTION
HAVING SOMEONE ON VIDEO PASSING
THE WINDOW TO GET INTO THE CAR
IF YOU'RE UNABLE TO PROVE BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT THAT.
THE CAR WAS ALSO LAW.
SB TWENTY THREE WILL CLARIFY
THAT UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW --
THAT TYPE OF FORCIBLE UNLAWFUL
ENTRY INTO A CAR -- IS
TANTAMOUNT TO PROVING THAT THE
VEHICLE WAS LOCKED IN A
SUFFICIENT FOR THE CONVICTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE
IN SENATOR NIELSEN.
BETTER PRESENT LADIES GEM THE
SENATE I LOGGED IN SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE.
IT IS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT.
THAT SHOPPING SUCH AS BREAKING
INTO A CAR.
BUT CRIMINAL INTENT.
THIS IS SERIOUS.
BUSINESS NO BIG DEAL CRIME WE
SORT OF GOTTEN INTO THE HABIT.
TO DO WITH PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN THAT SUCH THINGS OF
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARY OR NO BIG
DEAL.
THEY ARE A BIG DEAL.
THE MOTHER WHO COMES HOME TO THE
DARKENED HOUSE IT'S A LIFE
SENTENCE.
THE BURGER SECOND DOESN'T DO
THAT MUCH TIME PARTICULARLY NOW
NOW HERE'S ANOTHER.
ONE WE'RE BREAKING INTO THE CAR.
IN THE OUTDOOR PROBABLY MOST OF
US HAVE HAD THAT VERY THING
HAPPENED TO US.
NO I'M SURE WE DID NOT COME OUT
OF THERE.
LEAVING.
THE MASS OF GLASS ALL OVER THE
GROUND AND IN OUR CAR SINGLE
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
WE JUST GOT THE WINDOW FIXED
[inaudible]
NO.
WE HAVE A LASTING SINCE THAT OUR
PERSONAL SECURITY HAS BEEN
INVADED.
AND THIS IS.
A SERIOUS CRIME.
LET'S MAKE SURE.
THAT'S PEOPLE PAY THE PRICE. FOR
BREAKING IN. TO YOUR CAR.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM.
TING IN HEARING ON SENATOR
WIENER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIMA.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SHE'S
DISCERNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
THERE IS OBJECTION MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD.
I'M SORRY CABALLERO.
HI CHANGE.
I DOT.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
HI HILL.
HI HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCKED.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
I STONE BY HAMBURG IA CASKEY BY
WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BRADFORD.
THE ROWS OF MITCHELL.
ICE THIRTY THREE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK.
TO A PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE
HAVE IN THE BACK OF THE HALL A
GROUP OF OUTSTANDING YOUNG
STUDENTS FROM PROMISE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN INGLEWOOD CALIFORNIA
CAN WE GIVE THEM A BIG WARM.
SENATE WELCOME WELCOME TO OUR
PLACE OF WORK.
WELCOME TO THE STATE SENATE.
AND WITH THAT COLLEAGUES WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM TO TWENTY FIVE
SENATOR NIELSEN [inaudible]
SB.
SEVENTY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ OFF FILE ITEM.
TO TWENTY FIVE SENATE BILL
SEVENTY BY SENATOR NELSON AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR NIELSEN.
MATTER PRESENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE THIS BILL RELATES. TO
HELPING PREVENT.
THESE CATACLYSMIC FIRES THAT WE
ARE.
STILL BE LADEN WITH NOW.
IT REQUIRES A ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION TO COULD LOOK
INCLUDE IN THIS WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
A DESCRIPTION OF HOW AND WHERE
THEY HAVE CONSIDERED UNDER
GROUNDING ELECTRICAL
DISTRIBUTION LINES.
IN AREAS OF THE HIGHEST WILDFIRE
[inaudible]
PROBABILITY.
SO MUCH OF THE DIFFICULTIES
INCLUDING THE CAMPFIRE.
WAS RESULT OF A LINE COMING DOWN.
THE LADY GENERAL LINES WILL COME
DOWN NO MATTER HOW THE CITY IS
ANY UTILITY IS AND MAINTAINING
[inaudible]
THOSE LINES.
THE CAMPFIRE WE WERE DEALING
WITH A FIFTY MILE AN HOUR WINDS.
CHANNEL THROUGH CANYONS THAT
INCREASED EVEN THE PHILOSOPHY IN
THE PRESSURE.
SO WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
BUT SIMPLY CONSIDERING UNDER
GROUNDING.
I BELIEVE IS IMPORTANT.
AND THE APPLICATION OF IT
WHATEVER'S APPROPRIATE.
AND MAKE ARGUMENTS.
ABOUT ITS EFFICACY AS WELL.
ALSO OPEN UP APPROPRIATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE IT WOULD CREATE
A WORKING GROUP. TO ASSIST IN
DIRECTING THE PROJECT.
IMPLEMENTATION.
MOST OF THESE FIRES IS OF NOTED
OR ABOVE GROUND.
THE ARE THE RESULT.
OF THE TRANSMISSION [inaudible]
WHATEVER BE [inaudible]
ABOVE GROUND [inaudible]
OR UNDERGROUND.
THESE INSULATED UNDERGROUND
LINES.
ARE NOT GOING TO INITIATE FIRES
IN THIS ACCUMULATED BRUSH.
IT IS A GREAT WAY FOR OUR
UTILITIES TO HARDEN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHEN WE CONSIDER THE COSTS OF
THIS?
IT MUST BE CONSIDERED.
AND I WOULD THIS IS WORKING
GROUP.
CONSIDER SUCH.
THE COSTS OF THE FIRES.
THE LIABILITY TO THE UTILITY
ITSELF.
THE COST TO THE COMMUNITY.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IN MANY CASES AS IS THE CAMP
CASE.
THE LIVES OF OUR CITIZENS.
NOT A MANDATE.
BUT IT IS.
THAT THEY MUST [inaudible]
EXAMINE [inaudible]
AND WAY.
THE UNDERGROUND OPTION.
I REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
APPRECIATE CENTER FROM TAME
COUNTY BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
UNDER GROUNDING IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF MITIGATING WILD
FIRE RISK AS ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMART BACKUP
POWER SYSTEMS MICRO GREASE.
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY INTEGRATION
AND OTHER OPTIONS THAT WE KNOW
THE UTILITIES ARE CONSIDERING
BUT WE THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
A CRITICAL PIECE TO GET THIS OUT
IN THE DAYLIGHT REALLY LET
COMMUNITIES KNOW.
THE UTILITIES ARE MAXIMIZING THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET THESE WIRES
UNDERGROUND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
NIELSEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
MY COLLEAGUES FOR OUR OWN SAFETY
THE NUMBER PROPERTY SAFETY I
REGION I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZE
DISCERNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR UMBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACCOLADE INTO
ELECTIONS SENATOR ON BURKE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
LAST YEAR MARKED THE FIRST TIME.
THE CALIFORNIA -- ENACTED
ENABLED SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION FOR STATEWIDE
ELECTION OF THE LAW.
THAT TIME REQUIRED THAT VOTERS
AND A COMPLETE A CONDITIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION.
AFFIDAVIT AND THEN CAST A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
THIS PROVISIONAL BALLOT WAS
TABULATED ONLY AFTER IT WAS
CHECKED AGAINST THE SO SECURITY
DATABASE AS WELL AS DMV RECORDS --
TO ENSURE THE VOTER HAD NOT
ALREADY RECEIVED THE BALLOT
ELSEWHERE.
IN MANY WAYS THE SYSTEM WORK
VERY WELL FOR INSTANCE OVER
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND SAME DAY
BALLOTS WERE CAST THE GENERAL
ELECTION ALONE.
THE SECTORS STATE REPORTS THERE
WERE NO REPORT INSTANCES OF
FRAUD ASSOCIATED WITH THEM
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE.
OF THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT THOSE
SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION --
AFFIDAVITS AS WELL AS
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS COULD ONLY
BE CASTED VOTE CENTERS OR AT FOR
EXAMPLE THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS
OFFICE WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT
SOME.
PLACE SOME PLACES IN CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILES
TO GET TO A LOCATION WHERE YOU
CAN REGISTER.
ON THAT SAME DAY I KNOW FROM MY
OWN EXPERIENCE SEEING THE ORANGE
COUNTY REGISTRAR VOTERS THAT
VOTERS ARE LINED UP FOR MANY
HOURS AFTER THE POLLS CLOSE IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE.
TO CAST THEIR BALLOTS AND
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT OF
FRANCHISE NOW WITH THIS BILL
WOULD SIMPLY DO IS IS IT WOULD
ALLOW. FOR SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION -- AT VOTE CENTERS
AS WELL AS POLLING PLACES IN
THOSE LOCATIONS WHICH CHOOSE NOT
TO HAVE.
VOTES CENTERS AS WELL AS THE PRE
EXISTING LAW AT THE REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS EACH COUNTY -- EITHER
TONIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR NIELSEN.
NOT A PRESENT LATER DOWN THE
SENATE TO I'M NOT HERE TO READ
DEBATE AN ISSUE THAT I
VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE.
AND I WILL NOT EVEN DEBATE THAT
SOME FOR WE HAVE NOT HAD
PROBLEMS.
BUT I WILL SAY UNEQUIVOCALLY I
AM CERTAIN THAT WE WILL HAVE
PROBLEMS.
OF ALL THE OTHER STATES AND I
UNDERSTAND HERE IN OUR ANALYSIS
THERE ARE.
SEVENTEEN THAT ALLOW SAME DAY
VOTING.
ONLY CALIFORNIA DOES NOT REQUIRE
PROOF OF IDENTITY [inaudible]
A RESIDENCY.
WERE THOSE PROVISIONS INCLUDED
IN THIS LEGISLATION.
THAT AS YOU SHOWED UP AT THE
POLLS YOU HAD TO HAVE A PROOF OF
IDENTITY AND THE PROOF OF
REGISTRATION WHERE YOU LEFT.
THEN I'D HAVE SOMETHING TO VOTE
FOR BUT SHORT OF THIS.
I STATE THAT THIS IS STILL
FRAUGHT WITH FRAUD.
AND ORIGINAL VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
UMBERG YOU MAY CLOSE -- THANK
YOU OF MEN PRESENT I AM NOT
FAMILIAR WITH SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION OR AT LEAST THE
DETAILS IN OTHER STATES WHICH
PERMITTED.
I TAKE YOU AT YOUR WORD --
CENTER NIELSEN THAT SEVENTEEN
STATES PROVIDE SAME DAY ROAD
VOTER REGISTRATION.
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA IN ORDER
TO SHOW AND TO DEMONSTRATE TO
ENSURE ALL OF US THAT THOSE
VOTES ARE CAST IS PROPERLY.
DONE BY CITIZENS THERE IS A
CHECK.
THE CHECK IS AGAINST THOSE COULD
BE DATABASE AS WELL AS THE DMV
DATABASE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PEOPLE ARE PROPERLY AND LEGALLY
ELIGIBLE TO CAST A VOTE -- I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
HI.
THE ROWS OF HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
BY.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TOM.
BY JACKSON BY JONES.
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO REAL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
HI BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
HI SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE BY WHAT OWSKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE.
AYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG TO
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY ONE SENATOR
WIENER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR WINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO HIV PREVENTION SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT ARE CALLING SIDE SP --
ONE FIFTY NINE IS A BILL TO
EXPAND ACCESS. TO TO VERY
POWERFUL HIV PREVENTION DRUGS
CRAP AND PAP CRAP IS PRE
EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS PAP IS POST
EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS.
RAP IS A ONCE DAILY PILL THAT
REDUCES RISK OF HIV BY ABOUT 99%
ALMOST ENTIRELY ELIMINATING THE
RISK OF HIV INFECTION.
HAPPY IS A TWENTY EIGHT DAY
COURSE THAT YOU TAKE IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO HIV -- TO TRY TO
PREVENT THE VIRUS FROM TAKING
HOLD IN YOUR BODY -- THESE DRUGS
ARE GAME CHANGERS IN OUR EFFORTS
TO REDUCE AND ULTIMATELY TO
ELIMINATE NEW HIV INFECTIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY -- WE HAVE
STRUGGLED IN INCREASING UPTAKE
OF THESE IMPORTANT TOOLS
PARTICULARLY -- CRAP -- AND
PARTICULARLY IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR -- WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
EXPAND ACCESS.
SB ONE FIFTY NINE WILL EXPAND
ACCESS IN TWO WAYS -- FIRST TO
AUTHORIZE PHARMACISTS WITHOUT A
PHYSICIAN'S.
PRESCRIPTION TO PROVIDE THE FULL
TWENTY EIGHT DAY COURSE OF PAP --
POST EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS AND
THE FIRST THIRTY DAYS OF CRAP.
AFTER THIRTY DAYS SOMEONE WILL
THEN HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE BLOOD WORK AND GO SEE A
POSITION TO CONTINUE.
BOB THIS WILL HELP GET PEOPLE
ACCESS EASIER AND GET PEOPLE
GOING MORE EASILY -- WE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH -- THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND
WITH THE HEALTH COMMITTEE ON
THIS BILL AND I THINK WE'VE COME
TO A GOOD STRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PROTECTING PEOPLE'S
HEALTH.
AND EXPANDING ACCESS THE OTHER
PIECE OF THIS BILL IS -- SP ONE
FIFTY NINE PROHIBITS BY
INSURANCE COMPANIES FROM
REQUIRING PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS
TO ACCESS PROP AND PAP.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO BASIS TO
HAVE A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AND
IS SIMPLY THE LAYS ACCESS --
THERE'VE BEEN PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BECOME HIV POSITIVE BECAUSE OF
THESE DELAYS -- AND IT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE -- SO COLLEAGUES WE
HAVE A BROAD COALITION BEHIND
THIS BILL OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS IT THE ODD BECAUSE
LGBT CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
STONE.
THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT -- I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY NINE
WHICH I THINK MAYBE ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT BILLS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ENTERTAINED THIS THE
SESSION.
THE BILL INCREASES ACCESSIBILITY
TO PREVENTIVE HEALTHCARE THE
FIGHT THE SPREAD OF HIV AND AIDS.
IN ADDITION IT REMOVES BARRIERS
FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS
SEEKING TIMELY ACCESS TO PASS.
BY ALLOWING PHARMACISTS TO
PROVIDE THE HIV PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS TO PREP.
AND POST EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS
PAP [inaudible] TWO PATIENTS.
IT'S NOT A MERE MYTH BUT A
SIMPLE FACT THAT INCREASING
ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE HEALTH CARE
GREATLY FIGHTS THE SPREAD.
OF HIV AND AIDS.
SO BASICALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS TWO THINGS.
IT ALLOWS FOR GREATER
ACCESSIBILITY FOR PATIENTS THAT
NEED THE ACUTE TREATMENT OF CRAP.
BY GOING TO ONE OF FIVE THOUSAND
PHARMACY IS A CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
AND TO IT STOPS THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS IS
SOMETIMES CAN DRAG ON FOR DAYS.
BUT IS VERY IMPORTANT IF THESE
DRUGS ARE GOING TO WORK THEY
HAVE TO BE TAKE TAKEN IN A VERY
TIMELY WAY.
THAT'S LESS THAN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS FOR THE DRUGS SIMPLY DO
NOT WORK.
WHEN I WAS WORKING FOR MY DOCTOR
PHARMACY DEGREE U. S. C.?
I ACTUALLY DID ROUNDS WITH
PHYSICIANS AT THE COUNTY USC
HOSPITAL.
WE OFTEN TOOK MANY THE SAME
CLASSES TOGETHER -- AT WITH
MEDICAL STUDENTS SUCH AS ANATOMY
HISTOLOGY PHYSIOLOGY
PHARMACOLOGY BY MEDICINAL
CHEMISTRY.
IT IS NOT A UNIQUE IDEA THE
PHARMACISTS ARE ABLE TO
ADMINISTER MEDICATION THE FACT
IS MOST OF YOU KNOW YOU CAN GET
IMMUNIZED TO JUST ABOUT.
ANY PHARMACY IN THE TATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT AS PHARMACISTS
THAT ARE SPECIALLY TRAINED. TO
DO SO.
AND WITH THAT WE OF INCREASE THE
THE HERD -- IMMUNIZATION RATE --
PROTECTING OUR OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WITH
THE PASSAGE OF SB FOUR NINETY
THREE WE CODIFIED INTO LAW.
THE PHARMACISTS ARE MODIFIED
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS THUS WE
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE.
IN THE DELIVERY OF HEALTH CARE
FOR PATIENTS.
AS I MENTIONED IS OVER FIVE
THOUSAND PHARMACIES AND CITY
CALIFORNIA AND MANY.
ESPECIALLY SOME OF THESE CHAIN
STORES ARE OPEN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY.
SO IF THERE IS A THE EMERGENT
NEED. FOR PRESS OR PAP.
A PATIENT CAN GET THOSE DRUGS --
EASILY.
AND IN A TIMELY WAY.
LET'S FACE IT. ONE DOESN'T
ALWAYS PLANNED ACTS OF PASSION.
SOMETIMES THINGS JUST HAPPEN.
BUT IF YOU NEED PROP OR PAT.
AND YOU NEED TO GO THROUGH A
DOCTOR TO GET IT TODAY.
ANY NEED TO GO TO THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS CHANCES
ARE.
YOU MAY NOT GET TO THE INFECTION
IN TIME WORD ACTION BECOMES.
AN ACTIVE INFECTION.
BEYOND SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
THE LAYS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THESE DRUGS WERE THEY JUST DON'T
WORK.
LET'S LEAVE IT UP TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH AND KNOW
THAT THEY WILL.
NEED TO GET MEDICATIONS TO
PREVENT.
THEIR HEALTH FROM DETERIORATING.
WE HAVE PROOF THE PHARMACIST CAN
TAKE ON MORE PROFESSIONAL ROLES
LIKE DESCRIBING AND GIVING
INNOVATIONS AND WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO EXPAND THE
PROFESSIONAL ROLES. TO PREVENT
MORE CASES OF AIDS.
WE NEED TO ELIMINATE AIDS JUST
LIKE WE ELIMINATED POLIO.
WE HAVE THE DRUGS AVAILABLE AND
THEY ARE SAFE AND THEY ARE
EFFECTIVE.
BUT SIMPLY PEOPLE JUST DON'T
HAVE ACCESS.
AS A SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO
MENTIONED THE UPTAKE OF THESE
DRUGS UNFORTUNATELY IS LOW MUCH
LOWER THAN WE WOULD LIKE AND
AGAIN IT GOES BACK TO
ACCESSIBILITY AND TIMELY
APPROVALS OF THESE DRUGS.
WITH THE APPROPRIATE PROTOCOLS
AN INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS OF COLOR.
WHERE WE SEE A HIGHER PERCENTAGE
AND PERFECT BROUGHT UNDER ITS OF
AIDS ATTRIBUTED TO THE FACT THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS DON'T KNOW?
THAT THESE PREVENTED OF DRUGS.
ARE READILY AVAILABLE.
WE COULD GREATLY REDUCE THE
MORBIDITY AND LONG TERM SENTENCE
OF PATIENTS THAT WILL COME DOWN
WITH THE AIDS VIRUS.
THIS BILL NOT ONLY COULD SAVE A
LIFE BUT COULD ALSO GIVE HOPE TO
THOSE WHO ARE RISK.
OF GETTING HIV AND AIDS.
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I WHOLLY SUPPORT SB ONE FIFTY
NINE AND KIRCHER AYE VOTE
SENATOR PAN.
I THANK YOU -- MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS UP FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO -- FOR CERTAINLY
ASSURE HIS GOAL OF TRYING TO
ELIMINATE HIV AND ALSO A SHARE
HIS GOAL OF INCREASING ACCESS.
TO THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT --
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO HELP BOTH LIMIT THE SPREAD
AND HOPEFULLY -- LIMIT -- OF WE
GET EXCEEDS ELIMINATION OF HIV
AND IN FACT -- I THINK IN MANY
WAYS I THINK MOST OF THE
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL IN FACT
I'VE HAD SOME EXCELLENT
CONVERSATIONS -- I A SUPPORT MAY
SUPPORT STRONGLY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT ICE -- THAT HE
IS TRYING TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
THESE MEDICATIONS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO DO --
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE
I'VE CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT.
HOW TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE CLOSE
THE LOOP AND BE SURE THAT IT IS
PEOPLE ARE SEEKING CARE?
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO GET -- THE
HIGH QUALITY CONFERENCE OF CARE
THEY NEED NOW I WILL SAY MY GOOD
FRIEND TO TO MACULA THAT YES
PHARMACISTS HAVE A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE.
AND IN FACT PHARMACIST CAN DO A
LOT IN FACT I HAVE NO OBJECTION
TO THE IDEA THAT PHARMACISTS ARE
GOING TO BE DISPENSING.
OF BOTH PAP WHICH WE KNOW HAS A
TIME LIMIT TIME FRAME IN WHICH
SOMEONE HE'S RECEIVED THE
MEDICATION SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
OR PERHAPS WHICH IS ACTUALLY A
MORE PREVENTIVE CARE --
TREATMENT SO IT'S TO PREVENT
GETTING INFECTED -- SO THERE'S A
LITTLE LESS TIME AGENCY THERE
BUT I'M FINE WITH PHARMACISTS
ADMINISTERING THAT MEDICATION
THE QUESTION THEN BECOMES IS
THAT BECAUSE AND I APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE THE ANTI
COMMITTEE -- AS WELL AS WELL AS
THE HEALTH ME THAT.
UNDER THE GUIDELINES OF COURSE --
THERE ARE SCREENING TESTS --
NAMELY RENAL SCREENING TESTS
THAT NEED TO BE CONDUCTED --
BECAUSE OF ATTENTIONAL SIDE
EFFECTS THAT MIGHT RESULT FROM
THE MEDICATION AND IT'S A FAIRLY
RARE BUT IT IT'S IT'S A
POSSIBILITY THE OTHER THING I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THOUGH IS IS
THAT ALSO -- PATIENTS WHO ARE
GETTING SCREEN WITH THIS TEST
EVEN IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM CAUSED BY THE MEDICATION
THEY COULD HAVE A PRE EXISTING.
CONDITION THAT MAYBE EARLY ON
THAT AS ONLY IDENTIFIED BY THAT
TEST.
AND IN THIS BILL THE PHARMACIST
WILL BE ADMINISTERING A
MEDICATION WHICH IS FINE I'M
FINE WITH THAT AND ALSO -- THEN
ALSO DOING THE SCREENING TEST.
AND THEN THE QUESTION IS WHO'S
REVIEWING THE SCREENING TEST
RESULTS THIS IS NOT MERELY A
MEDICATION LEVEL WHERE YOU GO
OUT F THE MEDICATION IS NOW AT
A SUFFICIENT DOSE OR NOT.
IT'S NOT AN UP AND DOWN TEST
THIS IS A SOMEWHAT MORE COMPLEX
AND SO IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
THEN THE ISSUE ECOMES WELL.
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
INTERPRETING TEST AND THEN
COMMUNICATING WITH THE PATIENT
HAS TO THE ROOT THOSE RESULTS --
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT IN THE
BILL AND DUE TO MENACE ARE TAKEN
THE BILL THAT FOR CRAP SO WE'RE
GONNA.
HAVE TO SIDE WHICH CAN TALK
ABOUT WHICH IS THE PREVENTIVE
PART THAT IN THAT TREATMENT THAT
THEY CAN ONLY GET ESSENTIALLY
ONE CYCLE ONE ONE ROUND OF
TREATMENTS AND AND WHICH CASE
THEY THEN NEED TO SEE -- WHAT
THEY COULD GO TO ANOTHER
PHARMACY -- BUT WHO WHO DOESN'T
COMMUTE YOUNG COMMUNICATE FAR
BUT IDEALLY THEY WOULD GO
IDEALLY SEEK A A PHYSICIAN OR
SOME OTHER -- PERSON -- OF HIS
DECISION A POSITION TEAM AND I
AND I THINK THAT -- BUT I MY
CONCERN IS IS IS THAT BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY FOR THE PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE -- FOR A
PRIMARY CARE TEAM TO HAVE A
PHYSICIAN NOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
GONNA GET A FOLLOW UP RATE THAT
THE LAB TESTS WILL GO TO THEM TO
GET INTERPRETED.
THIS BILL WILL TRY TO EXPAND
ACCESS AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT SO ONE OF THE THINGS I
SUGGESTED -- WAS IS THAT.
THE PHARMACIST SHOULD HAVE A
CLEVER PRACTICE AGREEMENT WITH A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
PHYSICIAN WHO ACTUALLY HAS
REALLY SHE'S BUT THE PHARMACIST
TO HELP.
THE FED BY IS THEM TO REVIEW THE
TASK TO DO ANYTHING THE
PHARMACIST HAS.
HAS QUESTIONS ABOUT IN FACT
AGAIN WE'RE NOT TELLING THE
PHARMACIST THAT THEY CAN'T JUST
DISPENSE THE MEDICATION BUT THEY
SHOULD HAVE SOMEONE TEY CAN GO
REFER TO THERE'S A QUESTION --
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SOME CONCERNS THAT THAT WOULD
MAKE IT THAT PHARMACISTS MAYBE
WON'T DO IT IF THEY HAVE TO GET
A CLOUT FACT THIS AGREEMENT.
AND THAT IT WAS ALSO SAID THAT
WELL PHYSICIANS WOULDN'T AGREE
TO DO THIS BECAUSE THE RISK
WOULD BE TOO HIGH.
ALTHOUGH I POINT OUT THAT OF THE
RISK IS TOO HIGH FOR POSITION TO
HAVE THIS AGREEMENT AND BY THE
WAY THERE'D BE NO LIMITATION ON
THE NUMBER PHARMACIST A
PHYSICIAN COULD HAVE THIS
AGREEMENT WITH -- THEN I WOULD
SAY THAT THE PHARMACIST
THEMSELVES IF THE PHYSICIANS
CANNOT GET THINK THE RISK IS TOO
HIGH I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT MEANS
FOR PHARMACISTS WHO DOESN'T HAVE
ANYONE.
THIS BACKING THEM UP.
SO I'M NOT ACTUALLY A STAND HERE
AND URGE ANYONE NOT TO VOTE FOR
THE BILL AND FORTY I CANNOT.
BUT I KNOW AND I I CERTAINLY
HAVE A LOT OF FAITH MY FRIEND
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I HOPE WE CAN
TRY TO WORK.
THIS ISSUE OUT BEFORE THE BILL
BILL ENDS UP ON THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK ARE SIGNED INTO LAW BECAUSE
I DO THINK THIS IS A CRITICAL
PART WE TALK ABOUT TEAM BASED
CARE.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT HOW DO WE
BUILD THE TEAM TO BE SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET.
HIGH QUALITY CARE SO WITH THAT I
AM FOR SHE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
VOTE FOR THE BILL -- TODAY BUT I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR BECAUSE I KNOW WE SHARE
THE SAME GOALS I KNOW HE SHARES
THAT GOAL -- AND THAT HOPEFULLY
WE CAN LAND THIS BILL IN A PLACE
THAT -- WILL BE SURE AND I KNOW
THAT'S HIS DESIRE TO THAT OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET HIGH
QUALITY CARE AND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE THANK
YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
SENATOR GLAZER.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
AT THIS THOUGHTFUL DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR TODAY -- WAS REFLECTIVE OF
THE THE DEEP.
CONSIDERATION AT THIS MEASURE
HAD AND CERTAINLY IN FRONT OF
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTED I'M SURE THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE.
I IN THAT ACT BROAD
CONSULTATIONS WERE UNDERTAKING
WITH THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY --
AND WITH OTHERS ABOUT -- THIS
ISSUE THAT THE SENATOR FROM
SINCE SAN FRANCISCO SO PROPERLY
BROUGHT FORWARD TO US.
AND AND TWO CONCLUSIONS THAT I
SHARE WITH YOU. ONE IS THAT.
IN A PERFECT WORLD -- THIS TYPE
OF HEALTH CARE WOULD BE DIRECTED
BY A PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN.
THAT -- FOLKS WOULD HAVE.
THAT INITIATE THAT CONTACT
BEFORE PROBLEM OCCURS.
I CERTAINLY BE ABLE.
TO REACH THAT PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS AFTER -- THAT THEIR BELIEF
THAT A PROBLEM HAS OCCURRED --
BUT THE PRACTICAL NATURE OF THIS
IS THAT -- THE PERFECT CAN'T BE
THE ENEMY OF THE GOOD -- THAT
WAS CAN'T CONCLUSION NUMBER.
ONE ISSUE NUMBER TWO WAS THAT --
WE CAREFULLY EXAMINED.
THE GUIDELINES FROM THE CENTER
FOR DISEASE CONTROL IN REGARD TO
THESE -- DOSAGES THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED FOR PREP AND FOR PAT.
AND THE CONCLUSION THAT -- I
CERTAINLY CAME TO I THINK OUR
OUR COMMITTEE CAME -- TO IS THAT.
THE HEALTH CARE CONSEQUENCES OF
ADMINISTERING ONE DOES. TWENTY
EIGHT TO THIRTY DAYS -- WAS
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY LOW -- TO
THAT INDIVIDUAL AND WHILE FOLLOW
UP CARE IS RECOMMENDED AND AND
IT'S CERTAINLY -- SHOULD BE DONE.
THAT AGAIN THE CONSEQUENCES TO
THAT INDIVIDUAL -- IF IT WERE
NOT TO OCCUR WERE INCREDIBLY
SMALL.
AND SO THE CHOICE THAT I BELIEVE
ARE COMMITTEE MADE -- WAS IT
THIS -- SINGLE DOSE FOR PREP AND
FOR PAT -- STRUCK THE RIGHT
CHORD FOR A PRAGMATIC WAY TO
DEAL WITH -- A SERIOUS HEALTH
CARE CONSEQUENCE WHICH CITY IS A
GOOD AUTHOR OF SAN FRANCISCO IS
CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED.
AND WITH THAT NUMBERS I PRAISE
VISIT THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR LEADING ON THIS
ISSUE AND I ENCOURAGE AND I'VE
OF FURTHER DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
SENATOR STONE BETTER PRESIDENT
JUST REAL FAST I JUST WANT --TO
LET MY COLLEAGUES KNOW THAT --
WHEN WE WENT OF WHEN I WENT TO
PHARMACY SCHOOL AND?
IN PHARMACY SCHOOLS TODAY WE'RE
TALK ABOUT THE INTERPRETATION OF
OF LAB RESULTS AND WE CAN ORDER
TESTS.
AND WE CERTAINLY CAN IT IN IN
THIS CASE IF ORDERING OF A BLOOD
TEST THAT CAN.
HELP IDENTIFY WHETHER NOT
SOMEBODY'S HAVING A SIDE EFFECT
NAMELY TO THE KIDNEYS WITH
RESPECT TO OF ONE OF THESE DRUGS.
AND SECONDLY I DON'T WANT YOU TO
THINK THAT.
WERE YOU KNOW -- INVENTING A NEW.
A NEW PROGRAM HERE THERE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST IN
WASHINGTON AND THE STATE OF NEW
YORK.
THAT ALLOW.
FOR EITHER.
CRAP OR HAPPY.
IN SOME CASES ONE BUT NOT THE
OTHER IN THESE TWO STATES SO
THEY SAW THE WISDOM IN THESE TWO
STATES TO REDUCE THE INCIDENCE
OF HIV AIDS.
AND I HOPE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THE SAME HERE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
APPRECIATE THE INTELLIGENT AND
THOUGHTFUL DEBATE ABOUT THIS AND
I'VE ENJOYED MY CONVERSATIONS
WITH BOTH.
THE CENTER FOR MARANDA AND THE
CENTER SACRAMENTO HE'S A CENTER
FROM TO MACULA HAS BEEN A GROUP
RATE PARTNER IN THIS BILL.
ON A TO BE CLEAR -- THE RISK OF
RENAL PROBLEMS FROM -- THESE
MEDICATIONS IS VERY VERY LOW I
THINK EVERYONE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
IT DOES HAPPEN VERY LOW AS WE
HEARD -- FROM A PHYSICIAN WHO
TESTIFIED IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WHO IS PROBABLY THE
FOREMOST PHYSICIAN EXPR ON PROP
IMPACT IN THE WORLD -- THAT WHEN
THEY DO RARELY HAPPEN IT'S
USUALLY AFTER THREE OR FOUR
MONTHS IT DOESN'T REALLY HAPPEN
IN THOSE FIRST THIRTY DAYS -- SO
THE RISK HERE IS SO INTERNAL
TOUGH INFINITESIMALLY LOW IN
TERMS OF ADVERSE HEALTH -- AL
COME.
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE WILL PREVENT
HIV INFECTIONS -- AND THE ONE
FINAL THING I WANT TO KNOW IN
TERMS OF THE SUGGESTION OF A
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE IN REAL
LIFE COURSE -- AS IT EXPRESSES
CENTER IN SACRAMENTO I
APPRECIATE THAT IDEA -- WE KNOW
FROM EXPERIENCE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IT DOESN'T WORK
EITHER PHYSICIANS OR PHARMACIST
LIKE ENTERING INTO THESE
AGREEMENTS.
AND WHEN THE LEGISLATURE FIRST
AUTHORIZED PHARMACISTS TO
PROVIDE VACCINES BACK IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES A
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE AGREEMENT
WAS REQUIRED AND NOT LAW.
IT WAS A FAILURE VERY FEW
PHARMACISTS AND PHYSICIANS ADDED
INTO THOSE THOSE AGREEMENTS AND
WITHIN THE LAST TEN YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE DELETED THAT
REQUIREMENT FROM THE LAW -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
HI GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY AMBER.
BY WORK OWSKI BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARE TO THAT A BY [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
PAN.
VICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY THREE SENATOR
MORE LOCK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MORE LOCK AN ACT
RELATING TO JUDGES RETIREMENT
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
SENATOR MORE LAW THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT -- COLLEAGUES SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGES.
APPOINTED OR ELECTED AFTER
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR ARE IN A
COMBINED DEFINED BENEFIT DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION RETIREMENT PLAN.
WHICH OF KNOWN AS JUDICIAL
RETIREMENT SYSTEM TO OUR J.
ARREST.
TO IT HAS A UNIQUE STRUCTURE WE
CALL IT CLIF VESTING MAY HAVE
TO STAY A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
BEFORE THEY CAN BENEFIT FROM A
DEFINED BENEFIT.
RETIREMENT [inaudible]
SO IF.
THAT JUDGE HAPPENS TO BECOME ILL
OR HAVE.
FAMILY ISSUES IN CANNOT MEET THE
TWENTY YEAR REQUIREMENT.
THEN -- THEY DO NOT GET THE FULL
BENEFIT OF THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
AND THE FORM OF A DEFINED
BENEFIT -- RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
SO CONSEQUENTLY SOME OF THESE
JUDGES WILL WORK THROUGH CHEMO
OR WHATEVER IT'LL TAKE TO TRY
AND MAKE THE PERIOD --
SUCCESSFULLY MAYBE NOT BUTTHEY
WILL TRY BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
PROVIDE.
RETIREMENT BENEFIT FOR THEIR
SPOUSES MORE OF ONCE.
SO SB ONE EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES A
SIMPLE DEFERRAL MECHANISM TO
DELAY THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN THE
BENEFITS.
WITHOUT RISKING THE LOSS -- THE
COST IS BEEN ESTIMATED BY
CALPERS TO BE ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE HAVE A
BUDGET REQUESTS.
SUBMITTED CONCURRENTLY THE PAPER
THAT UP FRONT.
THIS IS A REPEAT OF LAST YEAR'S
BILL WHICH WE DID WAS SB SIX
FIFTY SIX THE RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT ON THIS FLOOR -- WITH
ONLY ONE MEMBER -- NOT VOTING
WHO WAS ABSENT.
GOVERNOR BROWN TO VETO THAT BILL
SB SIX FIFTY SIX ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE INITIATIVE
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
RETROACTIVELY WHICH WAS NOT THE
CASE SO WE'RE BRINGING THE BILL
BACK.
WE'VE HAD GOOD SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE.
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY FOUR SENATOR MONNING.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY NINE A
SENATOR MINING AN ACT RELATING
TO MILITARY BASE RE USE SENATOR
MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
SINCE ITS ESTABLISHMENT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN THE FORT ORD
MILITARY BASE HAS BEEN AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE MONTEREY
BAY REGIONS ECONOMY. FOR AN
NEEDS TO ADDITIONAL YEARS THE
FORT ORD REDUCE THE THORNY TO
ALLOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
IMPLEMENT ADEQUATE FUNDING
MECHANISMS TO SUPPORT PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED.
IN THE FOR A TRANSITION PLAN
WHICH IS CURRENTLY BEING
IMPLEMENTED.
AS WELL TO ENSURE CONTRACTS THAT
ARESTAB WISHED IN THE
TRANSITION PLAN IMPLEMENTING
AGREEMENTS.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF FOR A HAVE
ADEQUATE FUNDING MECHANISMS TO
ACHIEVE THE REGIONAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLAN THAT WAS
PROMISED WHEN THE AUTHORITY WAS
ESTABLISHED.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORNING DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE JOURNEY OBJECTIONS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SING IN HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR
HERTZBERG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TO A FIVE A SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS SENATOR HURTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT TO BRIEFLY EXISTING
LAW REQUIRES OF FACILITIES
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES TO OBTAIN
INDUSTRIAL GENERAL PERMITS TO
COMPLY WITH THE NATIONAL
POLLUTANT DISCHARGE.
ELIMINATION SYSTEM CALLED AN
NPDES PERMIT.
THIS MEASURE WHAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN ESSENCE IS THAT A
NUMBER OF OF ENTITIES OUT THERE
AS MANY AS 80% ARE NOT LICENSED
TO THE PEOPLE THAT -- LICENSE
GET CHARGE FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE NOT LICENCES TO WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE CREATING A SELF
REGISTRATION WHERE WHEN YOU
APPLY FOR A BUSINESS LICENSE YOU
GOT TO PUT THE INFORMATION IN
THE FORM.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION IS FOR ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
BELL.
I BRIDGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
I DOT.
AYE THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I'M REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY STONE HI AMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI. FOR JUST.
BY [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I WILK AYE AYES THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY NINE SENATOR
HERTZBERG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE.
THREE THE BILL TO THIRTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG ACT WILLING
TO STATE GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT OF THE SIXTY SEVEN
MORE THAN SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
AMERICAN COLLEGE GRADUATES IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ONLY FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
RECEIVE STEM RELATED DEGREES.
ECONOMIC OUR ECONOMIC
PROJECTIONS UP POINT TO A NEED
OF OVER A MILLION STEM
PROFESSIONALS SPREADING
AWARENESS UNDERSTANDING OF STEM
ADVANCEMENTS IS CRITICAL IN
PREPARING CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIANS FOR OF ALL AGES FOR
TECHNOLOGICALLY INTENSIVE FUTURE
BY THIS MEASURE CREATES STAB
WISHES THE POSITION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAUREATE FOR SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS TO BE APPOINTED.
BY THE GOVERNOR FOR TWO YEAR
TERM MASS RELIABLE.
BAY DOOR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
IS FOR ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO FORTY
SENATOR BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY FIVE A
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
ENERGY SENATOR BRADFORD THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB TWO FIVE
FIVE EXPANDS WHAT IS BETTER
KNOWN AS CHEN ORDER ONE FIFTY
SIX OUR SUPPLIER DIVERSITY.
AS IT RELATES TO UTILITIES
THIRTY YEARS AGO WHEN MORE
INTRODUCED THE MEASURE BECAUSE
SHE HAD FOUND OUT THAT --
UTILITIES WERE SPENDING LESS
THAN A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD WOMEN ALL MINORITY OWNED A
DISABLED VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES TODAY.
I IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT
SPANNED EXCEEDED TEN BILLION
DOLLARS BUT OUR CONCERN IS WITH
THE CHANGING ELECTRIC A MARKET --
NOW WITH THE ESPY'S IN CCA'S
THEY TOO SHOULD HERE.
TOO IN ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX OF
THIS MEASURE INCLUDES ALL THE
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES AND
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE NOW SERVING
OUR ELECTRIC GRID AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION IS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG TO FILE ITEM
TO FORTY ONE SENATOR HERTZBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 258% HERTZBERG AN
ACT RULING TO HOMELESS SHELTERS
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT IN CALIFORNIA AS WE
HAVE HEARD MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT
THIS FLOOR ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
THERE ARE AS MANY AS A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WE SEE THAT IN MANY PLACES SHE
SHELTERS REMAIN WITH WITH A
SPACE ON BEDS AVAILABLE TO FOLKS
AND WHAT WE'RE LEARNING IS IN
LOS ANGELES RHYME FROM BETWEEN
TEN AND 15% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSESS
HAVE PETS.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE SERVICES FOR
THEIR PETS THEY WILL NOT COME IN
AND ACCEPT THE SERVICES THEY
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE PET THEIR
PETS THEY PROVIDED IMPORTANT.
A DIMENSION TO THEIR LIVES AND
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE IS TO
CREATE A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
GRANT PROGRAM.
IT WAS THROUGH THE VARIOUS
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA ON TO
DEAL WITH BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEECHES RECALLED I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DOT.
HI DORADO.
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible]
HUESO.
I OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
OUR COUNTY I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible] FOR
JUST [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
STONE.
HI.
I IS.
THIRTY SIX ICE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ALONG TO FILE ITEM TO
FORTY THREE SENATOR LEYVA.
EXCUSE ME. TO TWO FORTY THREE
TWO FORTY TWO I'M SORRY ARE WE
ARE GOING TO GO TO TWO FORTY TWO
FIVE MY BAD.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THIS IS FILE
ITEM. TO SIXTY FIVE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 265% HERTZBERG AND
ACTUALLY DO PEOPLE MILLS AND
CLING THERE'S THREATS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
COUPLE YEARS AGO I DID THE BILL
ON THIS FLOOR ON LUNCH SHAMING.
WE LEARNED ABOUT THROUGH THIS
PROCESS THAT SOME KIDS WHO DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY WHEN THEY GO IN
TO GET A LUNCH TO GET THEIR
HANDS STAMP THEY GET A HALF
CHEESE SANDWICHES AND FOUR
OUNCES OF JUICE.
THEY GET THE TRAY PULLED OUT IN
FRONT OF A MEASURE PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY BOTH OUSES GOVERNOR
SIGNED IT THOUGHT IT WAS OVER.
STILL THERE'S PROCESS IS STILL
THERE SCHOOL DISTRICT TRYING TO
GET AROUND THIS I'M AND WE'RE
CLOSING THE LOOP WITH RESPECT TO
THIS MEASURE ON LUNCH SHAMING I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM MISTER ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THEREANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ON THE URGENCY EXCUSE ME PRICE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY ICE THIRTY SEVEN THOSE
HERE ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES.
AND NOW WE WILL GO TO SENATOR
LEYVA ON FILE ITEM.
TWO FORTY THREE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR LEYVA AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SENATOR LEYVA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
SB 266% PROTECTS THE PROMISED
AND PAID FOR RETIREMENT BENEFITS
OF CALPERS MEMBERS BY MAKING
SURE THAT ANY COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN COMPENSATION COUNTED
TOWARDS RETIREMENT CANNOT BE
TAKEN FROM A RETIREE.
BECAUSE IT INCORRECTLY REPORTED
INFORMATION BY THEIR EMPLOYERS.
THIS MAJOR RESPONSE TO CASES IN
WHICH PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION
OF RETIRED EMPLOYEES IS RECTOR
RETROACTIVELY DEAN.
DISALLOWED BY CALPERS IN THESE
INSTANCES THE RETIRED EMPLOYEES
ARE FORCED TO PAY BACK THE TOTAL
OVERPAID AMOUNT AND SUFFER
PERMANENT REDUCTIONS. TO THEIR
PENSIONS MANY RETIREES RELY ON
FIXED INCOMES AND SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE UNEXPECTED
CUTS TO THEIR BENEFITS BECAUSE
OF REPORTING ERRORS. TO NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN.
SB TWO SIXTY SIX GIVES RETIREES
PEACE OF MIND FROM BEING FORCED
TO PAY MONEY BACK OR HAVE
REDUCTIONS IN THEIR PENSION
BECAUSE OF ACCOUNTING OR
REPORTING ERRORS.
SB TWO SIXTY SIX COMPELS CALPERS
AND EMPLOYERS TO WORK TOGETHER
TO PROTECT RETIREE BENEFITS AND
PREVENT THESE INSTANCES FROM
EVER OCCURRING IN THE FIRST
PLACE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THIRTY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHANGE.
I DODD.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I LIKE OWSKI I WIENER
[inaudible]
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
VICE THIRTY KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG NOW
TO FILE ITEM TO FORTY FOUR
SENATOR BELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR BILL AND THEY'RE GOING
TO SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
SENATOR BILL BAD PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF THIS BILL CREATES --
SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOR PERSONS
ON PAROLE PROGRAM TO BETTER
SERVES INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS FACING
HOMELESSNESS -- SUPPORTER
HOUSING IS AN EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTION PROGRAM PROVEN TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE TEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE ON PAROLE
WHO EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS ARE
SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY. TO
RESERVE A THAN THOSE THAT OUR
HOUSE.
SO WE KIND OF FIGURED OUT WHAT
WE NEED TO DO HERE.
LEGISLATURE THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZED A STRONG LINK BETWEEN
INCARCERATION ON HOMELESSNESS
AND ESTABLISH THE INTEGRATED
SERVICESWERE MENTALLY ILL
PAROLEES PROGRAM.
DURING THE BUDGET IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT HOWEVER THE
PROGRAM IS NOW NOT IN LINE WITH
THE LEGISLATORS INTENT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
CURRENTLY USES.
THE THE PROGRAM FUNDS TO PAY FOR
A 100% OF THE COST OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT.
INSTEAD OF IN ROWING THEM IN
MEDI CAL.
WHERE THERE IT CAN DRAW DOWN OF
FEDERAL MATCH OF 5290%?
AND A UCLA STUDY -- OF THE TWO
YEARS AGO.
FOUND THAT THIS PROGRAM ACTUALLY
FAILS TO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
SO THIS BILL WILL CHANGE THE
PROGRAM AN ASSET -- THE FUNDS BE
CHANGE SHOULD RE DIRECTED
TOWARDS THE PROGRAM.
WHICH IS SUCCESSFULLY MODELED
AFTER OTHER PROGRAMS.
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO BETTER
SERVE THE SAME POPULATION.
AND REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND
PROVIDE HOUSING SUPPORT HOUSING.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS SURE
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ALONG TO FILE ITEM TO
FORTY FIVE SENATOR WIENER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY FIVE A
SENATOR WINNER ENACT WILLING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES SENATOR
WIENER.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- SB -- TWO EIGHTY
FIVE WILL INCREASE -- CAL PRESS
IN ROMAN AND ACCESSIBILITY TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS -- BY
CREATING A STATE COUNTY
PARTNERSHIP TO SIR CLEARING
ACCOUNTABLE STATEWIDE ENROLLMENT
GOALS -- DIVIDE SYMBOL AND
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ENROLLMENT
FOR ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS.
AND TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO THE
CALPERS ENROLLMENT PROCESS -- IT
WILL SET AMBITIOUS GOALS -- TO
RALEIGH 75% OF THE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE SSI RECIPIENTS -- AND
ULTIMATELY TO GET OVERALL
ENROLLMENT IN CALIFORNIA UP 295%
FOR EACH COUNTY -- WE ARE --
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE LOWEST
PERFORMING STATES IN TERMS OF
ENROLLING PEOPLE -- IN
CALIFORNIA'S.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE FOOD BENEFITS WHICH
ARE LARGELY PAID.
FOR BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
AND THERE ARE VARIOUS REASONS
WHY ARE ALL TAKEN SO LOW -- THE
DAM ROMAN PROCESS IS FRANKLY
RIDICULOUS SO TIMES IN TERMS OF
WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO GO THROUGH --
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A VERY
FRAGMENTED SYSTEM WHICH EACH
WITH EACH OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HAVING ITS OWN PROCESS
THAT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
COMPLICATED WHEN PEOPLE.
MOVE AROUND WE'VE BEEN TRYING
FOR YEARS TO GET OUR COUNTIES TO
INCREASE THE UPTAKE FOR CAL
FRESH -- IT HASN'T BEEN GOING
LIKE IT SHOULD GO AND IT'S TIME
TO SET CLEAR STANDARDS FOR THE
PERCENTAGE THAT THEY NEED TO
ACHIEVE AND IT'S TIME TO BREAK
DOWN THESE BARRIERS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER DEBATER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
ALAN A QUESTION FOR THE OTHER.
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION.
HAPPY TO MOUNT A PREFERENCE YOU
MAY PROCEED SENATORS WANTED US
TO SENATOR IF IT'S DISCONCERTING
FOR HIM TO BE PRESENTING AN
IMPORTANT BILL.
WITH SO LITTLE CONTROVERSY.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH.
FOR THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA MONICA I HAVE THE
PHOTOS TO PROVE IT THAT I THINK
ALL OF MY BILLS TODAY HAVE HOUSE
WITH OVER THIRTY VOTES ARE
ALMOST ALL OF THEM -- SO I AM
HAPPY TO HAVE A LOT OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A BROAD
SUPPORT FOR A LEGISLATION I
APPRECIATE THE COMPLIMENT.
WITH THAT I ASSUME THAT YOU'RE
CLOSE.
I ASKED FOR AN ITEM THAT I WAS
GOING TO SEE IF IT IF THERE WAS
ANY OBJECTION SUCH TO DO YOU
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL I WON'T.
I WON'T SUCCUMB TO THE
TEMPTATION IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NON ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO FORTY
SEVEN SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ECHOING THE
CIVIL LAW.
SENATOR HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I'M BACK.
WITH BAIL MADAM PRESIDENT --
TIME BACK WITH BAIL -- IN THE
SIMPLEST TERMS WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THIS BAIL AND
IMMIGRATION CONSUMER PROTECTION
ACT.
IS TO APPLY TO THE SURE IT
COMPANIES THE SAME KIND OF
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS OF THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
THAT ARE APPLIED IN SO MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES YOU BUY A CAR.
YOU HAVE AN ABILITY THERE
CERTAIN DISCLOSURES THAT A
REQUIREMENT YOU BUY A HOUSE YOU
GET A CREDIT CARD.
IN THE IN IN WE HAVE SEEN STORY
AFTER STORY IN THE BAIL SPACE
WHICH IN IMMIGRATION BOND OR A
BAIL BOND WITH THOSE PROTECTIONS
ARE NOT AFFORDED WE EXTEND THOSE
PROTECTIONS IN THIS MEASURE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE. EIGHT OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NON ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TO FORTY NINE
SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER AND ACT
REALLY CHILD SUPPORT SENATOR
SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SB THREE THREE SEVEN
WOULD ALLOW FAMILIES.
ON CAL WORKS RATHER BENEFITS TO
RECEIVE ONE HUNDRED OF CHILD
SUPPORT ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS OF
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS FOR ONE
CHILD AND TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR TWO OR MORE CHILDREN WHICH
ALIGNS.
WITH THE FEDERAL LAW IN REGARDS
TO INCOME DISREGARD. FOR SUCH
FAMILIES AND THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION THAT I AM AWARE OF
AND I ASKED FOR A VOTE.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
TURNING OBJECTION THE
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NON ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ALONG TO FILE ITEM
TWO FIFTY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AQUINNAH
BUSINESS.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY AGAIN
I RISE TO PRESENT A MEASURE TO
SAFEGUARD CONSUMERS THIS TIME
FROM COUNTERFEIT ONLINE TICKET
PRACTICING.
TICKET SCALPERS OFTEN USED AS A
WAY TO OUTSIDE OF GAMES AS SOME
PEOPLE HERE MAY KNOW I'M NOT
REALLY A BIG.
SPORTS PERSON BUT I'M TOLD THAT
THAT'S THE CASE SELLING OVER
PRICED TICKETS AND COULD NOW THE
SKIES -- HIM OR HERSELF THEIR
BUSINESSES WITH CREDIBLE VENDORS
ONLINE THESE COMPANIES BASICALLY
USE THE NAME OF THE VENUE OR THE
NAME OF THE TEAM AND DON'T
REALLY TELL THE TRUTH.
THIS BASICALLY PROTECTS FOLKS IN
THAT REGARD LAST YEAR I VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTIONS SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
SENATOR MCGUIRE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE UP.
YOUR ITEMS PASS ON FILE.
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
TWO FIFTY SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
FIFTY YEARS AGO AFTER THE CIVIL
UNREST IN WANTS THERE WAS A QUé
A REPORT COMMISSIONED THAT
STATED.
SOUTH LAS SANDERS EXPERIENCED
LITTLE ECONOMIC PROGRESS SINCE
THAT DEVASTATING ON CIVIL UNREST
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND WE FIND
OURSELVES NOW A HALF CENTURY
LATER AND LOOKING OUT TO GET OUT
OF SCHOOL PERFORMANCES AND
SCREWS IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
COMPARED TO THE MOST OF FLOYD
NEIGHBORHOODS AND LOS ANGELES
AND THAT'S THIS DISPARITY STILL
EXISTS TODAY FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY AND I THINK WE
ALL AGREE THAT'S TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE THIS MEASURE I SP
FOUR TO SIX JUST EXPANDS.
ACADEMIC AND LEADERSHIP SKILLS
OF HIGH SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND SELF Là
SENATORS AREA. TO THE FORMATION
OF THE DEBATE TIMELY FELLOWS
PROGRAM IN PUBLIC POLICY AND
SOCIAL ENTREPRENEURSHIP IT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
SKILLS TO INCREASE THEIR
COMPETITIVE IN.
THE TO EVENTUALLY BOLSTER THEIR
COLLEGE ENROLLMENT AND INTO THE
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM --
THIS YEAR ANY SOCIETY REQUIRES A
GOOD EDUCATION AND THIS ONLY
HELPS IS THERE IN A RESPECT OUT
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEC SEEING AND HEARING ON MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED.
HI BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON AYE JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
POWER CASKEY BY WIENER.
BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS [inaudible]
BASIS [inaudible]
ATKINS BY [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
WILK AYE.
ICE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR PAN WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO FILE ITEM.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY EIGHT A
SENATOR PAN ECHOING THE PUBLIC
PEOPLE HEALTH.
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS --
CALIFORNIA'S IN THIS IS IN THE
MIDST OF IT YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS DEPRESSION SYMPTOMS ARE
AT AN ALL TIME HIGH FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ACCORDING TO THE
US DEPARTMENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NEARLY ONE IN.
THREE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS SURVEYED FEELING.
REPORTED FEELING SAD HOPELESS
ALMOST EVERY DAY FOR TWO OR MORE
WEEKS IN A ROW NEARLY ONE IN
FIVE REPORT THEY HAVE SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED TEMPTING SUICIDE.
NOW TEACHERS IN OUR SCHOOL STAFF
FROM THE FRONT LINES OF THESE
CRISES AND AS SUCH SHOULD BE
TRAINED TO HELP IDENTIFY AND
ASSIST STUDENTS WHO ARE
SUFFERING.
RESEARCH SAYS SHOWS THAT THE
SOONER PEOPLE CAN GET HELP FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
CONCERNS THE MORE LIKELY THEY
ARE TO HAVE POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE TO CALIFORNIA THE PART
OF EDUCATION TO IDENTIFY AN
EVIDENCE BASED TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
THE TRAIN CLASSIFIED AND
CERTIFICATED STAFF ON YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID.
SUBJECT APPROPRIATIONS CITY
REQUIRED TO DISSEMINATE THE
SELECTIVE TRAINING TO ELEAZAR NO
COST AND FURTHER ALL ELEAZAR BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE BE REQUIRED
TO CERTIFY TO CD EAT AT LEAST
10%.
A CLASSIFIED IN TEMPERATURE OF
CERTIFICATED STAFF OR TO USE
CLASSIFIED OR TWO CERTIFICATES
STAFF WHICHEVER IS GREATER HAVE
OBTAINED THE TRAINING
[inaudible]
THAT.
TRAININGS NEED TO INCREASE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY LEVEL CAPACITY
THIS IS SPONSORED BY COALITION
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATES AS A
FOUR BY PARENTS AND TEACHERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES OUR
FINAL BILL FOR THE DAY SENATOR
WHITE COUNTY WE WILL GIVE YOU
THE HONORS FILE ITEM.
TWO FIFTY NINE MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FOR
THIRTY BY SENATOR AYE CASKEY AN
ACT GOING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT.
SENATOR Y. CASKEY MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS A SUPPORT
SUPPORT MATTER THIS ISTHE NINE
JUDGES BILL IT CRACKS IN THE
NOMINEE THAT OCCURRED.
NGUYEN IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THEY COULD TAKE YOUR SEATS TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN HERE TONIGHT.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK -- TO THE TWO ITEMS THAT
ARE ON CALL WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE WILL
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY THREE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BELL.
BY POR JESS [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
BY CHAIN.
I GROWTH [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
BY MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PLEASE SIR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY THREE COLLEAGUES.
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
MORRELL.
VICE THIRTY FIVE NOSE ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES IN THE FINAL ITEM.
ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE LEAVE THE
CALL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
NUMBER GUY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME ALLEN [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO NO.
ICE TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEND THE
MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
WE'RE AT MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF LIKE TO MOVE FILE
ITEM TO ELEVEN SCA THREE AND
FILE ITEM TO TWELVE SCA FIVE TO
THE INACTIVE FILE PLEASE SO
NOTED [inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO MOVE
MY BILL SB FOUR THREE FOUR FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX TO THE
INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA
THERE WILL BE THE ORDER.
ANY OTHER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MADAM.
PRO TEM.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
LET ME JUST -- CONCLUDE THE DAY
WITH MY YET AGAIN MY INCREDIBLE
THANKS TO ALL OF YOU.
FOR WORKING SO HARD TO GET
THROUGH SIXTY SENATE ITEMS TODAY --
THAT IS GOOD WORK ON THE PART OF
OUR THE SENATE AND I WANT TO
THANK THE FLOOR TEAMS OF BOTH
THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
FOR HELPING US OVE SO
EFFICIENTLY TODAY I WANT TO
THANK THE PRESIDING OFFICER --
WHO RAN A VERY GOOD AND LONG DAY?
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE ITEMS
REMAINING -- FOR THIS NEXT WEEK
AND A HALF.
ARE -- TWO WEEKS I SHOULD SAY
OUT LET'S NOT GET OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC TOO SOON -- IT AND
NOTHING LIKE THE LAST MINUTE IN
WHICH WE TAKE THE LAST MINUTE TO
GET EVERYTHING DONE.
BUT I HAVE GREAT FAITH IN US
GIVEN THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
TODAY THAT WE WILL.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK TOMORROW I WOULD ANTICIPATE.
I WELL WE WE WILL CONVENE AT TEN
AM TOMORROW.
I ANTICIPATE TO BE HERE UNTIL
THREE PM.
ARE WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
ARE FROM WELL FED.
AND WILL GET THROUGH ANOTHER DAY
OF OF SERIOUS SENATE BUSINESS
[inaudible]
AND THERE WERE THE REASON OF
COURSE THANK YOU MADAM BUDGET
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR -- IT WE
ARE WE ARE I CAN'T ADD
ADJOURNING TOMORROW AT THREE SO
THAT OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE.
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK THE REST OF
THE DAY I AND CONCLUDE OUR OUR
BUSINESS -- FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO WITH THAT -- WE
WILL RECONVENE TOMORROW
WEDNESDAY AT TEN AM.
AND I HOPE YOU HAVE A RESTFUL
AND GOOD EVENING THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM.
THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED WE
RECONVENE TOMORROW WEDNESDAY AT
TEN AM